[Music]
okay you're all set go ahead
representative
Pearson of the house health human
services and elderly Affairs committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order 12
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically some committee members
are participating in this meeting from
the Legislative Office building this is
a public hearing on bills referred to
the house Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee it may be
followed by an executive
session please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting
platform and that the public has access
to listen
contemporaneously and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91 Abby anyone
who has a problem accessing the meeting
should call
HCS
l.
state. NH do
us in the event the public as a whole is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us would you introduce yourselves
please uh Christina Dyer from house
committee
Services thank
you please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
vote we will start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance when each member
states his or her presence please also
State whether there is anyone else in
the room with you during this meeting
law Marsh representative
Marsh yes this is representative Marsh
I'm here I'm home alone in my home
office in
Brookfield representative
McMahon I'm
here representative Nelson here in my
basem in Brookfield
alone representative
Aton good morning I'm here my daughter
is homeschooling in the other room but I
on
gay representative kushman present
representative Fon present
representative
Kelsey I'm here in my home office in
Bedford my husband and daughter are in
another area of the
house representative
King he's trying to find his way into
the
building okay we'll come back to him
okay representative
Cal yes I am here in my home office in
Wilton and uh there are other people who
may be passing through uh but I am uh I
am alone in the room right
now representative Weber I here in the
committee
room M
snow he's currently
muted oh he just he just signed in but
he's currently
muted Ken un
you are you home
alone no my wife is in the
vicinity
represent yes I am here in my house in
Freedom in my study my wife will be
leaving for work some point but she's in
other area of the house okay
representative Salway representative
Salway is uh present home in his office
with only a dog and wife in the house
but not in the
room representative
Canon I'm uh in my home in summersworth
alone representative
NE um hello I'm here I'm in my home in
nashwa there's another family member
house
Keen representative
wood uh good morning uh yes I'm here at
my home in B New Hampshire I'm in my um
study by myself but my wife is
someplace else in the
house representative
Merchant yes good morning I'm here in my
house in clont and my wife is somewhere
else in the
house thank you um representative King
here and representative
friends
like to start the hearing on House Bill
34 to Homestead food operation license
and I'm looking for represent yes to
V good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee this is uh for the
record my name is Hershel Nunes I'm the
state representative from Hillsboro
District 37
towns of Pelham and Hudson I live in
Pelham and by the way I'm at home alone
in my home office um uh today I'm here
to uh to talk to you about HB 314 which
is relative to the homestead food
operation
licensure uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh as we learn to navigate
through our meetings and our sessions
during this challenging time I think
it's really important to remember those
of our constituents who are struggling
to make in Meet
uh we want to continue to find ways to
lighten regulations and requirements in
order to help them become more
successful uh first off uh I want to
apologize because I did find two small
word errors in the bill but I have
already submitted an amendment to the
office of legislative Services uh and
that amendment should have been emailed
out I emailed it to you Mr chairman this
morning uh just a few minutes ago uh I
received it I received it last night
late uh if you would like for me to go
over those changes for the amendment I
can or I can continue on down the bill
with your instruction I'll do whatever
you
chair is representative
Woods
uh Mr chair yes uh uh I am and perhaps
others as well are having some
difficulty hearing people in the
committee room uh sometimes it's not
loud enough and I'm I'm not I'm not
catching all that's transpiring there uh
is there any way to to alter that that
representative thank you
um someone from home is saying he's
having difficulty hearing the members
presence in the committee and we who are
physically present are hearing some
gargled are texting me and Christina Dia
is getting an expert to make us in the
are
Mr chair could I ask perhaps that uh
representative Nunez would reward that
amendment to us I've just looked in my
mailbox and I can't find it so if you
could send it to the hhsa committee then
we can have it to look at
contemporaneously you could do it right
now while we're
waiting certainly I'll get that done
of
arrived hearing now and should come down
but I don't
see
you uh FL tells me that they have not
seen Amendment yet
from OS but calling now to have extent
over and when they do they'll make
copies and run them down to us
here thank you Mr chairman and I did
just email uh that Amendment to the
committee to make sure that everybody
would receive it as
you would you like for me to continue
with the with the bill Mr chairman or do
you want me to
wait I would suggest you continue hoping
that they're working on the various
problems it just gets to the point where
we cannot hear you
suspending the uh yes thank you Mr
chairman uh what I will say about the
amendment it just changes a couple of
words in the bill there were some words
that were omitted uh so I'll continue on
uh with the introduction of the bill uh
and I apologize for the confusion Mr
chairman and members of the
committee in this bill that I'm offering
the committee today I'd like to talk
about changing a few lines of the
current statute that will allow
homesteaders uh or those who live in
their own homes on their own land to be
able to make and create and produce food
products to be able to sell from their
homes and other places such as farmers
markets or Farm stands retail food
stores and including by mail orderer
over the Internet making these food
types of producers exempt from
lure uh I want to talk a moment about
why the bill is important um Mr chairman
members of the committee selling
homemade food is an important source of
income for Farmers for stay-at-home
parents for the disabled and others who
need or want to work from home when
other states have expanded their
homemade food laws thousands of new home
businesses were created and this bill
will help the economy uh selling
homemade food is especially important
during the pandemic when many find
themselves out of work in other states
for example out of work chefs and
restaurant workers have been able to
sell homemade food to help make
meet consumers love buying fresh and
local food from their community and
people should have the choice to buy
homemade foods this bill is about
individual individual freedom and
Economic
Opportunity Mr chairman what the bill
does is it changes restrictions and
brings New Hampshire up to speed with
the best practices in other states
homesteaders no longer will need a
license to sell shelf to sell shelf St
stable
Foods as long as you're just selling
shelf stable foods you can sell directly
to Consumers online and to retail stores
with no license
required this bill also gets rid of the
sales
cap Most states do not have a sales
cap and if you do not have a if you do
have a license you can sell perishable
foods and meals and aifi or canned foods
but that is only with the license that's
things such as pickles or
relish and the only restriction is that
you can't sell meat or seafood or
alcoholic
beverages now New Hampshire's current
law uh 49 states allow the sale of
homemade food but our law is very
restrictive compared to other states
homesteaders have to deal with a lot of
red tape and
restrictions
homesteaders need to get a burdensome
license if they want to sell online or
to retail shops or over $20,000 in gross
sales and $20,000 can be very low after
subtracting for ingredients and other
expenses homesteaders are left with only
a few thousand dollars left in profit
and even with the license homesteaders
can only sell shelf stable Foods also
known as foods that are not potentially
hazardous you can't even sell simple
perishable foods like cheese cake or
pizza or mac and
cheese you also can't sell aifi foods
like
pickles now in this bill we've added a
section five it has to do with poultry
and poultry products and in this bill
they can be sold if the homestead
Slaughters no more than a thousand
poultry raised by the homestead food
operations during the calendar year if
the homestead operation does not sell
products bought elsewhere meaning they
must be raised by the homestead
operation
and the product is unadulterated and
col4 also we add a section six this bill
also prms any local government
regulations prohibiting and regulating
production and sale of homestate food
producers making it a bill for the
state Mr chairman in times like these
living in a pandemic many many folks are
trying to find ways to increase their
household Revenue uh their
income many have exhausted the ability
to stay on unemployment and many
businesses are struggling just to keep
their doors open the supply chain has
been broken but locally we can fix part
of that and as we do it without
punishing the homesteaders with
regulatory fees and Licensing costs on
food products that are deemed safe by
any other
means of course Mr chairman the labeling
will still need to occur uh directions
for how and when to use and ingredients
all of that stays in place and for
anyone who wants to sell any food
product that could be be deemed
hazardous the product still needs to be
licensed for sale under RSA 143
A4 should I say RSA 143 d a
colon4 Mr chairman that's my
presentation to the committee I'll take
any
questions all right before that
Christina d in this
meeting yes I am okay I attempted on
several occasions to stop the
representative from testifying and he
kept going which leads me to believe
somehow I was
muted uh well you weren't muted but we
did not pick up the sound um I have
reached out to our um our Tech person I
just they haven't come yet and I thought
I shouted no we didn't hear it I
apologize Mr chairman I didn't hear you
I thank you we were wondering if perhaps
moving these
microphones closer to the people who are
actually speaking my he I didn't I don't
know if that's okay or
not any as long as they don't did did
you try this uh gock microphone Mr
chairman did I try it no but I'd love to
okay somebody must have moved it that's
we put that to the cham right
wow with an onoff
switch
off okay how's this for sound
check I can hear
you yeah it's better when it's on right
yes and if a few of us could just say
random things uh to see if the home can
hear us
things my family doesn't like me saying
random
things that are supposed to be saying
the random things if we can start
perhaps with Jim yeah hi I'm Jim McKay
and I live exactly one
mile
Lucy Charlie McMahon Mark
Pearson bet gay kushman
okay Jeff
Salway Ben
Merchant jary
Mar Nikki
Kelsey Joe
Woods Jim
Cannon D
Nelson
we've heard that the um Prime sponsor
introduces Bill
314 and now comes the next learning
questions how do I do that how do I know
who is ask wants to ask a question I can
see people how about if we have our hand
up okay well I have can't see that
unless somebody shows me all right
representative
kerk okay um May I proceed then with a
question representative Nunes yes please
ask your question okay um thank you very
much I am a little bit confused when you
commented about your Amendment you said
it just changed a couple words but in my
mind it seems to change fundamentally
the entire point of the bill because the
bill uh we're dealing with the
exemptions from lure and the Bill had
that Homestead food operations selling
potentially hazardous food would be
Exempted your Amendment said if they're
selling food that is not potentially
hazardous and not is only one word but
it completely changes the entire meaning
of this bill what is it you're really
trying to
achieve uh thank you representative for
the question uh and I understand the
confusion there uh the the knot is what
was left out and that's what came in the
amendment uh it's just just a couple of
words but you're right it does
fundamentally change the bill as it was
drafted uh this amendment says food that
is not potentially hazardous that's what
we're looking at here food that is not
potentially
hazardous is that
on it's on the
amendment oh whoever is that one without
the
bill M representative if you'll let me
explain the the amendment for just a
moment Mr chairman may I do that yes
proceed uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh we found we found two
errors in the bill uh when we sent it to
OS it came back it it was it was small
so we missed it whenever we were going
over the bill and I do apologize for the
confusion on the original Bill if you
look at um at line three of the of the
original bill it says potentially
hazardous food the amendment changes
that to food that is not potentially
hazardous
food and then if you look in section two
on line
21 again it says potentially hazardous
food and we change that to food that is
not potentially hazardous those are the
only two changes
uh in the amendment uh against the
original
draft anyone else with a question
representative gay thank you thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
representative I I agree with the
representative caner that if you put the
knot in
there can or cannot sell I'm getting
mixed up on this double negative maybe I
thought the whole point was of this bill
was to allow the sale of potentially
hazardous food because it could spoil it
would not have to be shelf stable in
order to allow them to sell a whole lot
can thank you representative gay for the
question and uh let me clarify once
again we're we're talking about food
that is shelf stable that has a cap on
sales and that cap was currently set at
$20,000 uh we want to lift the cap for
food that is that is deemed not
potentially hazardous and to also allow
bill mac and cheese is
out yes prepared food is out except for
Pou Tre products
has thank you representative gay uh if I
understand your question uh poultry is
already allowed under uh
statute to be
sold this just adds this adds this into
this this bill to allow for up to 1,000
homestead okay uh representative Weber
please thank you Mr chairman um my
question is uh I had an email from
somebody who is very excited about this
bill because she said it would allow her
daughter to sell cheesecake is that
correct thank you representative Weber
for the question uh I'm sorry that is
not correct uh cheesecake is open aired
and the the only type of pies or
anything that could be sold or double
crusted as statute Ari
States and can I ask one follow up
please um
the could you explain to us where the
definition of shelf stable food is
because this is an
exception and I think when we look at
over at home we're going to need to know
where the definition of self self-stable
food is that's a great question
representative ever and I'm I'm
unfortunately I'm not able to answer
that for you but I will research that
and get it right back to the committee
if you could email that to us that would
be helpful and I'll retain other
questions until we've had a chance to
look at the bill a absolutely
representative I'll get that done for
you thank you uh representative Pearson
we have um some hands on the screen
representative snow representative Marsh
representative
Merchant uh we'll start with
representative snow
thank you Mr chairman I just wondered
we're saying you can sell poultry uh
which surprises me but no meat or meat
products but I'm wondering aren certain
Meats dried Meats um that are shelf
stable I forget what you call it but you
know dried out beef is certainly would
be I think meat to death is a shelf
stable because it can last forever is
that
conflict
thank you representative snow for the
question uh the way that I understand uh
the statute is that uh any type of meat
or meat products that are already
controlled uh under potentially
hazardous in which I think we're talking
about beef here things like that um that
still has to um stay within the current
RSA
143a uh colon 14 um we're we're only
allowing in this bill to add to add
poultry which is which is already
covered so we you know we'd like to move
forward with that we're not we're not
talking about meat or meat byproducts or
alcohol okay representative
Marsh uh thank you Mr chairman I uh
raised my hand for two reasons first of
all I wanted to demonstrate to people
including representative kerk who is
waving that there is a hand rais
function at the bottom of the zoom
screen and second of all I would like to
ask representative Nunes whether this
bill is in fact necessary because my
family has been able to buy numerous
farm rais products over the years uh
from local farms including grass-fed
beef pork uh chickens turkeys raw milk
and vegetables and this bill has not uh
obviously been put into law so I would
ask him to address that
question thank you very much
representative Marsh that's a great
question uh the way that I understand
what we're doing with this bill is we're
removing the cap which is a $20,000 cap
uh to allow for homesteaders who want to
create these types of products to be
able to sell more to help their families
uh in these times especially that are
trying but going forward we'd like to be
able to see this work out so that these
homesteaders uh can have a better access
to bringing in a little bit of extra
income for their for their families
especially since uh during during this
pandemic now we've seen all of our um
material prices go up uh people who may
can things or jar things or even buying
buying ingredients or using ingredients
off your farm everything is more
expensive now and we want to be able to
lighten the regulation on them a little
bit by removing the cap and then by also
allowing them to process poultry through
this
bill I thank you thank you very much sir
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman um
represent news I looked at the bill and
help me for clarification on the bill
that's proposed not the amendment but on
the bill on line 24 and
25 it says the sale through a retail
store is exemp from regulation which
you're proposing along with licens your
department departmental inspection
however if you go down to the next
section in section three it says at that
point in time they would have regulation
or control over it so I'm kind of
confused between the exemption of
Regulation but then the next section it
includes that they would actually have
regulation which includes potentially
hazardous food so we're looking to
strict say if it's non potentially
hazardous that's exempt or are they
exempt from
everything well they're not exempt from
anything if it's if it is a potentially
hazardous food that's already that's
already created in statute and it would
stay potentially hazardous food this is
about shelf stable food lighten up the
the um the regulation so that they may
be able to sell
more did I answer your question sir well
I'm looking at
it probably looking at the words if you
will but where it says or to retail food
stores on line 24 are exempt it's want
to be clear that we're exempting only
non-p potentially hazardous Boot and not
all exemption including corre
representative that is correct thank you
okay that's clarification and Mr
question yes please sorry thank you Mr
chairman in regards to the internet and
sales is this strictly for instate or
will include out of
state I I would think that it would it
would include anywhere that they may be
able to sell
to okay thank you representative McKay
thank you Mr
chairman
section six which is line 21 it seems to
me that that eliminates all local
intention I'm I'm not sure that I
completely understood what the
representative said could someone repeat
it for me the uh under line 21 on page
two which is the bottom of it it it's a
section that essentially says local
government has nothing to say about
this thank you representative for the
question that is true that this section
uh uh says that we will preempt any
local government regulations prohibiting
and regulating production the sale of
home state H Homestead food producers as
correct thank you representative Weber
does that mean that this preempts local
zoning
regulations
well that's that's a good question
representative Weber you keep stomping
me here um I will I will write that
question down and get that back to you
but as I understand the way we wrote the
Bill uh this makes us have one statute
for everyone in the
state may I have a followup yes you may
is in the room
statute preempt for example the city of
nasha's food regulations that's one
thing but as written it says this
section preempts any local government
regulations prohibiting and regulating
the production and sale of homes to
producers and uh zoning laws would
prohibit certain uses so that's what I'm
driving at would it Trump local zoning
LA and again you can just add that to
your list of things to get back to us on
thank you thank you
representative representative Pearson we
have several um hands up we have
representative Merchant representative
kerk and representative
Shapiro okay and uh I will first ask my
question and that is um the bottom of
page one line 27 the the strikeout is
$20,000 maximum it doesn't raise the
dollar amount it eliminates it and my
question is when does homestead food
business thank you Mr Mr chair for the
question um I I believe that that uh
again that's another question that I'm
going to have to answer for you uh get
an answer for you but
um I know that there are regulations
that are out there about how we form
small businesses and what those small
businesses are supposed to do and not do
um I will I will figure out that for you
and get that information back to you and
I apologize Mr
chairman you know we've seen a lot of
good things come out of the house where
there were a lot of questions asked at a
hearing like this and people did some
work on it and it turned out pretty fine
so uh this this is just the first step
thank you Mr chairman for your
understanding chairman ask a procedural
question yes of course thank you is this
a bill that might go to a
subcommittee uh it is and I I ask that
because it might be easier on people
asking questions if they know that some
of the word smithing might have another
opportunity and they don't have to get
everything down right now and that might
help us proceed more quickly thank you
for that voice of wisdom and
experience um okay representative
kerk thank you okay I am continually
stumped at what this bill is actually
trying to do and bear with me for a
moment um in statute RSA 143 A5 gives
the exemptions for
lure the exemption in seven and this is
in either the original bill or in uh the
amendment line three which strikes out
the annual sales the exemption currently
says that you are exempt from lure if
you sell less than
$20,000 by removing that you've actually
achieved precisely the opposite of your
goal that is you've said that everybody
even if they sell $10 worth of materials
would be subjected to
licensure
um is that not correct because you're
removing the exemption of the
cap I'm removing oh I'm sorry uh thank
you representative for the question
we're not removing the exemption for the
cap we're removing the
cap yes but but may I sorry follow up
yes but but you aren't removing the cap
because the cap refers to an exemption
if you are producing less than that
maximum amount you are exempt from lure
which is what um um 143 A5 is all about
those are the
exemptions by removing that I mean if
you go back to the statute itself 143 A5
it's exemptions the following
establishments shall be exempt from
departmental iure and then it gives us
laundry list one of which is Homestead
food sell operations that are selling
less than a maximum annual gross sales
by striking that language you have just
made them not exempt that representative
that's not the way that I understood it
but that's a very good point and if I'm
re if I'm redirected to over to that
stat statute we may need to amend uh
something else in order to make this
bill uh push through final
followup one more yeah just look at the
statute 143 A5 um which is what uh uh
Roman numeral 7 is extracted
from and I the answer would be remove
the striketh through because what you've
done is just the
opposite thank
you
representative Merchant I believe you
had your hand
up no Mr chairman you eloquently asked
the same question I was going to ask
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman and
excuse my ignorance on this but I am a
little bit unclear if we're talking
about
um I'm a little bit unclear about the
difference between licensure and
Regulation and is the intention of this
bill to take these exemptions and make
it
so a license is not necessary or is it
to change the regulations for people who
are going to continue to be
licensed thank you representative for
the question this is this is about those
homesteaders that are now currently
forced to get a license this remove this
allows as defined in the bill for them
to not have to get a
license thank
you we have a few other people who have
from the division of Public Health is uh
testify do we have Colleen Smith
Mr chair very quickly thank you for
allowing me to testify to the committee
you're welcome thank you for coming all
right I have yes yes I Y my line was
just unmuted thank you thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is Colleen Smith
I'm the administrator of the food
protection section the food protection
section is within the division of Public
Health Services of the Department of
Health and Human
Services um this due to this amendment
um it does change our testimony some
somewhat we had prepared some testimony
and submitted it to the committee in
advance um we do would still have some
concerns over uh the language around
poultry and poultry products is this
would still allow foods that we consider
potentially hazardous such as a chicken
pot pie to be allowed to sell without
the benefit of lure and and
inspection um currently we have 113
licensed Homestead food operations in
New Hampshire and um as as was stated
the reasons why they would be required
to be licensed is they um are either
offering Foods via the Internet to
restaurants to wholesalers or they gross
more than $220,000 in sales and to be
honest with you in our experience it's
not that dollar amount that's requiring
those folks to be licensed it's usually
because they are selling VI via the
Internet that's like that's usually the
most common reason why they're seeking
that lure and just want to point out the
um this license is an $150 annual
license it does come with an inspection
um where our one of our staff goes and
visits that home food manufacturer talks
to them about um sanitizing surfaces um
talks about General food safety um good
practices we talk about um if you have
pets securing them away from the area
sanitizing all food contact surfaces
um Etc so we definitely were concerned
about the expansion of potentially
hazardous foods that this the previous
version of this bill would have allowed
um but we do also I just want to point
out that poultry products would still be
considered um potentially hazardous so
that would be concerning and I'm happy
to answer any additional questions you
have about Homestead lure in general
thank you for letting me provide
it's your testimony that the amendment
to 314 mitigates some of your previous
testimony yes we had definitely had
serious concerns about the allowance for
expansion to potentially hazardous foods
uh the this would o we we recognize that
many home kitchens aren't equipped with
proper Refrigeration they're not requ
ired to have commercial equipment um
also when it comes to the production of
acidified foods there is food safety
knowledge that and and control points
that have to be hit to make sure that
food doesn't support um the the
claustrum botulinum that bacteria that
causes botulism so those those are have
always been considered high-risk
products um we have worked very hard
over the past years to come up with a
pathway for very lowrisk foods to be
made without a food license um and and
also there is um there is a provision
that consumers are aware through the
label that products are made in a
residential kitchen so we um again we
would not want to see this open up to
potentially hazardous foods such as the
poultry products that are mentioned in
um in the current bill if you
submitted a
revised testimony email to the committee
and I'm sure that we would appreciate it
and when this bill does go to a
subcommittee that'd appreciate it very
much uh does anyone have any questions
uh for Miss
Smith yes yes U chair recognizes
representative gay thank you chairman
thank you for taking my question
currently
currently poultry products are or are
not salable by
home home
businesses so the current regulation and
this is allowed by USDA is for whole
poultry to be offered from a person's
Farm their own um Farm Stand or Farmers
Market um with that thousand bird limit
if it's just the the poultry products um
can so if someone was to for example
make a a chicken pot pie that's where
our concern is so they're currently
Allowed by us to offer whole Birds only
but it's just the expanded products that
we don't currently
allow thank you representative kerk had
his hand
up thank you very much um thank you for
being here Miss Smith I had a question I
think you were there apparently then for
my questions about the amendment and I
am still confused about that question of
removing the cap from the exemption
actually means that
now that there any person will be
submitted and there is no longer an
exemption for the low volume producer is
that your understanding of this
amendment and
Bill so unfortunately I don't have a
copy of that Amendment so I would like
to um would take like to take a look at
that in context of the current statute
and and I um could comment to that after
that time followup please yes I I should
say actually in the bill itself the same
language was stricken um that is that uh
it strikes the and you knew that from
the initial bill online too where it
strikes the less than the minimum annual
grow sales but it just seems if you
remove an exemption you then make these
persons uh liable to uh having to
license no matter what sales they have
even if they're low volume sales they'll
they have to sell because they're not
exempt is that not correct it's the same
in the bill and the amendment for that
piece that I'm asking by the way corre
correct we were we were confused about
that in the original the language of the
original bill as well because it did not
um exempt out those that are currently
exempt from a license producing only
foods thank you and thank you for your
testimony uh the chair would now like to
recog ize Ross Conley who has signed up
to
speak and I've been informed it takes a
while for the computery things to make
that happen hello Mr chairman can you
hear
me we can hear you you're a bit garbled
oh I apologize I'll try to get a little
little closer uh everyone dealing with
uh this this new world in in Zoom
um uh so thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for holding
this hearing today uh for the record my
name is Ross Connelly I'm the deputy
state director for Americans for
Prosperity New Hampshire I'm here to
offer our support for
hb314 uh obviously there's some it
sounds like there's some issues that
need to be worked out with language of
the bill but in general we we we support
the intent of this
legislation uh in 2011 our state made
the decision to establish a two-tiered
system for selling homemade food
products uh for example if a single
mother decided to start selling homemade
cookies to make extra money she would
need to keep the total gross revenue
under
$20,000 and she would not be able to
sell in retail stores or online unless
she acquired a
license currently homemade food
producers in New Hampshire May sell
baked goods like Breads and cookies
along with candy Dry Goods pastries jams
jellies and snacks
SS uh the process to acquire a license
and the regulations needed to comply are
honorous and burdensome for low-income
entrepreneurs who are selling Goods that
have been deemed by definition and
limitation of what a homestead food is
to not be potentially hazardous food uh
if this product is not potentially
hazardous when it is produced under the
$20,000 limit it is not potentially
hazardous at $20,000
And1 this teed system quells
entrepreneurship and holds back Granite
Staters from growing their local
business out of their home our state
policy should remove uh focus on
removing barriers that are standing in
the way of citizens using their talents
to improve their lives their families
and their
communities as we understand it this
bill simply removes the requirement to
acquire a license when their homemade
products gross revenue exceeds
$220,000 and allows for that very
important retail and online sales the
limitations on what is deemed a
homestead food or what is potentially
hazardous does not change much outside
of of of the poultry uh provision with
this bill uh but the UN unnecessary
second tier of regulations will be
eliminated to make it easier for
homebased businesses to thrive and grow
and at a time when many Gran Staters uh
have been forced to work from home as
many of us are today uh and food
distribution has been deemed a an
essential service it makes all the sense
in the world to give these entrepr
entrepreneurs this uh needed regulatory
relief so uh with with these uh
grammatical changes we do urge the the
committee to recommend o to pass on on
hb314 and I'd be happy I I I have a
little bit of a time limit here but I'd
be happy to take any questions do any
Conley thank you sir for your testimony
thank you Mr
chairman the chair now recognizes Erica
Smith who is testifying also in favor of
this
Bill thank you for your time my name is
Erica Smith and I a senior attorney at
Justice a national nonprofit
organization that fights for individual
rights
I'm also a legal expert on homemade food
laws also known as cottage food laws and
I assist state legislators to improve
these laws
Nationwide uh before I get into my
testimony I did want to clarify some
confusion uh obviously the bill language
needs to be clarified but I could speak
to what the intent of the bill is
because I think there was some
misinformation uh the intent of the bill
is to if you you are just selling shelf
stable Foods you no longer need a
license but if you want to if you have a
license it will allow you to sell
perishable foods like the pot pie the
mac and cheese and the pizza uh I
understand that there's uh concerns from
Health the health department about this
but other states are already doing this
and it's working very
successfully um so with that
clarification I can get into my
testimony which will explain the bill a
little bit more and the reasons to
support so I encourage the committee to
support this bill for three reasons
first New Hampshire's current law is
very restrictive compared to other
states the bill fixes this and would
bring New Hampshire up to speed with
best practices second there are no
safety concerns with the bill and third
the bill would create thousands of new
small businesses so to start New
Hampshire's current law is very
restrictive right now it requires a
burdensome license if you want to sell
shelf stable Foods also known as not
potentially hazardous foods uh if you
want to sell these Foods online to
retail shops for more than the
$20,000 sales cap uh this is in contrast
to many other states which don't require
a license at all but still allow you to
sell these shelf stable Foods online and
to retailers the majority of States also
do not have a sales cap the bill
corrects these problems it eliminates
the license for most types of sales and
eliminates the sales cap
completely the other problem with the
current law that is that it banss the
sale of several types of foods like
perishable foods perishable meals and
acidified foods like pickles in recent
years several states have changed their
laws to allow the sale of these Foods
these states include Wyoming Utah North
Dakota and California the bill would
allow New Hampshire residents to sell
these Foods as well I should note that
while most most of those states do not
require a license to sell perishable
foods uh hb314 does require a license
for those foods but you could still use
your home kitchen and that's the
essential part so with or without a
license though health concerns are
almost non-existent people are already
legally selling homemade foods in 49
States including in this one yet we've
yet to find a single report of someone
getting sick that's probably prob
probably because homemade food
businesses are generally very small
operations and their owners have their
names and reputation at stake finally
hb13 would help thousands of people
support themselves their families and
their farms at The Institute for justice
we' have studied the economic effects of
these laws and they're impressive for
example after Minnesota eased its
restrictions on homemade food 3,000 new
homemade food businesses were registered
and Texas saw a similar development
after it eased up its
restrictions additionally studies show
that lower income women living in rural
areas are the most likely to benefit
from these laws which is great because
they don't have a lot of other economic
opportunities this bill would also help
chefs restaurant workers and others
start homade businesses during the
pandemic while they're out of work also
benefiting our stay-at home parents
people with disabilities Farmers
military spouses and retirees all people
who want or need the flexibility to work
from home in conclusion I urge the
committee to support the bill and I'm
happy to answer any
questions are there any questions
representative
Weber I'm just wondering and this is
something we could tell from a pink card
but I don't know how much of the pink
card information our clerk has are you a
New Hampshire resident or are you test
testifying on behalf of a National
Organization I'm testifying on behalf of
a National Organization uh I am the only
legal expert that I know of on homemade
food losss and can I ask where you're
located I'm work I'm located in Virginia
um my that's where my organization is
headquartered but we have offices across
the country than you thank
you anyone else a
question thank you for your testimony we
have two people left and I'm going to
ask uh Peter
Bixby sorry representative Peter Bixby
sorry representative I
know um Can Am I am I audible you are
okay so for the record I'm
representative Peter Bixby straford
District 17 in Dober New Hampshire and I
am the ranking member of the House
environmental and agriculture
committee and uh I have been uh involved
with a number of uh small changes to
this law uh since I became me uh uh
representative in uh
2012 uh and uh so I'm I'm fairly
familiar with the history of it uh the
purpose of the uh exemption is
essentially to make it possible for uh
people who are either hobby producers or
who are just getting started to uh get
started without the Burden Burden of a
license uh the cap on this bill the the
uh sales cap was originally 10,000
$10,000 uh in um I believe it was 2014
we raised it to
$20,000 uh originally one was not
allowed to sell to retail establishments
uh we made we uh we made possible to
sell to retail establishments in
2015 uh because uh there were a there
were people who wanted to be able to uh
produce their products and then sell a
sell at someone else's Farmstand or at a
small local business uh so we have uh
essentially made the made it more uh
permissive as time goes on uh but the
the point of the cap is that if you are
producing Beyond a certain level you
need to actually have a better a larger
uh operation a larger capacity which is
often not available in a home kitchen uh
so
uh in order to uh make sure that people
are uh produ are producing an
appropriate uh situation or appropriate
setup uh We've we think that the lure
makes sense Beyond a certain production
level uh and that's consistent with what
with the testimony we've heard over the
years from uh Health and Human Services
I was initially very concerned about
this bill because of it looked like it
was going to be allowing hazardous food
or potentially hazardous food and uh
with the amendment that that problem has
been been eliminated um I would
recommend rather than eliminating the
cap alog together go with what we
actually passed in our committee last
year which was to raise the cap to
35,000 which took into account an
increase in the cost of
ingredients uh and uh I'm glad that the
uh the pro the CRI sponsor was not
intending to allow meat under this uh
because that is potentially hazardous
and also is uh regulated by federal law
uh in ways that we don't want to get
into as for the poultry end of things uh
we actually have uh the most permissive
poultry sales uh legis uh laws that we
can under federal law already in RSA 427
2A Roman 3 sorry so kind of wrapping up
the first
B do you
understand am I am I am I talking too
quickly uh point of order Mr chair would
you please tell representative snow to
mute his microphone oh thank the
lorda snow you must mute we can hear
everything you're saying
thanks okay so um do I need was I
audible do I need to repeat anything oh
you're good you're very good okay
so um so uh so I would recommend that
the poultry part of this be struck
because uh
anything uh because basically we already
have the maximum amount of uh permission
possible under federal law for uh home
for Homestead sales of poultry under 427
colon 2 uh and I would recommend rather
than completely limiting the cap raising
the cap to
35,000 and so when someone gets to that
level it really makes sense for them to
be able to to to be inspected and to get
the advantage of advice from the
Department of Health and Human Services
food protection um as to what other
states do I'm not I haven't done a
thorough sample of all other states I do
have a friend who is doing home uh
Homestead production in Maine and she
was actually very surprised that New
Hampshire didn't require any lure uh at
at a low level uh she is producing well
under what our
um our $20,000 cap and she was Rec
required because she was doing it at all
in Maine to get inspected and it was and
she found that inspection actually
rather helpful because she got good
advice in terms of uh practice you good
practices um I think that uh our our
exemption for that low level makes sense
I think that once you get up to a
certain level uh the license the $150
license with inspection if uh you are
producing over $35,000 worth is a
relatively small business expense and uh
it makes sense to uh maintain that uh
lure at that at that level and
representative gay thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
representative Bixby um at what point do
people have to have
um kitchens that satisfy requirements
like triple sinks
Etc uh the um I I don't I'm not
thoroughly versed in the um
in in the uh food protection um
regulations I think that uh uh um
Colleen Smith from food protected
services could probably uh provide a
better answer for that uh but in terms
of uh when you are required to have
certain equipment it is certainly is not
you are not required to have that below
the cap level and it is possible in uh
that a home kitchen could be
sufficiently equipped uh for the to get
the license even if um without any
without major Renovations you don't need
to you even even even at the licensed
level uh you are talking about a home
kitchen you are not talking about a
commercial
questions representative bxby and once
again apologies for not calling you
earlier thank
you and the final one to uh bring
McLoud can you hear me now
yes uh yes uh thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the
opportunity to testify um there's been
uh obviously a big change in this bill
this morning
um and I'm testifying uh for the record
I my name is Thomas mlar I live in
Mountain Vernon uh my wife and I uh
would like to have a um homebased uh
food production business um currently
we're experimenting with different
products um as I understand it uh and I
haven't seen the uh amended language as
I understand that this bill would would
allow us
to uh use our home kitchen for uh
fermented uh certain fermented foods uh
which we would not be able to uh do
Under the uh under exist existing law um
I had prepared um more things to say uh
regarding the original language um but
since that apparently has been
struck uh I'm going to leave it at that
and uh we we as I understand it we I do
support the bill in the current form uh
and I think there's more work to do on
it and with that I'll uh end my
testimony thank you Mr McLoud and with
that I am bringing to a close this
hearing I will name a subcommittee which
is neither of the two big subcommittees
all of you signed up for but because
this is sort of a different thing Al
together and while I have everybody's
attention just to let you know future
meetings of this committee I was told
yesterday will be on the 1st of February
we already know that it's been noticed
that's a Monday and then Tuesday the
second of
February and then the 8th of February
which is also a Monday and after that
they're still working it
out so could we take about a minute and
a half stretch and breathe break before
over because you can do that you ask for
the expertise of another
commit
M be careful of the
sir don't do that you can do that
yes
Mr chairman can you hear
me we can hear you can Mr chairman is oh
yes he is I'm sorry may I apologize to
the committee I I attempted to mute
myself when I had a call from the
speaker's office and I had to take it
and I thought I muted myself but I was
already muted So I unmuted myself I
apologize representative snow we
understand believe me I'm sorry we
stuff as long as we have you here you
know what you could do is keep yourself
muted all the time and when you want to
speak just hold down the space bar on
your
keyboard oh I didn't know that oh
okay Ken that's what I do that's that's
a good way to do it all right I didn't
know I didn't know that was an
option time to discover it in some
embarrassing
moments so you keep the space bar down
if you hold the space bar down it you
and then when you let it out
to yeah when when you're muted the space
bar becomes a push to talk
button
okay okay we are back and this one I
quicker this yeah house build
378 from our very own committee
representative Dennis Aton to present
the
bill okay good morning everyone thank
you for your time um we have uh House
Bill 378 which is uh repealing the
therapeutic use of cannabis advisory
Council let me give you a little B bit
of background in why this uh we're
trying to do this um after the bill was
passed uh the therapeutic cannabis law
was passed um there was a a desire to
bring together a team of stakeholders to
provide advice and consult to the
Department of Health and Human Services
as they created the program basically
from scratch uh it was uh the law um
tasked
to okay so the law the law um testy
Council providing uh four different
points one is to assist Health and Human
Service services and and adopting the
rules two to collect info as required in
the bill uh three to make
recommendations to legislature on the
rules and possible changes to law and
four uh within five years make a
recommendation to the success of the
program and whether the bill or whether
the law should be continued or Sunset um
the the council met 15 times between
2013 and 2018 and did a lot of really
good work in helping healthy Human
Services to uh create the rules for
selecting and U helping the alternative
centers to find locations and and all
the rules um that were involved in that
and um then finally in
2018 the um the council issued a an
advisory that the uh the pro there were
no problems with the um operation of the
therapeutic cannabis program and they
issued the the the uh an opinion that
the program should continue so uh in
essence we look at it is that they they
have accomplished the goals of the
original legislation and therefore we're
looking to repeal it now what what has
happened is that we now have the medical
oversight board which is active and um
providing consult uh to our committee
and and to health health and human
services on uh the next phase which is
dealing with the med the medical
conditions that are allowed and so forth
so we feel that the uh the therapeutic
use of Canabis advisory Council has
accomplished its Mission and therefore
should be struck from the original Law
and that's the goal of this legislation
thank you very much representative I'm
going to move immediately to call on
representative
McKay who can bring some history and
perspective to this sir than you Mr
chairman um would you
believe that I was chairman front of
that commission for five years it was
essential and representative act has
done a great job and and uh was uh
positive and hasn't always been positive
the comments about our organization it
had some very diverse
populations essentially we were to work
to advise the Department of Health and
Human Services about the beginning and
structural steps to start the medical
marijuana
program U representative Nelson was also
a member of
that commission u in essence to make
this very brief that we've done our job
uh the medical marijuana program is
strong and moving along and and
developing uh there is no need for the
advisory committee to continue to
particular because the the committee
that representative coner is I don't
know if he's chairman or vice chairman
is dealing with the treatability issues
which are very complicated as to whether
or not medical marijuana is useful for
certain kinds of conditions so that's in
very good hands uh so therefore I
strongly support that uh we uh support
this legislation and put that committee
to rest thank you representative McKay
the memo that uh the chairs get from
DHHS um indicates the Department of
Public Health says this cannabis
advisory Council has fulfilled its
purpose and the agency is fine with the
bill repealing it is there anyone who
needs to testify
on
this with that I'm going
to's hand up
and no sorry you missed missed the time
session which means we vote on it
represent okay
um uh Mr chair can I can I make a
motion uh
yes okay um I would like to move that we
uh we accept and pass U House Bill 378
through our committee as in
OTP about to pass yes I second second I
am going to give to representative McKay
because of his years of service I would
be glad to
absolutely like
so representative McKay second
representative Acton
moves all right when you are ready Madam
clerk you may call the
rooll representative Marsh VES
yes representa McMahon yes
representative Nelson
yes representative gay yes
representative kushman
yes representative pson yes
representative Kelsey
yes representative King
yes representative
copal
yes representative Weber yes
representative McCay yes representative
snow
yes
yes representative Solway
yes representative
Canon
yes representative n up
yes representative
Shapiro
yes
representative Woods
yes representative
Merchant yes representative the chair
Mark Pearson
yes okay uh
21 y zero NOS on to the consent calendar
with
it thank you did it thank you that's how
bipartisanship works right
there
okay I now close the exec session and
open the session on the hearing on House
Bill
131 I think yeah relative to reporting
of Health Care Associated infections and
representative woodmar committee is the
prime sponsor would you introduce the
bill sir uh thank you Mr chair uh yes
I'll um this is very straightforward
again um I'll be very brief and
summarize as there's several people from
the affected agencies that can provide
technical details if
necessary uh in essence uh this brings
um uh the testing and Reporting up to
datee um uh and also uh revises uh the
standards by which uh measures uh are
examined um specifically uh the um some
of the tests some of of the uh reporting
that's done uh is done to make sure that
the particular facilities either
hospitals Day Surgery centers nursing
homes uh meet certain standards um and
once they reach those standards which
they have have done in this particular
situation relative to uh central line
practices and surgical antimicrobial
prophylaxis uh then it's no longer
needed to report uh both the uh
infection rates and the process by which
they're monitoring it uh this bill um
would uh change that such that uh the uh
uh appropriate uh reviews still look at
these excuse me still look at these
issues which are important uh but the
reporting they don't have to report uh
sort of the protocols if you like uh so
that it's a simpler administrative
process for them uh and relieve some of
the administrative burden um uh the uh
uh uh second part of the bill uh brings
it up to date in terms of uh identifying
the appropriate agencies CDC
CMS um hospital and um reporting systems
uh the National Quality Forum uh that
are uh appropriate for the particular uh
Day Surgery Center hospital nursing home
uh uh agencies that oversee them and it
brings them up to those standards and
identifies that those are the standards
that will be met um the only other thing
that it adds is that um you'll see uh at
the uh in section four uh uh reporting
infections it adds measures um and
that's again just consistent with what's
uh the reporting process is now across
the board um finally uh at the uh line
28 uh they you'll notice that there is a
strike out of accreditation of
healthcare organizations uh that's the
the new name for the Joint Commission
which most of us in the medical area are
quite familiar with For Better or For
Worse um uh one just uh last uh sidebar
uh you'll notice that on line 30 it says
New Hampshire Health Care quality and
safety commission uh notice that it's
the uh uh item is not capitalized I was
advised by OS uh that federal agencies
are capitalized state agenc or not uh so
um I I learned something there so
basically this is just bringing uh up to
dat uh the uh reporting uh criteria uh
and the U agency and federal agencies uh
that provide the standards by which
those reportings will be
reviewed um so in a sense um it's um
just bringing things up to date uh and
again reassuring that the healthcare fa
facilities really are meeting the
standards we expect uh for our citizens
in New Hampshire thank you you prepared
to take questions
representative uh I'll try but again
there are I think there are some folks
if there are real technical issues I'll
have to defer
okay representative gay thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um it sounds like this is a
housekeeping uh Bill to bring us up to
current Uh current procedure and current
reporting excuse
me I just have one question about what
the wording means the coverage rates of
influenza vaccination for Health Care
Personnel does that mean like in this
Hospital what percentage of people have
taken the
shot uh uh that would be my
interpretation it says coverage rates uh
so my sense is that there that the
facility then would have to look at that
issue of how many do in fact have that
particular um um
vaccination follow follow up uh so is
that a a federal requirement they try to
track it would fit with that I'm not
sure how the databases uh are U are
interfaced uh that gets very complex uh
but um I'm I know that they do I just
don't know how uh they're interfaced
perhaps someone else can ask answer that
more
technically Mr chairman representative
up representative
Marsh thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you uh representative Dr Woods it's a
pleasure hearing you again on this issue
uh and and I would like you to clarify
some things for me it's my understanding
that the continuous quality improvement
initiative that the the hospitals
participate in including my Hospital of
which I am a trustee uh began with a
number of measures which hospitals
overall were rather deficient in
including the two measures that you're
striking here the adherence rate of
central line insertions and surgical
antimicrobial prophylaxis and that those
initiatives resulted in the hospitals
now universally Meeting those standards
and by the original idea it's time to
remove those standards and replace them
with new ones so that we achieve the
goal of continuous quality improvement
am I correct in that well no I I think
there's a misunderstanding if you look
at the RSA it doesn't re remove the
reporting okay that those are still
reported it's just that they actual have
the the part that's being removed as as
it it says it's uh they report the
process
measures so if you look at just above in
the original RSA 151 uh colon 30 3 uh a
uh 2A it says though there will still be
reported so we'll still be able to
monitor it so those will be just
reported as numbers but the hospital
doesn't have to provide the uh U overall
processing that they used to uh address
that
issue follow up Mr chairman follow up
yeah is it not true that those two
measures are no longer the measures on
which hospitals are scored under cqi
uh I can't tell you the details about
the the numbers I do know that the
numbers and the uh following these are
are quite high and U there there are
people that provided testimony to the
committee that provided the numbers and
it's up in the
98% uh level of uh compliance uh with
these uh and um with this process uh so
it is has been quite good been as you
noted has been very successful um and
and uh so uh again it's just uh removing
the ACT additional administrative part
of of demonstrating the process besides
just the numbers yes and thank you and
Mr chairman one last followup please go
ahead is it true that this bill makes no
change whatsoever in the reporting about
influenza vaccination
correct I thank you any technical
questions be held because we will have a
speaker in a minute who will be able to
address them but first I would like to
call on Laura Condon who signed up as a
member of the public to oppose the bill
L cond non techical question of
Representative yes go ahead uh just one
further non-technical question am I
right in thinking that this is the same
bill that we passed last year that's
correct exactly the same okay now Laura
okay am I unmuted
now yes hello okay this is Laura Condon
speaking because I he I heard another
voice it wasn't me so um all new here
with this technology so thank you very
much uh Mr chairman and committee
members for the opportunity to speak to
this bill today and what I would like to
say is I very I well I'm Laura Condon
from Bedford um I would like to say that
I appreciate the efforts to track and
control Hospital acquired infections we
know that hospitals and other medical
facilities are germy places if you will
um where many people who enter such
facilities uh without infections
thereafter acquire infections and this
is uh a national problem that you know I
appreciate we all appreciate the
attention to um mitigate that I would um
bring to the attention of the committee
that this is a bill um similar to a bill
that was introduced last year the bill
that was introduced last year was House
Bill uh
1246 what this bill does is it adds
language and that bill was defeated what
this bill does is it adds language which
is concerning and that's why I speak
today um I recognize that um that there
still will be recording requirements for
certain mitigation efforts and infection
measures I mean infection rates but what
concerns me is the added language of
measures measures is actually not
defined in this statute but the way that
it's written it certainly would lead you
to believe whatever measures are taken
to mitigate infections um including
because it's listed is influenza
vaccination and so by the language of
the this law that would include any
other measures that might fall under
vaccination now being is required to
required to be tracked and
reported and so the concern here to me
is that this measures language added um
would include the tracking and reporting
of all vaccination measures not just the
one itemized here because has taken away
itemizations and adding in this broad
language which essentially could result
in a backdoor vaccine um tracking and
Reporting registry somewhere gosh knows
where it goes to these Federal databases
of uh Hospital uh healthcare workers
patients and residents an involuntary uh
tracking and Reporting System so for
that reason that added language was not
there last year um I was not concerned
with the bill last year I do have these
concerns now with that additional
language and so for that reason I do ask
that the committee uh please oppose this
Bill thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak thank you Miss gon
I will next go to I know there's people
who had hands up and we'll be getting
back to you I'd next like to call on
Paula minahan from the the Hampshire
Hospital
Association friend of some standing of
this
committee
good morning Mr chairman can you hear me
yes great thank you and good morning and
members of the committee my name is
Paula minan for the record senior vice
president of state government relations
with the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
communities um 26 hospitals as well as
specialty hospitals the hospital
Association is in strong support of
House Bill 131 um with me today on um on
the phone is Anne defendorf the
associate executive director of the
foundation for Healthy Communities Vice
and vice president of patient safety and
quality here at the association and
Foundation um and she can answer any
technical questions and I would I will
defer to her in a minute um I do want to
thank representative Woods for
introducing this bill in it its exact
form um I just wanted to state that for
the record this is as representative
Weber indicated the same exact language
that was passed in the committee last
year and thank you representative Woods
for reintroducing it it did pass your
committee it passed the Full House and
it actually was heard in the Senate But
ultimately did not get signed into law
because as you know um due to the
pandemic with the um Omnibus Senate
bills um this this this was used as a
vehicle last year's Bill and ultimately
was not was not signed into law had
nothing to do actually with this bill um
we worked with the department and
representative woods and the committee
last year to um get the bill that you
see in front of you this year um passed
um so again um the department was HHS I
believe they are available to to answer
any questions as well and I am going to
defer um to Ann defendorf at this point
because um she really is the one that
works with our quality directors at the
hospitals um in our infection control um
Specialists um to answer any particular
questions but I just want to be on the
record indicate this was the exact same
language we went word for word to make
sure there were no changes to make it um
easy for easier um to understand that
this was we were just reintroducing the
same bill um could I ask an to raise her
hand if that would be acceptable to the
chair and so that she can um also
testify go
ahead
hello this is
an you hear
me okay um I just wanted to reference in
terms of some of the questions earlier
with regard to the measures that we
asking to be removed one is the surgical
Care Improvement project those were
measures that are no longer reported
anywhere they were considered obsolete a
few years ago because they were so based
in strong evidence that there were no
questions of people adhering to them and
the other one the central line insertion
practices is no longer reported anywhere
and they're again strongly embedded in
hospitals will you take
question
question thank you my my question is
actually uh rep uh directed to
representative woods so Mr chairman I
don't know if you'd like me to ask that
now or wait well I'm going to bring
representative Woods back because I uh
moved a little too quickly from
representative woods and couldn't see
Hands in the top of my screen so yes uh
representative Woods if you would uh be
willing to take some questions more
questions yeah sure I'll I'll do my best
representative kofalt you may
proceed so um yeah so so this Echoes a
comment that was made in testimony a
moment ago um by uh by a previous uh
person I guess my my concern is the
language in section three which appears
to essentially defer State oversight of
U of some of these metrics and hand that
over to uh to
to Federal and quas governmental
authorities and I guess my concern there
um is is that use of the word and or the
phrase and measures which I I think
opens us up to a pretty broad
um a a a pretty broad uh set of
potential requirements that are you know
that were never decided or overseen by
um by the state of New Hampshire U
legislature or executive branch so I'm
um I'm interested in hearing your
response to that why we've included
language that um that that you know
spells out specifically the the
technical advisers to be consulted I
have less of a problem with that I have
serious concerns about the latter
section um in in what has been described
as a as a kind of housekeeping measure
but um seems to be handing over uh quite
a bit of State um State Control to uh to
to agencies that are not elected or
accountable to New Hampshire uh to New
Hampshire voters can you respond to that
sure um I'll do my best but I think part
of it I would like to refer to an
deindorfer for part of it and I'll get
that in a second um in section there's
two parts section three um reference to
the Centers for Disease Control Etc uh
we're not turning over control to them
uh it's it's simply states that uh the
amator uh in consultation with technical
advisers in other words these are
standards that have been evolved over
the course of time at uh at one point U
many of the hospitals and many of the
states had their own criteria establish
their own criteria uh that became
somewhat honorous uh as medicine became
much more uh fractured fragmented
complex uh those standards uh became uh
harder to
identify um and as a consequence um uh
uh uh the different agencies uh turned
to uh other people that had expertise in
that realm again um that provided a
standard uh Across the Nation uh but
it's a as you'll not it this is not
turning over control to them uh but this
is indeed in in consultation with
technical advisers so um these are just
what when the state does this uh this is
only looking to them for advice um and
they may accept them as standards uh
after review um uh on on the second part
relative to measures um uh that I'm
going to turn that over to an deindorfer
if she's still about uh to really give a
a very firm uh definition of what
measures
mean um and uh the uh differentiation
between uh an entity of infection versus
a measure relative to an infection and
exactly what is reported and that may
clarify your for you so if I could uh
ask Ann if she's still
here an yes hello I am um I I think I'm
going to defer to the department around
the word of measures they were I'm
pretty sure they added that but I would
just say measures is a term that often
our regulatory agencies are using in
addition to specifics of rates and
infections so I think we just want to
make sure that the bill would allow
additional scientific and
evidence-based items that would be
included um and I think is Abby Rogers
that
thank you uh representative Merchant had
think thank you m thank you Mr chair
chairman um in regards to the data
that's being reported or
collected could you speak to whether
it's aggregated data which is patient
identified or is this individual patient
level what yeah uh I can't I can't stay
specifically about the character of the
data uh I do know that a lot of it has
been deidentified
um um uh maybe I'll ask them to step up
again I do know a a Department of Health
and Human Services is under uh currently
looking at new data platforms to bring
the the uh desperate uh areas uh so that
they can communicate uh and again one of
the Hallmarks is that it will be uh I
identified so that uh have more Comfort
level and meet Hippa standards in a
strict manner um but um maybe if if
someone from HHS is is on again they can
maybe ask uh or answer in a more
technical
manner is Abby Rogers
uh on this meeting yes she is Abby
Rogers could you
answer couple bring right on
please hi good morning this is Abby
Rogers legislative lay on um for dphs um
I actually wanted to let you know that
Katrina Hansen who is the chief of
infectious disease surveillance is
scheduled to testify on this bill and
she would be the best person to provide
the information that you're looking
for who is scheduled to testify uh
Katrina Hansen she's from the Infectious
Disease surveillance section she signed
up just to testify in the bill this
morning not on the witness list but I
will accept her as an expert witness
okay okay well we we we I thought she
was registered but uh she should be she
should be on and uh
on good morning members of the committee
and chairman my name is Katrina Hansen I
the chief of infectious disease
surveillance at the division of Public
Health Service Services thank you for
having me here today I did register so I
apologize maybe there's some sort of
technical issue on my end but I will
look to resolve that for future
testimony um I'm here today to provide
information and support HB 131 relative
to the reporting of healthcare
Associated infections if you prefer I
can answer some of those questions or I
can also provide my testimony and answer
those questions further on please advise
what you would
prefer well I think we're pretty much
coming to the end of this if you could
give some brief testimony take a few
questions would would appreciate it
great all right I will do that we also
submitted our written testimony which
also provides a little bit more detail
one of the questions was regarding data
we do collect data but this is an
aggregate form for measures I want to
let the members of committee know that
when it comes to various meas measures
such as health Healthcare Associated
infections um in influen of vaccination
rates it's in aggregate form some
measures are in individual form but it's
all deidentified through a CDC webbased
secure system and there it is in a way
that in a mechanism that you cannot
identify
individuals and I am going to provide uh
the rest of my testimony and a little
bit of background as well to these
measures if this if it will assist the
committee Healthcare associate infection
or Hai is an infection that a patient
acquires during the course of receiving
treatment for another condition in a
healthcare setting Hai cause estimated
722 th000 infections a year and 75,000
deaths in the us alone in acute
hospitals by these estimates hii are the
top leading 10 causes of death in the US
certain hais are required to be reported
by law in New Hampshire and in 2018
there were 197 such infections reported
to the New Hampshire reported in New
Hampshire hospitals hey excuse me uh
people are having trouble understanding
you could you speak a little more slowly
please oh sure is this better and clear
better all right I apologize thank you
for stopping me I appreciate
that Healthcare associate infections are
a leading cause of death in the US and
certain ones are required to be reported
to the Department New Hampshire by New
Hampshire hospitals and Ambulatory
Surgery centers in 2018 for context
there were
197 infections that we reported in
addition to certain infections hospitals
Ambulatory Surgery centers and dialysis
centers also have to report some
preventative measures put in place to
protect patients in this this is where
that measures piece within that bill is
is referenced to it's preventative
measures to prevent Healthcare associate
infections these include Healthcare
Personnel influenza vaccination surgical
care um antibiotic prophylaxis and
central line insertion practices in
hospitals um they report central line
assertion practices and surgical
antimicrobial prophylaxis under the
previously known surgical Care
Improvement project this bill seeks to
remove those measures um for several
reason reasons the clip monitoring
assesses key infection prevention
practices that occur during the
insertion of a central line such as
performing hand hygiene and wearing
gloves since the start of reporting of
this measure in New Hampshire hospitals
have improved and maintained High
adherence to recommended insertion
practices from 93% in 2008 to 98.3% in
2018 surgical antimicrobial prophylaxis
is the administration of antibiotics
prior to surgical procedure to prevent
surgical sight infections monitoring
appropriate administration of these
antibiotics was initially included in
the reporting law over 10 years ago
because all hospitals already had to
report this measure via the centers for
Medicare and Medicaid services through
the surgical Care Improvement project
DHHS collected data from CMS instead of
from hospitals directly however after
2013 CMS dis continued collection of
these data and hospitals are no longer
required to report this measure at the
federal level in the final year that
DHHS had access to these data Hospital
adherance to best practices with similar
or higher than National Data for all
98% for NE Hampshire um I can provide
more details for each of those measures
but for example um one of them measure
two
was uh yes uh representative kushman
thank Mr
chairman um thank you for my question um
although the data is collected in
aggregate it requires um the data on
individual healthare workers to be
collected by employee employers by
adding this broad term measures if the
CDC or one of the other agencies um
changes their recommendations and say
it's best practice to Monitor and track
vaccination rates of healthcare
employees for vaccines other than
influenza which is the only one that's
explicitly mentioned in this
statute could then and would like then
the department update their measures to
require New Hampshire facilities um to
track rates of other vaccinations be
workers and may I speak to this question
this is Katrina
Hansen so the right now the statute and
the and the rules specifically mentioned
influenza vaccination we are not
requesting access for other vaccination
information for healthcare workers so
right now it's solely influenza
vaccination for healthcare workers and
we're only requesting uh aggregate data
and then also for tracking of it not
requiring
it and we are go
ahead um well so my other question is
would you be willing to um miss this is
for Mr Woods I guess um to amend this
bill to clarify what measures are and um
to state that it does not it won't apply
to um other vaccination rates besides
influenza and healthcare workers unless
RSA I think we could I could um I could
consider those um in discussion with HHS
and see what implications that might
come of that um um so I wouldn't say I
would um categorically insert those or
take anything out uh without discussing
it to see what the ramifications might
be thank you any other questions
um
I've been told there's somebody else
who's not on the witness list and I will
allow um Courtney Tanner and uh would
ask you please to be brief are you for
or against the bill and if so why or why
not Courtney Tanner hi chairman Pi
Pearson this is Courtney Tanner I'm the
director of government relations at
Dartmouth Hitchcock and I would uh like
to yield my time to Alyssa Malcolm
Alyssa Malcolm is the director of
quality assurance and worked to craft
this bill last legislative session I
would really like her to have the
opportunity to testify if that's okay
dth Hitchcock is in support strong
support of this bill and she can provide
some practical information about this
bill
up uh good
morning um thank you for the opportunity
to testify uh today my name is Alissa
Malcolm I'm the director of value
reporting and analytics at dmouth
Hitchcock my role includes
responsibility for all of the external
Quality Reporting for Dart with back
including infection reporting to the
state of New Hampshire um additionally
since 2011 I've been a member of the
healthcare Associated infection
technical Advisory workg Group which
provides scientific and infection
prevention expertise to the hii program
um I spoke last year in support of this
bill so if my testimony today sounds
familiar is because I've provided it
before um I support hb31 not only does
it allow for the state to use the rules
process to stay current with
scientifically valid measures but also
reduces the reporting burden for
hospitals both the state and hospitals
have struggled for years on how to meet
the clip and Skip reporting requirements
as Katrina Hansen um mentioned a moment
ago clip um stands for central line
insertion practices and Skip stands for
surgical excuse me surgical Care
Improvement project and is a group of
infection
prevention over the the better part of
the last decade um in the technical
Advisory workg Group we've been talking
about how to address the concerns with
the clip measure both its weakness as a
metric and its time intensive nature to
report um it's a low value measure and I
I want to stress that the concept of f
is really good the idea of a bundle of
actions to prevent patient harm is
really important but I would argue that
what flip measures is our ability to
document what has become standard
practice for line and
Sur with skip BMS retired the measures
years ago nationally as mentioned the
measures had topped out meaning the
performance was so high and the
distribution so tight that meaningful
distinctions between hospitals could no
longer be measured hospitals cannot
continue to abstract measures when
definitions are not being maintained by
measurement science it serves neither
the citizens of New Hampshire nor the
hospitals whose performance is on
display this bill fixes the issues with
both of these measures furthermore
you'll note that they're both process
measures as as we've talked about a
little bit earlier they focus on the
steps in the process rather than the
outcome or the result of the care that's
provided for years Medicare CMS has been
placing heavy focus on outcome measures
and moving away from process measures HB
131 helps line the state up with CMS
current practices and allows the state
to be flexible as infection measurement
changes over time through alignment with
CDC CMS and the national
qu po form measures try to stop you now
we've got the gist of what you've had to
say we appreciate it um and I am going
to move on on this bill and suggest that
representative Woods considers input
particularly representative kushman's
question regarding the word measures and
representative Woods when you have done
the asking around you told us you would
be doing let me know please when the
bill will be ready to
exact uh thank you I will do that and
with that I'm closing the hearing on
this
Bill W only a half an hour
behind House Bill I'm introducing now
House Bill
mlan thank
yes
know
yes representative s sorry
representative McAn please introduce
your bill thank you chair and members of
the for my testimony my name is
representa from we can't hear well
enough speaking up you're gonna have to
speak up because you got your back to us
him
how's this work folks better better all
right just throw me your show me your
thumb down if I if I start to speak a
little bit too low um so again uh thank
you Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Mark mlan representing Hillsboro
District 44 which is H Southern
Manchester and the town of Lichfield I'm
here to speak on behalf of HB 290 which
is a short but I think important bill
that acts uh as an addendum to uh the
bipartisan direct Primary Care
legislation that passed in the last term
basically what it's doing is taking that
direct payment model that was in that
bill it's extending it to Health Care
Facilities it simply put it states that
if a health care facility chose to only
accept uh direct payments that was their
exclusive form of payment they would be
allowed to get out from under the
existing law which requires them to
accept all forms of payment
now many primary care doctors including
my own uh found that the bureaucratic
burden of sorting out payments was heav
heavy and and costly so those that
wanted to pursue Private Practice
outside of the hospital setting the
direct Primary Care model that we passed
allowed them to choose a path that ease
that burden and in many cases allowed
them to stay in private practice and
extending the direct payment model now
to healthcare facilities allows for
among other things an opportunity for
those providers to kind of band together
to provide uh an expanded canvas of
offerings and so those people that maybe
find Value in that direct payment model
uh with this they would have access to
even more services like uh lab testing
ultrasounds MRIs things of that nature
and I think it may even lead to an
increase in the services being offered
in the more rural areas of the state so
25 years ago um this is not the kind of
thing that really would have excited a
lot of patients um I know 25 years ago I
would never have looked at it I had
employer-based insurance and I was very
happy with that I got done what I needed
to get done I paid a small co-pay and I
moved on and I didn't even think about
it but today is a different day and my
deductibles are really through the roof
and I'm not alone New Hampshire has some
of the highest if not the highest
deductibles in the country and partly as
a result of that you're starting to see
a little bit of an increase in hsas I
don't think it's massive um but it is
growing and I'm seeing more and more
folks in the factory that I work start
to take that up as an option and when
you add in the gig economy where lots of
folks are starting to work for
themselves and then situations where
people are working multiple small jobs
to make ends meet and maybe don't have
the same kind of access to the employer
based plans and then I think the need
the legislation becomes more into Focus
so in in many cases the direct Primary
Care model that we passed gave folks a
predictable monthly expense and this
bill is going to offer some of that same
level of predictability for simple
procedures and other offerings and The
Upfront nature of the pricing really I
think creates incredible transparency
here coming outside of the reimbursement
model and that's going to allow
consumers to plan and more importantly
have confidence in their plan so in the
past that lack of confidence might have
led people to shy away from the care
that you know they might have had I
don't know what this is going to hit can
we really kind of go down that path but
with the passing of HB 290 a growing
number of of uh residents they're going
to have new options maybe some new
confidence and it might just work for
them so I hope that you will support
passage of HB
290 and that's my
testimony thank you very much
representative mlan are there any
him I'm sorry
represent see you thank you
representative
kerk sorry I was not unmuted I wasn't
expecting I thought the Dr
representative Marsh had his hand up
before me so I wasn't expecting that um
thank you for taking my question I was
curious if you can explain to us what
you would expect the effect will be on
our critical access hospitals and other
small facilities that are licensed and
accepting all patients as a result of
siphoning off the high-paying business
can you explain to me whether you think
that the critical access hospitals will
survive
this well um I
I I I was looking for the the takeup
data coming off of the the direct
primary care and looking at other states
just to try to see if I could look at is
there some hard data that I could
present because I would anticipate that
question and unfortunately I wasn't able
to really find anything
but what I have seen because because
it's not massive and there's not a l
data I don't think that the takeup rate
on this is very high I think the the
bulk of people um still are either on
Medicare Medicaid or they still have the
employer-based insurance so for a lot of
those people um I think that the uh the
hospital root the traditional form of
care is still going to be um more
beneficial to them U but I think you
know down the road I don't know as a
dedu Ables continue to increase um you
know that that may change but one of the
things that that this may do because of
the nature of the transparency of of the
pricing is it may actually start to have
some lowering of the prices in the
hospitals but I don't have hard data
that would tell me one way or another
is that
followup yep yes U Mr chair man follow
up yes okay
so my concern is since currently various
licensed facilities are sharing the
burden of the low-paying customers when
you sci-fi off the high-paying customers
uh can you not conceive that that may
have an effect on the viability of our
critical access hospitals that have
margins running often a percent or less
or in the
red if if you suddenly saw a massive
takeup on this um I think that that
could be possible but the reality is
when I'm going around and I'm doing the
literature research I'm not seeing any
of that happening in in other parts of
the country and I just know when I from
my own experience when I talked to the
people that I have working with me in
the factory we've introduced hsas for
example for a long long time and they
really haven't been taken up with any
real uh degree is a percentage of the
plans being chosen so I really don't
think my God is telling me that there's
not going to be a lot of penetration
when this first comes in employer-based
uh insurance is still uh the way most
people are going to be accessing and
there I think in most cases insulated
from the cost so they are going to go
model thank you uh representative Marsh
uh thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you representative for taking my
question and as you know I'm a supporter
was my direct primary care bill we
passed last session uh I uh support
transparency and healthc Care pricing
and and note from the data that you're
correct that that has resulted in
Oklahoma where the uh Surgery Center of
Oklahoma's transparency has resulted in
decreased prices on some surgical
procedures in the state of Oklahoma but
I wanted to ask you if there is any
relationship ship between the expansion
of the surgery center of Oklahoma which
is the model upon which this legislation
is based and the closure of eight
hospitals in Oklahoma between 2010 and
2020 those being epic Medical Center in
eufala Latimer County General Hospital
in Wilton Memorial Hospital and
Physician Group in Frederick Mercy
Hospital in elino musk Community
Hospital Paul's Valley General Hospital
sah community hospital and hasell County
Community Hospital in Stigler thank you
um I really don't know why those
hospitals Clos so I I don't have the
hospitals anyone else wish to ask a
question represent mer thank you Mr
chairman representative m is it what is
what um sort of customer
is the typical kind that you would see
utilizing this um model payment would it
be would it be correct to assume it
would be people who do not have employer
um insurance through their employer and
also don't have Medicaid so maybe they
fall in
between um you know they're
underinsured yeah I mean I think
ultimately that's that's kind of what's
driving this legislation is it it's a
recognition that we have certain
limitations around access as well um you
know for for people who are in the gig
economy for people who have multiple
jobs like I said don't have
access the same amount of access to
those employer based plans they're
really vulnerable and they're looking
for some transparency and the ability to
plan so this um works well I think for
them and also I think where it may work
well is in rural communities um rural
communities um really have a real
problem with respect to asset if you
look at the last census I think um about
20% of of the country is rural but if
you look at the amount of doctors that
are serving in those rural areas um it's
less than 10% so there's a real access
issue which I I think um the direct
primary care bill you know helped to
address and I think this just Builds on
that by allowing those people to offer
more services um it goes and I think it
improves access uh in those rural areas
also for people in the G economy and
things like I said and I I really don't
want to be going after uh hospitals and
closing hospitals especially not rural
hospitals uh that that would be the last
thing I want but understanding the
issues of access that we have um I think
we we have to recognize that just going
up and beefing up the hospitals you know
we've been doing that we've been trying
to do that and and I don't think the
sole solution is going to come from that
and so we have to be looking at at other
other options as well and and this is
one
I other questions uh representative gay
thank you Mr chairman excuse me thank
you representative um I have actually
three questions the two or definitions
I'll ask at the end the hard one
is um if I'm understanding you correctly
the bill would make things
cheaper because the the uh provider
would not have to pay for the staff to
do all the paperwork to deal with the
insurers uh I have a friend who's an
expert at that just a question just a
question so is is that the point that
this would be a benefit to the people
who have no insurance are not covered by
a government
agency that it would actually be
cheaper because right now if they're
build they're build much higher at least
in my experience the the retail price is
much higher than what they agree with
insurers to pay um you know it it it may
be cheaper that's the thinking about it
um and it will also be more predictable
and and so in the case of my primary
care physician who chose to go the
direct Primary Care model on this P she
wanted to have her own practice she
wanted to be outside from Under the
Umbrella of a hospital this allowed her
to do that because she didn't have this
whole infrastructure that was required
you know with the insurance and the
Medicare models and and all of those
things um and it did allow for her to
really drive the price down but it also
it's not just that the price is lower
but is that it it's predictable and so
um so it allows people to go places
maybe where there's not a hospital
Network to support them in the rural
area but it allowed you to do it so that
I can for to be in practice and I can
pass that on to my patients and they
have predictability so that's that's my
thinking of it you said you had another
question yeah I wanted to know the
definition of
HSA and direct Primary
Care uh new on this committee oh um well
uh the the direct Primary Care is
primary care where you're providing care
directly to to uh the patient there's no
reimbursement model so in the case of um
my primary care doctor she just would
set up a subscription service you pay x
amount of money a month and you have
unlimited service and you're uh and the
uh what the HSA that was your other
question the HSA is just the health
savings accounts so um my wife and I we
still have a PO plan which is a
traditional plan but with a health
savings account you can go and instead
the money goes into an account which you
can use for routine procedures and if
you don't use it you you you get to keep
that money so
um so for some people that don't have a
huge
amount that that kind of works for them
um so I hope I answered your
question anyone
else anyone else representative Merchant
has hand up representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank you representative for taking my
question I have two interrelated
questions um question
one is this really for patients without
health insurance and say that somebody
who has under Insurance still Insurance
way to see it so we looking for an
audience that doesn't have any health
insurance and only has an H H HSA
account or are we talking about
both um it it could be utilized by
anybody um you know uh it could be
utilized by a person who has Insurance a
person who has HSA a person who has no
insurance anybody that wanted to utilize
uh the the those services at a facility
that offers that could use it um because
it's very hard I think to cost compare
um if you had a full employer based plan
you would probably still be going to
something that offers the reimbursement
model because it's not easy to compare
um what I would be paying say at CMC
versus what I would be paying um at a
clinic that would offer this and because
the the clinic would maybe have very
transparent pising because it's not a
reimbursement model we all know that can
be sometimes hard to off offer um so
because it's going to be difficult I
think easily for consumers to do that
direct comparison it is my opinion that
that people who are on the traditional
employer based plans for the moment
anyways are still going to be kind of
going down that path um and as there's
more transparency maybe that changes but
um but anybody would be able to use it
Mr chairman if I may my second question
would related to
it my second question representative is
that in the event you have a patient
that has Insurance even though it's a
high deductible like $10,000 which is
common who is going to track the
expenses that they pay out of pocket
because they not going back to the
insurance company if all of a sudden
heaven forbid they get hospitalized and
they have a
$50,000 how are they going to take the
$5,000 they paid out of pocket to go
towards that $10,000 deductible how is
that process going to work so what
you're saying somebody that has a
traditional plan chose to take part of
their services on a direct pay mode and
another part of their services with the
more traditional Insurance mode is that
and and how do you know what was spent
where no how is the insurance company
going to take the $5,000 they paid out
of pocket and apply that towards the
$10,000 deductible there's nowhere to
track
it well in in anything that you would
spend to uh a
direct to a to a clinic that only took
direct payments would not be counting
towards your
deductible that that that's something
that exists completely outside of the
relationship with your insurer so to you
if I may Mr chairman um I think it's
important if we look at this the patient
fully understands that that $5,000 they
just paid out of pocket
they're going to have to pay again when
they go into the hospital because the
$10,000 deductible is going to then
incur when they go into a hospital
admission for whatever reason so they're
going to have to double dip then and
double pay that's that is that is a
correct
statement what what they pay to the
direct the direct payment facility is
outside of your relationship with your
insurance thank you representative
Merchant for your questions do any does
then the chair will call on Greg Moore
who has signed up to testify in favor of
this bill and welcome Mr Moore and tell
represent sure can you hear me yeah
thank you uh my name is Greg Moore I am
the state director with Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire and I'm
uh and I'm thrilled to be here Mr
chairman members of the committee uh to
speak in favor of House Bill 290 uh as
representative mlan mentioned this bill
Builds on the progress of the direct
primary care bill from two years ago
that was broadly supported we are strong
supporters of that model is it gives
patients an option for highquality
personalized patient centered care
that's affordable and it's also model
that practitioners like um this was a
point that was driven home to me when I
was at a policy conference in Colorado
back in October of 2019 back when we
went to events uh and there was a panel
on Direct primary care I certainly was
interested particularly given the
passage of House Bill 508 and uh one of
the Physicians on the panel uh said of
direct primary care that this is why I
went to medical school and and got Brad
approval uh that same uh that same
panelist also was talking about some of
the challenges for passing direct
Primary Care he mentioned uh the
insurance uh the insurance Challenge and
uh thankfully uh we have made that
change here in New stamp in New
Hampshire two years ago but he also me
mentioned some of the challenges in
dealing with facilities and and the um
inability to have access to certain
basic facilities uh like lab work like
Radiology uh Medical Imaging and and
this bill addresses that uh we're
hopeful that this model gains traction
particularly as sponsor pointed out with
the gig economy uh creating more and
more people who aren't necessarily
getting traditional employer based based
health insurance however you know one
barrier that for for long-term success
of direct Primary Care is lack of having
access to those those certain procedures
uh you could certainly Envision uh
multiple direct Primary Care
practitioners coming together to form a
practice and then looking to add the
capability to do things like blood work
take an x-ray or or an MRI unfortunately
all of the those Services require a
facility license under state law and in
order to get a facility's license now
you were required to take all forms of
payment Medicare Medicaid and private
insurance uh when the section when the
section of of this bill that were
working would be modified under this
current law was passed in 2016 there
wasn't any discussion of direct payments
or any thought at that time of of direct
Primary Care the reason why that was
passed back in 2016 was there was a lot
of concern that that uh if it weren't
put in place providers would uh spring
up that would take High uh high-end um
in what they call cherry-picking taking
high-end reimbursement from private
insurance and then not taking medicaid
uh and and creating that sort of
imbalance that I think uh representative
representative kerk mentioned the direct
Primary Care model is very different
from a third-party payment model and
this legislation recognizes that fact uh
similar the way House Bill 508 uh did
two years ago what house bill 508 said
was is that if a provider didn't take
thirdparty payments that they would be
relieved of thirdparty payment
regulation and this bill does the exact
same thing just at the facility level uh
now to be fair no one's going to be
building a direct primary care hospital
nursing facility Rehabilitation Center
this just not the market to sustain
something on that scale however the
areas that I did mention earlier like as
I said lab work Radiology Medical
Imaging are places where there might be
a viable opportunity for uh for
facilities in this space and House Bill
290 gives us a chance to build on an
Innovative approach that can be a great
fit to meet the needs of some gr estator
and uh i' encourage uh this committee to
cons to strongly consider it i' I'd like
to speak a little bit to representative
kerk's question which uh relates to
critical access hospitals nothing in
this bill changes the section in RSA 151
that provides the 15 M radius around it
so uh uh facilities would still this
would still apply to facilities within
the 15 mile radius so that that's still
in place uh and uh and and I think
that's an important uh thing to keep in
mind
um and as to representative Mars's
question uh it would still I still don't
see a viable case for something like the
the surgery center of Oklahoma coming to
New Hampshire if with this bill passed
and the reason for that is because
there's another section uh that was as
part of how Senate pill 481 back in 2016
that says that anyone who wants a
hospital license and in order to have a
hospital license in uh in New Hampshire
it's a a facility who keeps a patient
for more than 24 hours either needs a
hospital license or or a Skilled Nursing
Facility license um or or long-term care
be licensed under that those so um I and
the current law says that if you if you
are have to get a hospital license then
you need to have a 247 emergency
department and so I just don't see a
case for a business model to make sense
so I think you really are talking about
those types of facilities that do this
type work in this space like I said
Medical Imaging lab work things like
that so I think that's really really the
the uh the scope of what we would be
talking about if this bill were to pass
uh thank you and I'd be happy to take
any questions any questions for Mr
Moore representative Mar represent
up go ahead representative Marsh he
thank you Mr chairman thank you Greg for
taking my question here uh and my
question relates to your statement that
you don't see a model for something like
direct primary care and facilities and
it seems to me that the idea of paying
facilities on a retainer uh By A large
group of people cutting out the
insurance middleman um would be a very
viable financial model and much more
akin to the direct Primary Care model
than the model that's being proposed in
this bill so could you address that
please I I I'm I'm sorry um uh maybe I
misunderstood your question uh
representative uh uh
[Music]
let me rephrase it then would it not be
possible to uh have a model whereby that
would be very comparable to the direct
Primary Care Model whereby A Health Care
System um uh took payments on retainer
uh from people who subscribe to their
services and then no longer build fee
for service to those people who paid the
retainer on annualized basis and they
set the retainer fee at a rate such that
they could pay all their expenses that
could easily become a less expensive
model for healthcare than than the model
for health care that we have today oh uh
representative uh we were in violent
agreement um
unfortunately in order to get a
facility's license you have to you have
to take all payers and and that's sort
of the problem so the subscription model
for that includes facilities would still
have the same challenge as a result of
this the the the section of laws that
currently exists um you couldn't you
couldn't do it you could not move
forward with that model and I and I
agree 100% I think that would be uh
tremendous cost savings a tremendous
opportunity for more personalized
patient- centered care but it can't
happen uh as the current the current law
lays it
out a follow-up Mr chairman followup yes
might that perhaps be something that we
think about uh for filing in the
future we would support that
100% I I thank you any other
questions representative kofalt has his
kohal thank you Mr chairman uh and thank
you Mr Moore um you you you were talking
about direct primary care and and I'm
just wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit on the the economic model and
sort of what are the mechanics of cost
savings around direct primary care and
that would perhaps help us to better
understand the implications of this a
absolutely um it's important to
understand that um there is a enormous
amount of overhead that goes in place um
when when you um implicate third party
payers uh every single every single
practitioner has a small army behind
them of people who have to support their
work there's a uh Physician Group uh
trade Association that uses as a best
practice model that for every physician
there should should be 2.5 full-time
employees just doing medical billing um
add on to that things like revenue cycle
add on to that um compliance and
understand that that overhead that over
those overhead costs are mirrored on the
on the third party payer uh so for
example in the Medicaid Program you have
claims Representatives Medical Loss
people you have uh uh Auditors and so
that that massive overhead just sort of
sits a top of the the healthc care
system uh there was study a peer
reviewed study that came out a year ago
and I I think it was the anals of
internal medicine I'm not 100% sure
about that that said that 35% of health
care costs are overhead or $800 billion
dollar a year uh by having a direct
Primary Care model that sort of slices
through that those overhead costs and
and really uh Works to to ring a lot of
uh a lot of those costs out of out of
the the Health Care system by having a
direct payment system um the other sort
of factor that's that's in place that is
a hangup um from a facility standpoint
for the uh direct primary care beyond
the fact you can't just offer it is that
uh that under State Medicaid laws that's
RSA
126a uh you can't offer a lower price
below your Medicaid rate so even if you
were able to ring all the costs out of
out of the overhead and say say 30% off
of what other facilities would charge if
that price dropped it below the price of
of the Medicaid cost the Medicaid cost
is a floor because under state law uh
you uh you cannot offer a lower a lower
price than the Medicade price so I think
that's something uh something to
consider as well uh why this this would
potentially offer the opportunity for
thank you Mr
Moore thank you next up Paula minahan
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association who signifies she is opposed
to the
bill good morning Mr chairman again and
members of the committee um again from
up the record Paula minahan Senior vice
president state government relations
with the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
hospitals in the state we are opposed to
HB 290 we see this bill as really um
negatively impacting access to a health
care facility um if they did not have
required to have charity care policies
those are fundamental to ensuring that
all all patients regardless of their
ability to pay have access to care so
you know while um you know we
respectfully disagree with the sponsor
and Mr more um and our appro our
position is that charity care Pol
policies protect the patients especially
those that are uninsured by having um
having those in place and being required
to have those um it was unclear to me um
without un I did not really understand
exactly what the approach or the um
intent of the bill was um I understand
it better now after hearing the
testimony um I do want to make clear a
couple things one is that the state of
New Hampshire under Health Facilities I
listed some of the in my testimony some
of the facilities that require a license
um I think it was stated that MRIs and
Radiology requires a uh uh Li Health
Facilities license in our state it does
not I just wanted to make that point um
I I um understand direct Primary Care um
I'm not really testifying on that that
is a completely separ separate um Health
Care model um but Health Facilities
where our hospitals are licensed um is
kind of my more my um my baileywick if
you will and this this statute that is
being amended and um impacting charity
care policies again that we believe um
impact negatively the the citizens of
the State of New Hampshire we I I am
very familiar with I am very familiar
with the with the statute I'm very
familiar with the with the bills that
were passed um addressing um trying to
ensure that there is standard um
coverage for all regardless of their
ability to pay and that is a requirement
if you get a licens um a health
facilities license in the state of New
Hampshire um and um again that's pretty
much my testimony that I I believe very
strongly that um this will negatively
impact our patients um we do have a
hospital that is currently um in
bankruptcy in the in courts um and we as
representative kerk and others have
indicated um we um we have hospitals
including critical access hospitals that
um serve um our citizens um very well
and we want to make sure that they are
continue to be able to take care of our
patients um because in the North Country
we really don't have um a lot of other
um services available to them so um it
is critical to our um patients we
believe in this in the state to ensure
that we have viable facilities um I do
not believe this bill is necessary I I
am very very concerned that the way it's
being um affecting charity care policies
will will have it'll be a slippy slope
and have unintended consequences and I
am very concerned happy to answer any
question questions and thank you any
minahan representative kerk has his hand
up representative
KARK you um thank you for taking my
question uh would you agree then that
perhaps one of those unintended
consequences would be indeed the adverse
Financial effect Upon Our critical
access hospitals leading more of them to
perhaps cut essential services such as
maternity or just have to
close um yes I would agree with that
statement representative kerk thank
else thank you Miss Mahan for your
chairman chairman I do see that uh
representative Love is in the attendees
and he has his hand
up
who's
this representative David love has
bill is there a Melissa Saint Seer yes
you yes hello um thank you my name is
Melissa ster I am the chief legal
officer for the Department of Health and
Human Services and I just wanted to um
clarify something we we remain neutral
on the bill but um the testimony earlier
regarding who this bill would um impact
currently the way that the statute is
written it is only for those facilities
under our Suba and subd which includes
hospitals but it also includes
facilities such as um outpatient
Rehabilitation clinics ambulatory
surgical centers hospice uh emergency
medical care centers dropin or walk-in
centers Di centers and burden centers
you're having trouble understanding you
it's
garbled I apologize I will do my best um
to let me see if I
can is this
better well say a few
things um so the the facilities that are
that fall under this um provision to
ensure that they have a policy for um
non-discrimination for source of payment
the
um the hospitals hospitals are under
this it's it's those are that are part
sub a and part subd and 151 um colon 2
so it's hospitals also facilities that
are outpatient Rehabilitation clinics
ambulatory surgical centers hospice
Emergency Medical Care Centers walk-in
centers dialysis centers and birthing
centers so these are the only facilities
right now that are required to have such
a policy uh under our licensing rules
and um so that does not include our
Laboratories and Paula manahan is
correct we do not license um
radiological Services um under our
health facilities the equipment is
licensed under Public Health but it is
not um it it is not licensed under RSC
151 which is what we are amending in
this in this bill so I just wanted to
make sure that I gave uh the committee
that information for for for your
thoughts
thank you does anyone have any
questions representative Weber that's
okay um could
miss uh email us those points so we will
have them in writing which will help
both the clerk and the rest of
us I'm happy to do so thank you that
that's just helpful for the references
to the other sections which it's hard to
keep up
with sure do anyone else have a
question representative Marsh has a
question representative
Marsh yes thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you Melissa for taking my question
and my question relates to access under
the Medicaid Program um specifically the
Ambulatory Surgery centers uh if this
bill were to become law uh do you
foresee that there would be an access
issue for the State Medicaid Program to
ambulatory surgy centers in the state
and would that uh cause a change in the
cost and the amount that the state has
to finance uh in order to fund the State
Medicaid
Program um so I um I'm not uh the
foremost expert in our Medicaid Program
um Henry Litman is and I can certainly
take that question back to him I do uh
believe that this you know the the the
requirement to have a a policy regarding
non you know allowing or caring for all
individuals regardless of the source of
payment um doesn't necessarily just
pertain to Medicaid it pertains to all
payers and and so um in in having that
policy and how they the each facility
addresses that policy you know they have
different they have different ways to
approach um that you know the the
creation of that policy and and what we
do is we look at the statute to ensure
that that the policy just meets the the
intent of the statute meets the language
of the statute but how that would
necessarily impact our Medicaid Program
I don't know if I can speak
intelligently to that right now um but I
can certainly take that question
back uh thank you very much uh Melissa
could you also ask Henry to give us some
idea of what percentage of the state
budget currently is uh the State
Medicaid Program because I think that
may be relevant to this U topic specific
to ulatory surgical centers uh just
Medicaid in general I believe it's a
large percentage of the state budget but
I don't know off the top of my head what
percentage that is
okay
call then I end the hearing on House
Bill 290 the committee will take about a
four or five minute walking around
recess we'll be back at quarter to 12
for House Bill
247 it is my intent to go to
12:30ish and then break for lunch if
we're not done we will have a
continuation of 247 so we are adjourned
moment
wait sounds like there's a cheaper model
cheap
uh
hello what what are we doing right now I
had to step out for a second we're just
taking a a short recess a little break
and then our
return um he said that that um he
anticipates U going to lunch at 12:30
around 12:30ish if we if they haven't
finished okay um I have a I have a
meeting at 12 uh 12 to1 I need to attend
so I I will come
back oh I'll come back at yeah you
should be able to be able to come back
um no problem with the same link yes
problem
yeah well you know on my left hand is
Mason and on my right hand is we and
they're both been
helpful a lot of help with committee
procedure
anyway I've been in both parties and
I've been minority and majority several
times so each time I must say I much
prefer
more
[Music]
which it was a campaign speech was not a
speech to be the speaker of all the
members of the house see I must not have
been listening to it it was the one you
listened to in your car
oh sure we
did
scar a
certain both parties have a certain
parties I called
to I tried to
did you get through on
EXC because we were being told that
hour
today I call the house Health and Human
committee out
of recess we didn't adjourn we were at
recess played on the playground so we're
back and
uh apologies to everyone we're running
late we're going to go to about 12:30 is
and then see what happens after that I
would like to call Representative
please
yes um if representative lungren is on
the call can you please raise your hand
you okay here we
you
unmute if you're calling from the phone
that would be star
n can you hear me
now yes yeah oh I'm I'm so sorry I'm
anyway thank you for your time uh my
name is David lungren uh state
representative from Londoner New
Hampshire I represent Rockingham 5 I
come before you to submit this bill
regarding a need for opioid reductions
I've worked closely on a similar bill
with three colleagues from the state of
West Virginia which is the second worst
state in addictions in the United States
followed by New Hampshire we were able
to present this bill at a delegation in
uh you US Congress both uh
representatives from New Hampshire and
West Virginia and while in Washington we
were able to actually meet with the
Secretary of Veterans
Administration who believed that this
bill would warranted distribution to all
the vas in the country as a doctor of
Chiropractic treating severe patients
I've seen a drastic reduction in opio
use with my VA patients as well as my
regular patients and it shows that there
is a proven method to Alternative Care
statistics shown between 2018 2 2017 and
18 is a 70% increase in opioid involved
deaths in the United States the CDC has
released Grim statistics suggesting that
more than 880,000 drug overdoses
occurred over the course of a single
year ending in March of
2020 uh statist statistic also show
there has been a more drastic increase
in opioid use since the
pandemic this bill basically states by
first giving the patient the choice to
implement Alternative Care before
prescribing these highly addictive
medications we can provide them the
opportunity to try one of more proven
Alternative Care therapies that I've
listed their ability to reduce and
eliminate pain without potential risk of
addiction
I also want to uh add to that that there
are leading medical organizations in the
country right now that are recommending
and including these Services as a coste
efficient and effective means of dealing
with opioid crisis that being uh there
is a study going on in Boston right now
re uh involving University of Wisconsin
University Utah brigam and Women's
Hospital Harvard Medical School uh
seeking alternative methods to coping
with back pain
um and that's basically it I appreciate
your time I hope I can answer the
questions and I hope you can still hear
me thank you representative I'm going to
do something a little out of order in
that Dr Anthony Milano has a patient at
12 noon and needs uh to speak and we've
held him up 45 minutes already so Dr
Anthony Milano if you would like to
you thank you Representatives is my uh
volume and microphone
working okay thanks for the opportunity
to testify my name is Anthony Milano I'm
an orthopedic cancer surgeon and Trauma
surgeon at conquer pedics and conquered
hospital I've been in active surgical
practice for 15 years and see
uh maybe about 10,000 patients a year
and perform about a thousand surgeries a
year and I represent the orthopedic
surgeons in the state and nationally as
a past president of the New Hampshire
Orthopedic society and as a n as a
national New Hampshire State counselor
representing our national of society um
regarding HB
247 to
be but simply it's a somewhat illogical
Bill and even somewh outstandingly bad
in in written intent just to read it let
alone imagine it actually being a law um
I know of zero
orthopedic medicine precedent where a
law similar to HB
247 would determine Medical Treatments
and the Order of Medical Treatments or
legislate Orthopedic Medical Treatments
uh in any state that that I know um you
know for example it would be nonsensical
before you would you legislate before
someone received the corona vaccine that
they would first need Vitamin D or food
or water or vitamin C before of course
not so the the bill states that before
opioids are medically used um let let's
say after major heart surgery orthopedic
surgery or for a terminal cancer patient
in home in hospice that you would
somehow legislate that treatments such
as acupuncture or Chiropractic
treatments would be necessary before
opioids are used of course not
I'm a surgeon and opioids are used for
every modern anesthesia for every major
surgery and they're used temporarily
after those major surgeries such as
traumas and back surgeries and major
surgeries including heart surgeries so
am I going to call acupuncturist or
chiropractors or a physical therapist
into an ER or an O for patients in
painful shock that require opioids of
course not um in medicine we just take a
hypocracy
often prescribe no unnecessary
treatments so for 99% of what what I do
as a surgeon I prescribe
over-the-counter medicines and provide
education and guidance and I use a ton
of anti-inflammatories Tylenol
acupuncture Chiropractic treatments
physical therapy and sometimes surgery
and pretty rarely
opioids um but there's no mandates on
the order of those in conclusion really
Orthopedic muscoskeletal care in any
modern state or Society needs to have
the treatment dictated by medical and
Science rationals and not any
nonsensical legal directives on the
order of um treatments like in HB 247
nonsensical Nikki Kel representa kelse
said that her video
representative Nikki Kelsey says her
video screen is not
work it it may sorry chairman it may be
a um problem on my end I'm trying to fix
it but I just want you guys to know I am
here sorry for their
Interruption and
others
questions
Dr representative has his hand up
representative I'm sorry that was
actually a question for the sponsor um
and I thought maybe we'd be going back
to the sponsor but perhaps Dr Milano
could answer this because this question
because I share something with him is a
retired Orthopedic spine surgeon um my
concern and I'm wondering if you think
the language might be acceptable if we
segregated out acute and chronic pain
because as the currently it says of the
Myriad conditions that cause pain and I
agree with you completely that it's
illogical to uh use alternative
treatments for kidney stones and for hip
fractures and so on in chronic pain
there may be a role do you think this
bill would be acceptable if we said only
management I am not a chronic manager of
pain and you know it sounds like you you
probably weren't either and and I think
chronic pain treatment rationals exist
and it and it exists to minimize opioid
use in principle it's always existed and
we've evolved to minimize opioid use and
despite trends that have existed in West
Virginia and our state I think a lot of
angles on the opioid epidemic have been
tackled um but of course for chronic
pain there would be a a big difference
to state that alternative
treatments uh are are critical to use
not not even to just legislate they're
just critical to use to reduce opioid
dependence
legislate
theair
representative
question um Mr chair when I have first a
question of the chair and then a
question of Dr
Molina is this a second committee Bill
and is it going perhaps to Commerce on
the insurance aspects after here I
believe so but I don't know 100% okay
thank you welcome um and then my
question for Dr Molina is if we
separated the bill out a different way
and removed the medical mandate but
simply allowed the part of the bill to
proceed that requires cover for certain
nonopioid modalities that are not now
acceptable is is that question for me I
take representative lungren if you want
to answer it yeah I'd like I'd like to
interject something basically what what
the bill should have stated or states is
that it requires the physician to have a
discussion with the patient as to
whether they want to have Alternative
Care now everybody seems to be
misreading that and
um I I think the bill is very sensical
I'm I'm sorry I I disagree with the doc
um but
uh it's a basic bill that gives the
patient the opportunity
simple Yes uh so could you clarify for
me then because I'm not sure I'm fully
understanding the concept of the
directives okay are the nonopioid
directives something that's coming from
the patient like like for example uh
Advanced Health Care directives in other
fields is that what we're trying to do
here and if so in what format do those
directives come or is the directive
coming from the statute to the doctor
direction
um I I I wouldn't get I wouldn't go that
far my my my intention with this whole
bill was is to be able to have a
conversation with a patient and allow
them to make a choice whether they
wanted to take the medication or if they
wanted to proceed with Alternative Care
maybe for a two week period Etc this is
I'm not I'm not talking about totally
not allowing the physician to Medicaid
but at least give the patient the
alternative to choose a different method
thank you for the CL may I comment
please uh it's Anthony
Milano yes Dr go ahead I I I again need
to State there there's no precedent for
legislating orders of medical treatment
such as aspirin use by law before heart
surgery or aspirin use before opioids
for heart surgery or that there's it's
somewhat nonsensical it's valid it would
have been a wonderful effort 30 years
ago before oxyon was created but now
we're in a very much more modern um
treatment Paradigm to reduce opioid use
it's a
multimodal uh world of of treatments we
now have and we all as Physicians have a
substantial amount of continued medical
education to reduce opioid use and it's
the the intent to reduce opioid use is
is appreciated but there's no medical
rationale on any order of treatments um
and to to legislate before opioid use
um and and you could legislate that a
conversation be had sure if you really
want to legislate that you could
legislate that a conversation needs to
be have but that's that's the directive
of the physician patient relationship um
and and that that is between the
Physicians treatment providers and
patients thank you Dr M Lano I'm told
that you have a 12:00 thank you thank
you thank you uh for your service and
your time thank you and I'll bring back
rep uh represent lungren uh that we took
a little detour from
right thank you Mr chair um I'm having a
real hard time with this Zoom thing so
I'm sorry but um I I just wanted to
reiterate that what the bill intends is
for uh
pain of The Spine and
Neck okay he's that Dock's going on on
and on about heart conditions and this
and that it's got nothing to do with
that now as a practicing chiropractor I
can bring up the fact that I've had a
patient that fell off a
ladder went to the hospital was uh
diagnosed no broken bone sent home with
uh meds okay after one day of use he he
called me he says I'm loopy and I don't
know what to do well come on in we'll
give it a try well thank God and I mean
that thank God 10 days later the the
man's pain free but he was he was given
92 pills now I keep hearing that it's
under it's getting under control this
this is not under control and I think
that it it this bill without a doubt
gives the patient the right to
choose a different care and uh that's
pretty much what I'm sticking with um
and I know that you're uh you know short
on time and I uh obviously will
entertain more questions but uh it it's
the bill is about having a discussion
with the
patient thank you we're going to take
some more questions representative
krishman so for
clarification um in online one it starts
when patient seek treatment for any of
the Myriad conditions that cause pain
shall refer or prescribe to a patient
any of the following treatment
Alternatives so there's a shall there so
that that
indicates you know in leg it's
must and and then based on the
practitioner's clinical judgment that
seems to leave room for if they believe
that opioids would be the first line
treatment in their clinical judgment
they they don't have to so the sh is
doesn't
apply and and then availability of
treatment um before starting a patient
on opid so I think that that's where the
the idea that this is um mandating
certain medical interventions prior to
others um comes from so perhaps some um
changing the shell to a
May and
um and maybe just clarifying that this
is some clarifying language that it is a
voluntary decision made
between the the patient and the
prescriber okay uh representative lren
um I'll finish your thought here would
you be comfortable with that it's got to
be a
question
yes thank you uh representative gay
thank you Mr chair and Mr Dr
L I definitely think your word your
wording needs to be adjusted to meet
what you're saying uh a really honorable
thing which should keep the shell in
choice okay I think your point is
patients need to know there is an option
so right
fits but what you shall do do you agree
would that satisfy what you're trying to
accomplish yes
representative starting with an
alternative to opioids because I know my
doctor automatically wrote when I had
the last time I had surgery
automatically wrote me uh an opioid
prescription only I didn't realize it
was until I got it and then I told him I
said I don't take that he says I don't
either I thought why did you off why
didn't you talk to me about this
questions representative Shapiro and
representative kerk have their hands up
representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for taking this question or
two questions um following up to what
other people have alluded to um I think
the language doesn't reflect that this
is really a question it uses terms like
a
directive and at the same time it uses a
lot of qualifying language like whenever
possible
or um practitioners clinical judgment so
I would be very happy to do something
that mandated that there was a
conversation about um various ways of
treating pain but I don't think the
language really reflects that um my real
question um has to do with the part
about
coverage and
um talking about evidence-based
nonopioid treatment for pain including
but not limited to it sounds like um
this bill would create mandatory
coverage um for certain treatments um
and then leave the opening for insurance
companies to um reimburse or not
reimburse for many other um treatments
and I think this is a real problem I
wonder how the problem is going to be
dealt with that there
are basically unlimited kinds of
alternative treatments that people use
and swear by and
um this is my bias but sometimes
evidence space is not so um is not
clearly defined um so I'm wondering how
insurance
companies are really going to deal with
what is reimbursed and what is not and
if we are picking with this bill if we
are kind of picking winners and losers
like um yoga therapy yes
no I I totally understand what you're
saying can you hear me yeah
okay yes um I realized from uh what I
did in West Virginia with gentlemen that
uh there was no increased cost to the
patient
um uh I look at it this way is that uh
my my medical doctor that I go to if he
uh gave me the opportunity to make a
choice and he recommended a essentially
uh my going to an
osteopath that my my insurance coverage
would be applicable um and there would
help okay I guess I'm you know my
question is more addressed towards if
we're going to mandate coverage of
certain altern
treatments
um how are we going to decide which ones
are really effective and um which ones
are
not I I'm sorry I can't answer
that any other questions for
representative
lungren representative kerk has his hand
up go ahead yes thank you very much um
thank you represent lungren I am still
very stuck on the language because you
made a comment that this bill was for
neck and back pain again the area that I
worked in but the bill doesn't say that
the bill says any of the merried
conditions that cause pain which led to
Dr melo's testimony of using it with hip
fractures kidney stones pancreatitis and
so on and so forth we would have to
either uh I'm wondering which we'd be
more comfortable with sorry question and
that is changing it from acute pain to
chronic pain which is a an entirely
different issue than acute pain or
confining it to back and neck but even
that has some difficult problems because
if you fall out of a tree and have an
acute compression fracture that's
different than 30 days of back pain so
which would you feel more comfortable
with moving to if we were going to try
to salvage this build to make it
workable um I I I think I'd rather see
the chronic pain uh
addressed thank you did you okay
actually can I do a followup followup uh
representative okay my followup actually
comes back to what represent Shapiro
just finished with and that is I and I
think maybe this is what he was driving
at we say evidence-based and there's a
laundry list and the question is who's
evidence right I think that's one of the
difficult questions because we know that
people can interpret things differently
is it going to be a matter of the
insurers um doing that because I know
that process I've actually participated
in helping to develop policies on that
based on evidence um that's certainly
not an unreasonable option but we have
not defined who whose evidence we're
using well I I mean let's get back to
the um um chronic and acute now I've got
evidence based from Dartmouth uh from
Dartmouth that uh for acute care that
chiropractic has reduced
56% yes of the the
opioids
help may I follow up yeah yes yes I mean
I this is my concern about the acute and
chronic because I agree with you I would
much rather send a patient even though I
was a spine surgeon to a chiropractor
than to give them an opioid for acute
back pain it was far better so the
that's my difficulty with trying to come
up with what language you think could
work the cute and chronic has some
sticky Parts in it as well right I think
I think and after looking at all that I
I think probably the acute would be the
I I'm sorry anyone okay I know we're not
supposed to have a debate though we'll
have to word this
later yeah thank thank you
representative kerk anyone else with a
question at this time representative
Merchant uh thank you Mr chairman and
also thank you representative for taking
my question um I want to commend you for
putting in some protection for the
pharmacist that deals with things on the
receiving end however one of the
questions I have is online 18 on page
y
what did you say uh line 18 line 18 on
page two okay on on line 18 page two it
says the pharmacist acting knowingly
against the voluntary non Opia directive
form um as a pharmacist how would I know
I'm acting against it if I don't receive
it good
question
um
I yeah I don't know how to answer that
I'm
um there's a lot of there's a lot of uh
Corrections that need to be made in this
bill and I
am apologize is that I do not know if
this is what is called an early bill if
and I've got several texts out to people
I'm hoping they'll tell me really soon
if it's an early Bill we got to get it
out the door here and just a matter of a
few weeks okay not an early bill we can
keep it and work on it for a while if
there are people from this committee who
would like to work with you on that um I
think what I'm hearing is many of us see
Merit in the bill but problems in the
bill so um I'd be willing to do that Mr
chair
all right and I would be interested in
knowing uh if there were people on this
committee and I'm I'll round out that
group but people on this committee who
would be interested working with you is
there anyone here okay Mr chairman this
is uh representative March and I'd be
representative are there
others Mr chairman I would suggest I
know it's not time for a motion but this
bill would be retained rather than try
to work on it at this phase because
there are way too many problems in this
bill to be solved uh we do you know we
we might tweak some small things but we
should not do a complete rebuild of this
bill of course which requires would you
be interested in
helping um perhaps but I would think it
should be a retained Bill unless there's
something that will allow us to get it
done that quickly but we are under the
gun with a lot of bills to be done and
if Bill isn't really ready for Prime
Time retention may be our better option
thank you that's that's a a good thought
Mr chair representative Weber if you
need to balance the numbers I'd be glad
to work on this as well but I think that
point about the amount of time that it's
going to take under the this is you know
we can't just go in the room next door
and notice it and have it done it's
difficult of course so I will have to
determine whether this is a second
committee bill which means we've got to
do something with it very quickly or if
this is something that we can keep and
work on I'll get back to everyone on
that but we do have a few other people
who signed up to testify and we do have
Roy uh good afternoon now uh can you
hear me yes nice backr excellent thank
you um
so first of all thank you for taking the
time to hear me on this uh bill um a
little background on myself in October I
was diagnosed with something called
adhesive
arachnoiditis um and contrary to what
you may think it has nothing to do with
spiders um if you look it up it it's a
chronic uh uncurable pain condition
where the nerves and your lower spine
fuse together with scar
tissue there is no other treatment for
it save pain killers and were it not for
um opioid medicines I don't know what
level I'd be able to function at
today I have encountered um from doctors
all the way to pharmacists this stigma
against patients who require this
medication and I would caution the
legislature to stay as far out of the
doctor patient relationship as possible
while still being able to um oversee it
in in a response responsible manner so I
would I would encourage you all to
Google what I just said uh adhesive
arachnoiditis and understand that there
are chronic pain conditions out there
that there are no other treatments for
um now that's that having been said this
bill looks to me like you've uh you've
been handed what what I might call a
fixer upper um and I'd be happy to work
on it with you to help fix it up because
there are some great things in this bill
uh the idea of mandating coverage for
Alternative Care such as massage therapy
Chiropractic Care uh acupuncture I think
that's a great idea because these things
are helpful to a lot of pain patients
and they if the insurance doesn't cover
it they can't afford it I mean um I go
for a Weekly massage myself it doesn't
necessarily treat the pain but it keeps
me mobile it keeps the muscles from All
Season up and um you know that's that's
over $100 each trip so there's there's
some things that this bill could help
people who who don't have the money to
pay for this Alternative Care but it can
lower the amount of opioids they'd have
to
take um so I just I I really think that
there's there's there's something to be
salvaged in this spill I would cut the
whole first part out about mandates um
just because it it it gets into gets
into the weeds of the doctor patient
relationship and not there's so many
different conditions that the doctors um
I mean let's face it they they go to
school for so many years and they
continue their education throughout
their career for us and I know there are
some Physicians here among you um and
for us non-physicians or non-experienced
people to come in and say well you know
this is how you have to deal with this
is is is just um it's not a good idea
whatsoever so I I believe in legislative
oversight but not legislative
interference and I think that there's um
a lot to be saved and salvaged in this
bill and if it is a second commit bill I
would be happy to lend my um my
experience um not necessarily in in
medicine but as a patient committee to
that uh work group thank I didn't hear
you I'm sorry you've just been appointed
to the work
group I don't I don't recall
volunteering for that but yeah
okay I'd be happy to and I'd be happy to
take any questions from
anybody this is recorded and if you play
back the last five minutes you
volunteered
twice
Zoom I just uh got the official word
this is not an early bill so we can um
work on this without undo haste thank
you representative Roy I'd like to yes
representative Weber if you are putting
together a work group if this is not an
early bill
might you consider asking chairman if he
might send us a member from Commerce to
help us with the
insurance I will not only consider it I
you other there any other questions
before for before I shut this horrific
thing
off I would like to call now Michelle
half who um is representing in the
Hampshire Association of naturopathic
half uh if you're online um oh there you
are Dr half here we go
yeah hi there um good morning thank you
so much for giving me the opportunity to
speak today um my name is Dr Michelle
half I am a New Hampshire licensed
naturopathic doctor and today I'm
representing the New Hampshire
Association of naturopathic doctors um
we are a professional membership
organization um and we represent roughly
150 naturopathic doctors licensed in New
Hampshire um this year marks 25 years
that naturopathic doctors have been
licensed in our state and during that
time we've seen significant growth uh
not only in the number of is practicing
here but also in the demand for our
services from the public um and a desire
for coverage of those
Services um our organization supports HB
247 and we respectfully request that if
the bill moves forward uh that section
one and any other reference to treatment
types in the bill includes naturopathic
medicine as a treatment alternative to
opioids uh naturopathic doctors are
trained in numerous non-invasive
low-risk and also lowcost natural
treatment
modalities that have not only been used
traditionally for thousands of years but
have also been studied extensively in
Modern Times And proven effective in
treating both acute and chronic pain
these treatment modalities include diet
and nutrition lifestyle modification
herbal medicine Physical Medicine
including massage hydrotherapy and
physical
manipulation as well as IV nutrient
therapy Homeopathy and mindbody Medicine
additionally many of us are uh New
Hampshire certified or licensed
acupuncturists um as this most recent
wave of the opioid epidemic has raged on
for the last eight years uh naturopathic
doctors have been successful in treating
countless individuals in New Hampshire
for pain utilizing these modalities
without the use of opioids or other
pharmaceutical or surgical interventions
um we would welcome opportunity to
continue to Pro
provide oh sorry um we would welcome the
opportunity to continue to provide these
services to the public by being included
in HB
247 and I thank you again for your time
and attention I'm happy to work with the
committee and answer any questions you
might have thank you does anyone have
half seeing none I would like to call on
savich
I think I just became unmuted can you
hear me yes thank you um I submitted I
hope through the mike padmore in the New
Hampshire Medical Society onepage
written
testimony and
um basically uh Dr Kirk and Dr Milano
covered pretty much everything I was
going to say I'll be very brief um
basically
um and I was very glad to hear the
sponsor of the bill Dr lram talk about
converting this to spine and back
because as a general surgeon I'll give
you a little background I I practiced
general surgery and conquered for over
30 years and I retired from clinical
practice about six years ago but I still
teach Dartmouth medical students three
times a week and I also teach about 15
times uh a year in the gross anatomy lab
at Dartmouth and um the pain that we're
all talking about here is was called
sematic pain and from teaching anatomy
and physiology there's a type of pain
called visceral pain also uh somebody
alluded to pancreatic disease that's
visceral your GI track your gallbladder
all those things are visceral these
alternative treatments I don't think
have any evidence-based
information based on visceral pain when
you're laying on hands which all these
conditions are talk about here all these
Alternatives including naturopathic
medicine uh you can see where that may
have some basis on sematic medicine
which is or somatic pain which is bones
joints and so forth but there's a whole
field of pain out there that we're not
even getting near and the fact that the
sponsors willing to Define that is
probably the most important thing if
you're going to continue to work on this
bill um there are other comments talked
about basic and I I want to be brief it
said shall prescribe based on Judgment
of the pH of the provider and uh whether
these alternatives are readily available
uh Judgment of the provider is something
that the Board of Medicine deals with
about 500 times a year U that's the
number of complaints and lawsuits and so
forth that we have to deal with I spent
17 years On The Board of Medicine until
last year um so when it comes down to
judgment if there's concerns about that
uh and sometimes the judgment to use
something is not correct that's where
the Board of Medicine is forward for um
and I think that would be a good idea uh
the other thing about alternative these
alternative medic these alternative
ideas are growing Beyond a doubt for a
good thing but they're not usually
available 247 even an urgent care center
is not open at night so one of the
biggest volumes of work in an emergency
room at night is patients that come in
with pain and all these alternatives are
really not available right there and
then and those folks often get opioids
and that's hard fix unless all these
alternative folks are willing to be
there all the time uh my last comment is
uh to uh representative
lram that horrible story told about
somebody being discharged with 92 pills
that's an exact example of where that
complaint in my mind should go to the
Board of Medicine not not be not with
legislation created simply because of
that if that's the motivation so those
are my comments but basically uh Jerry
Kirk and and Anthony Milano covered my
points that are in my written
testimony Dr
committee thank you would you take
us I have no further I have no further
comments okay thank
you
um
uh
David representative David love are you
call Representative David
love representative love um I know
you're on the phone if you could press
you
I believe star six may may actually be
the right combination for
unmute
hello hello hello this is representative
love can you hear me uh we can hear you
representative love oh good afternoon Mr
chair and committee members uh my name
is uh representative David love I
represent Rockingham 6 and of co-p of
this bill I want to give you a little
personal history on back in 1972 And I I
had extensive knee surgery after a
motorcycle accident and being young and
stupid I became addicted to opioid pain
pain meds I know the pain of addiction I
know the pain in my mother's eyes in an
in inner voice when she said I hope your
grandmother never finds out it'll it
would kill her and not being able to do
anything about it it was a living
definition of
powerlessness now fast forward uh seven
weeks ago I broke my back back after
falling 15 ft while climbing into a tree
stand while hunting I was prescribed
perco set 5 migs at first at the
hospital then I called my primary care
and uh they uh they gave me 40 40 perco
set of 10 milligrams to be taken one
every four hours for pain the pain was
excruciating for the first two or three
days and when the pain subsided I was
able to back off off back I start
started backing off the Percocet dosage
using a t unit a mile form of electric
muscle stimulation provided by my
chiropractor which helped immensely with
my
pain I started going to the chiropractor
chiropractor approximately one week
after the after the injury and use a
stronger electric muscle stimulation and
laser therapy on my back because of the
these alternative therapies therapies I
was be I was able to be pain medication
free at around three weeks post
injury as legislators I feel we have no
we we should leave no stone unturned in
the battle against opioid addiction some
argue that if we passed this bill as
written required requiring health
insurance companies to pay for the for
some alternative therapy treatments that
health insurance rates would rise but I
would argue that those costs would be
offset by insurance companies not having
to pay for the for the usually multiple
rehabilitation hospital stays or the uh
the the the the therapies that have come
out in the last few years such as
suboxin which is is the costs are pretty
prohibitive uh taxpayers wouldn't have
to pay for the unfortunate
incarcerations and broken families of
and result from
addiction I'm grateful to say because of
Al of the alternative therapies which
wasn't covered by the insur by insurance
companies provided by my chiropractor I
used only the first 10 5 milligram
perette and 22 of the 10 milligrams and
have 18 left over which will be turned
over to the dairy Police Department soon
most importantly my family doesn't have
to go through the agony of having an op
op opioid addicted loved one once again
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members for taking my testimony and I'll
take any
questions any questions for
representative
love seeing none the chair recognizes
department hi Tyler Brandon from the New
Hampshire insurance department um I am
the director of health health economics
with the department and I'm going to
focus just on the insurance provisions
of the bill as um probably most of you
know when the department testifies we
don't normally have a position on a bill
and uh that's the case today um that
being said I'm going to address a couple
of concerns um the bill would be a
significant policy development and
that's a a legislative decision but it
does create some new insurance mandates
and when I say mandates I'm talking
about sort of traditional Insurance
mandates that change the scope of
services that are covered it also
impacts both the group and the
individual markets and that's important
in general insurance mandates do put
upward pressure on health insurance
premiums there is sometimes the
assumption that if you get better access
to certain types of services cost
overall will be lower um because people
who might not otherwise use the services
now use them when you look at costs at a
population level they often go up even
when you might think otherwise for
particular patients because it impacts
the individual Market uh the federal
government has said that when a state
passes a mandate the additional costs of
those mandates because the federal
government pays premium subsidies in the
individual Market those additional costs
need to be made up for by the state so
it could incur a liability for the state
it's one of the big things that we have
to deal with with mandates these days
and often legislation is modified so
that it doesn't impact that particular
market and create the state
liability some of the services listed
are a little unclear because they're not
traditional medical services that
insurers get built for that creates a a
dynamic in terms of how you track those
claims how the claims get submitted to a
uh ensure and even how the services are
described in yoga therapy and
acupuncture probably good examples of
that but because the legislation's
pretty open-ended um there could be a
number of other services that that would
be of concern the good news is New
Hampshire actually has a process for
reviewing mandates and um the chair of a
committee can request that of the
department we have an Actuarial firm
that's on staff they can do a mandate
review tell you more about the costs and
there's a specific process for doing
mandate review that includes looking at
the social
benefit there's also the issue with uh
creating sort of a payment parody with
visits to a primary care provider so
because there are screening services
that are not subject to cost sharing
deductibles if you create this type of
parody you're going to run into problems
with the high deductible Health Plan HSA
type Arrangements these are tax favored
accounts but they have to have cost
sharing deductibles apply to any service
that is not considered screening or
preventive that's by the federal
government so you'd have to include
those types of products which again is
not unprecedented but um it is something
a dynamic that would need to be
considered the same issue exists for
catastrophic health insurance products
that also require cost sharing uh full
cost sharing for for most
Services um so as I mentioned we don't
have a position hady to take any
questions but I want to address just the
bill questions for Tyler Brennan uh
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Brennan um I was
wondering short of um requesting that
kind of intense
evaluation is is was there supposed to
be a fiscal note on this and maybe
that's a question for the chair rather
than for Mr Brennan but I'm just
wondering I don't see a FAL note
so yeah we we do get and I can answer in
terms of fiscal notes in general we get
requests for fiscal notes the the life
and health actual reviews them I take a
look at them just to to make sure that
it's it's um appropriate for for the
audience of the legislature but the the
fiscal notes typically say it may have
an upward pressure on claims it's
indeterminable about how much and we're
only looking at this from a premium tax
point of view so in general they don't
go into a lot of depth there's not the
kind of deep analysis that would be a
part of a mandate review um as a part of
the fiscal note process
questions representative Shapiro has his
hand up representative Shapiro thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr Brennan for
taking my question um in regards to the
Mandate review is that a state part of a
state agency that does that or is that
an independent contract and second part
of the question is you said that part of
that review is looking at Value and cost
does it would it also um evaluate the
effectiveness of the mandates that we're
actually talking
about so the request would come to the
insurance department the insurance
department has a contract with a a
private company um they have analysts
and an act on staff they would produce
their own report um so in a sense it's
it's done by a third party but it would
be done through the insurance department
um the opinions would be theirs the
specific part of the statute which is
RSA 400 a39 b uh it does include a
number of things and it spells out
saying the report shall include at a
minimum and to the extent that
information is available the social
impact of mandating the benefit the
financial impact of mandating the
benefit the medical efficacy of
mandating the benefit the effects of
balancing the social economic and
medical effect efficacy considerations
and for the purpose of this section a
mandated benefit proposals one that
mandates insurance coverage for certain
conditions specific Health Services
specific diseases or certain providers
of Health Care
Services thank you for that incredibly
sure anyone
else representative kerk has his hand up
kerk yeah yes m is very asked I would
just ask I looked at my mailbox I did
not see this testimony from Tyler
Brandon I was wondering if he could
submit what he said and writing if he
has it prepared because it was thorough
and I was taking notes but I'm not sure
I got it all thank
you I would be happy to send my notes
there're in bullet form but they'll
cover what I said that's fine thank
you now the chair calls on Mr Adam
Lerner and he's representing himself and
you've got a couple of minutes
Mr
learner hello can you hear me sir great
so I'm actually not representing myself
uh my name is Adam larner I am the
President of the New Hampshire
acupuncture and Asian medicine
Association we are the the association
of acupuncturist all throughout the
state of New Hampshire uh additionally
I've been in practice since 2005 and I
just want to speak briefly to to uh lend
our association support for the bill as
well as with a clarifying amendment that
we offered in our written testimony that
was sent yesterday uh and that that
clarifying Amendment just goes to um in
in section two of the bill when they're
talking about insurance coverage uh
acupuncture has listed multiple times as
a covered service but in the exact line
when they're talking about uh 20 visits
uh 20 visits uh being approved that
acupuncture has left off that list and
it seems that given it's it's mentioned
in multiple other places it seems like
it was probably uh an afterthought so in
in our written testimony we propose a
clarifying amendment to that but you
know so many people in our state have
been touched by this opioid crisis I I I
know there's so many stories but but as
a practitioner I would be remiss if I
didn't take this quick opportunity to
tell you Michael's story you know
Michael is a patient in a mine and when
I met him he was in his late 40s he was
a a very successful profession in the
Sea Coast Area New Hampshire he had uh
you know beautiful family with two
daughters and and he had a knee injury
and he was prescribed opioids for his
knee injury and he took his prescription
as prescribed and then a couple of
months later he found himself horribly
addicted to the point where he was
trying to score pills at
parties and his addiction I mean it
destroyed his life and I'll never I'll
never forget the day where he was in my
office with tears in his eyes
and now years after the addiction and
been dealing with this for years when he
saw how well acupuncture worked to
manage his pain you know he just he said
I just wish I knew that this was an this
was an option I I I wish I wish I wish
this was something that was available to
me and and knowing and I can tell you
that I have a bunch of these types of
stories and and and and I can guarantee
you that virtually every practitioner in
the state has stories just like this you
know and several of the other folks who
have spoken already have have said that
there have been changes and I think
there probably have been changes in how
these medications have been prescribed
but the the bottom line is the CDC said
that in the year that ended in the
middle of 2020 it was the there were the
most overdoses so the situation really
isn't getting better yet you know so
more changes are necessary and knowing
what we know now I think it's hard to
make any kind of reasonable argument
that we shouldn't be using every tool
that works to help prevent addiction
whenever possible and acupuncture works
you know we we we have lots of evidence
of this now in the written testimony I
sent we sent some really some really
strong references to to studies that
have been done maybe the most compelling
uh you know statement of this though is
that in 2020 after really exhaustive
research in both efficacy and and cost
Effectiveness Medicare decided to cover
acupuncture for 20 visits for low back
pain okay so uh you know
um I I think that I think that's really
really powerful um so thank you so much
for listening you know I'd be glad at at
some later point when when the time is
more appropriate to talk more about
acupuncture with people as as as a
therapy you know it's very old but I
know it's new to a lot of folks as well
um you know a as a therapy it's non
addictive It's very effective and it
would really be my privilege to to to
talk to people about it and show you
about it we've even had several members
of our association has volunteered to
give to give folks uh tours of their
offices thank you sir we're up against
the clock now and I'm going to be
o'clock are there
a
no so we're coming back to this no no
this one's done oh this one's done yeah
no question yeah there is no one
else start one o'
congratulations representative
Pearson yes um I would be happy to mute
the screen for folks that are eating
lunch I would just need someone in the
committee room to unmute when the
committee um
reconvenes it'll be okay it'll be 1 o'
who going to do that um I'll find
somebody that can do it if I can't
figure it out all right 1:00 all right I
now
Lucy
Lu
all
[Music]
so
weird
I just I did it on
theen yes
I I believe we are
[Music]
uned that's really hard for me doing
this is the sound some
people's microphones are so bad I'm just
straining to
understand it's it's when when you're on
a call from home it's better generally
speaking rather than in
this because I haven't had any problems
before today
understanding anybody today has
myar Mr
chair representative Pearson
representative conark yes thank you um I
got a phone call while I was making my
peanut butter and jelly sandwich uh
mayor Andrew Hosmer uh who represents
Anthem had signed up electron Al to
testify on
247 he called me because he never got
recognized he would still like to do so
if you willing to reopen that for a very
short time he has a short
testimony and he is still on the
call yeah I don't see him on my call
list
here yes well that system has some
glitches as we spoke about two days
ago okay and apparently I skipped
somebody else to to all right so we are
out of recess and back it looks like
very briefly please into the hearing on
House Bill 247 and representative kerk
uh who is the person I'm calling on
Andrew
Hosmer all right the chair recognizes
Andrew Hosmer to speak on the bill well
thank you very much uh uh Mr chair and
thank you very much representative kerk
for assisting me there uh good afternoon
chairman Pearson and vice chair Marsh
and members of the Health and Human
Services uh committee it's nice to be
back in front of you and working with
you my name is Andrew Hosmer and I'm
representing Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare
uh New Hampshire's largest not
for-profit Health insurer and serving
over two million customers throughout
New England uh HP um Harvard Pilgrim is
focused on the health and well-being of
our members and always open to
innovative ideas that allow us to better
serve those that we cover um Harvard
Pilgrim currently supports supports the
idea of finding alternatives to the use
of opioids but as written we oppose HB
247 we'll draw your attention to
specifically sections two to five uh we
find that the coverage mandate there is
problematic um just to to be clear we
currently offer plans that cover
Chiropractic Care osteopathic
manipulative treatment and acupuncture
treatment so mandating this type of
coverage seems unnecessary Harvard
program also covers physical therapy and
occupational therapy on all of its plans
Harvard pilgram also covers a range of
safe nonopioid uh medication options and
has been supportive of that for quite
some time uh specifically to the yoga
coverage it reminds us of the bill that
that was filed last year we do not cover
yoga because there is no licensing or
credentialing of yoga instructors unlike
the other services mentioned in the bill
which makes it impossible for us to
determine if an instructor is qualified
Andor effective
uh this also creates concerns about how
um efficacy is determined and I think it
was mentioned by I believe
representative kerk
earlier uh reflecting back on uh the
yoga mandate bill from last session um
these were also the concerns we had last
year and that's why it was recommended
for no further legislation on a 14 to1
vote by the Commerce Committee so uh we
also would agree with um Tyler Brennan's
assessment that this new insurance
mandate create a cost for the state as
Federal Law requires any new insurance
mandate passed by the state to be
covered by the state for any individuals
purchasing insurance on the exchange uh
again though we support innovative ideas
and discussing alternatives to opioids
we oppose HB 247 as written and ask that
um this bill either be Rewritten
retained or and preferably um it by the
committee thank you very much and I
appreciate your the opportunity to speak
would you take a question uh I'll do my
yes seeing no questions thank you for
your testimony
and the chair recognizes Jennifer o
Higgins who got left off the list before
we broke for lunch so with apologies
Jennifer o Higgins from
DHHS and her position is neutral on the
bill are you with us still yes good
thank you thank you and apologies that's
okay so hello I'm Jenny O Higgins I'm
the legislative liaison and Senior
policy analyst for the division of
Behavioral Health within DHHS thank you
for your time today I'm here just to
provide information on behalf of DHHS
okay I'm gonna jump in you got to go
slower because it's distorting the
equipment doing something so a little
slower please I apologize thank
you so HB 247 is very similar to HB 708
from last session and the department was
asked to complete a fiscal note
worksheet on that bill last session but
were not asked for fiscal impact on HB
247 so for this reason we wanted to just
bring to the attention of the committee
that the bill requires DHHS to develop a
voluntary non-opioid directive form and
to create rules around such a form the
bill also amends the provisions in the
insurance statute to require that
insurance provide coverage for these not
these evidence-based not opioid
treatment um the department assumes this
applies to Commercial insur Insurance
and not the department but if it applies
to Medicaid dhjs would need to develop
and Implement a new Medicaid service to
comply with this requirement as the
state's Medicaid Program does not
currently cover Chiropractic yoga
acupuncture treatment so the department
is unable to estimate the cost of a
establishing such a benefit or the
Staffing Resources necessary to
implement
questions thank
you thank you
all and now I realize there are some
people who are trying to um indicate
they would like to testify but um they
didn't get under the wire so I am
closing the hearing on that bill and we
will now open the hearing on
157 repealing the State Health
assessment and State Health Improvement
plan Council and the chair recognizes
Edwards all right I think I'm unmuted
can you hear me
yeah all right uh I don't think you're
able to see me though which is a shame
because I got dressed up at least from
the waist up for this August group so um
uh I have dogs in the house they'll make
a little bit of noise I'm uh I'm
representative Jess Edwards um I uh four
years ago I was sitting where you all
are not in your houses but there in the
L and uh I don't really know much more
than I did then but but uh but I have
been around a while this is my third
term I'm on finance division 3 where the
the division that finances appropriates
money for DHHS and the veterans home I'm
also on uh the HHS oversight committee
um and before I really get going do do
members have uh the email attachment I
sent prior to the meeting it was just
this morning but it was a few hours
ago I think most of living in a meeting
and didn't have access to a
printer okay um I have been polishing
this thing uh so I'll I'll be sending a
an updated version anyways but um so
what uh House Bill 157 does is it
repeals the the the
current um
legislative requirements and
specifications for a state health
assessment that's uh that's in our in
our rsas and it also repeals a brand new
State Health Improvement uh plan Council
my reasons for this if you were to
summarize it it would be uh
redundancy and making sure that the
lines of communication and
accountability are clear uh this is a
this is a bill that uh got I think
caught up in the covid
craziness um and uh the Senate heard it
put it into a large Omnibus Bill uh and
it never came back to the house
apparently for the house to look
specifically at the establishment of
this State Health Improvement Council I
think if you if you had had hearings on
it you you would you would have found
the reasons why we shouldn't have done
this uh it's it's redundant in the sense
that the current IRS
code um requires that uh Community
Hospitals perform ongoing uh assessments
within every three years to go out and
get their Community input to address the
the community uh Public Health needs and
other needs uh of that Community they
put that into a report they provide a
copy of that to uh to
DHHS um and and so uh DHHS all already
has sort of this boots on the ground
Bottoms Up driven set of reports on the
the health assessment of each
community so we created a new new
bureaucracy last summer that's
absolutely
enormous how big is enormous it's so big
that it has to have 17 people just to
have a
quorum now U management study suggest if
you really want an effective committee
uh you try to keep it between five and
seven so 17 as a quorum number is just
uh unwieldy in in my view so we we've
got a pretty large uh uh Council that's
been set up now and and it isn't just
the fact that it's set up so big it's
that that it uh
supplements and stands as a a a side by
side separate organizational structure
that's supposed to do these State Health
assessments and develop the State Health
assessment
plans um and so um the
commissioner uh has this Bolton
bureaucracy that uh needs to be
contended with that is sort of in
between him or her and the public health
employees that the state employs to do
this sort of thing um and so what I'm
going to use a military term but it's
the same whether you go study business
uh organizational uh design and behavior
um the whole concept of unity of command
gets thrown off because you don't have a
clear line of sight from the
commissioner to his Public Health uh um
employees and and and therefore you're
also breaking the expectation of the
governor to be able to reach out and do
a One-Stop shop with uh with his or her
commissioner to find out where things
go interestingly if you go read the
specifics around the
plan the this Council actually has more
Authority than the commissioner does
when it comes to creating this plan
because of the use of the word
sh in the law it says the State Health
Improvement plan shall guide the
department in assessing planning
implementing and monitoring Improvement
in the health and well-being of New
Hampshire's population well that shall
means the commissioner shall take the
plan and implement it and and he or
he I I I'm I'm sorry I keep screwing up
on the gender I I'm from the Midwest
they're all you guys so so the guy is uh
is confused about whether or not um he
or she is in charge of this plan or not
but when the plan is done by the council
the law says it shall be complied with
so um I would say um for those reasons
it's just bad organizational Des design
now if you actually get to the plan
itself um it it it hardcodes to use a
software term it hardcodes things that
uh the plan should cover and strategy
imperatives of the plan it it it it
effectively takes the legislative
priorities of 2020 in the midst of a
pandemic and puts them into the law and
so therefore if we were to come back and
2030 or
2040 uh it's likely that this plan will
have been become kind of stale in the
sense that it's no longer responsive to
the needs of society in the moment
because the the boundary conditions are
very well defined in the law and I think
too well defined I'd say that strategic
planning is a is a key part of why we
hire Commissioners like for example our
Commissioner of DOI t uh he does glay
commissioner glay he does a strategic
Information Technology plan he's not
required to do that by law and and and
and they update and maintain that plan
so that there's an ongoing road map so
that they know what systems they're
going to be replacing what new
functionality they need what sort of
interoperability is
desired but in the next year the next
iteration of the plan if the priority
shift they can do that um so I would say
that uh defining as specifically as has
been done in the law exactly what the
plan should cover is a mistake it
doesn't age well and and and I think
that's why we hire Commissioners to to
to be able to provide that level of
strategic
management if you um are curious about
my claim that
this the health assessment plan is
redundant at the bottom of what I've
provided you I've just copied and pasted
the relevant portion of the IRS code and
and so you can see that commun Community
Hospitals have to do this kind of work
anyways they provide a copy to uh the
commissioner and his or her staff and
and so we have the material that we need
now I have heard some people argue that
well the commissioner just hasn't been
doing it or it's not been a priority to
the commissioner well okay so if you
have poor leadership I can tell you you
it's better to go get better leadership
than it is to add a huge organizational
structure of another 30 35 people to to
to hey hey my dogs are going nut sorry
they're happy though um
so uh you just get better leaders you
get better employees you don't you don't
come up with a redundant parallel
universe to overcome their weaknesses
and and as a member of the I'm almost
done I I know I'm running long I'm so
sorry the the other part of this is uh I
as a member of HHS oversight if there's
a failure of leadership to do this job
well I would hope that the oversight
committee would would be on it and and I
and you and you know that I I suspect as
HHS members that your chairman also
chairs the HHS oversight committee so I
I I'm proposing to you that there are
remedies uh if there's been a problem in
the past to to not have it live into the
future and with that I'm done I'll take
representative representative McKay have
a question of the chair is that you as
co-sponsor I'm sorry sir I can't hear
you are you co-sponsor of this leg yes
does that have any effect on
your I'm not saying a word about it
usually P practice the chair steps
down yes okay I unless I'm really told
otherwise would like to continue but not
speak yeah I just wanted to know what I
were going to be doing this I appreciate
that
so so representative McKay just a
thought on that I didn't coordinate any
of my prepared remarks uh with um with
your chairman he he he was clueless on
what I was going to say and probably
worried in the past when the chair is a
when the chair is a sponsor the chair St
down okay I have
no that sounded like representative
Weber was that for me sir no we're
having a chat here does anyone have
questions for representative
Edwards representative Merchant and
Marsh my hand is not raised
representative Merchant
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and
representative Edwards thank you for
taking my question
um is it my take from what you're
testifying that you're in support of of
a plan like we do in the Department of
Transportation have a 10-year plan so we
actually look at things on a 10-year
Horizon and the same thing we do in
healthcare um or you oppose to the
process to get to the plan and allow the
commissioner to have latitude to develop
the plan but we still want to plan I I I
think I'd say something sort of
different but very similar to your
second set of comments there
representative Merchant I would say that
it is um an inherent and vital task of a
commissioner to do strategic planning
and to do strategic planning well uh and
I think when we go out and we recruit
and we hire a commissioner for DHHS
their ability to think strategically and
to act tactically is a huge part of the
job
qualifications so I just would not
legislatively bind his or her hands to
stipulate exactly what the Contours of
that strategic plan ought to
include or and and and sort of by
assumption what it does not
include Mr chair if I may
chairman yes follow if I may to
represent Edwards I think we're saying
the same thing um that we want to have a
plan yes legislatively we're basically
mandating a plan like we do in
Department
transportation but I'm suppor of the
fact we don't want to get into the nuts
and bolts of how that plan gets created
but we're more concerned with the
outcome than the
process so um as you know as you know
with me handing over this bill to the
committee it's now your bill if if if
you were to say uh that there the that
the part of the statute that demands
that there be a a plan developed um I'd
be fine with that but I would suggest
that you pull out a lot of the kind of
terms and conditions and details and
specifics that have gotten hardcoded
into the bill or the legislation so that
the commissioner has flexibility on on
on the Contours of the plan that's all
it's it's we're it's it's to it's too
much
micromanagement put into law for me to
think it's good
government thank you m representative
any other questions of the
representative representative
Woods uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you representative Edwards for taking my
question um I'm looking at the back side
of your uh a printed testimony you sent
out and uh you referenced the uh IRC
articles um uh What uh facility is
performing each of these uh six tasks uh
and where does that information uh to
whom is that information
transmitted so I understand that all 26
of Our Community Hospitals uh are
required to do this under the IRS code
and that um uh its
distribution I I can't tell you I I have
got to imagine that a a copy would be
available to DHHS for the asking if it's
not already
done but but there's an assumption in my
answer
sir okay well that would be interesting
to follow up whether in fact the these
go to DHHS and currently are used for
Statewide Community planning certainly
each individual facility making a
community plan uh would uh maybe differ
rather
substantially uh from a a Statewide uh
plan uh would seem would would that be
correct I I I wouldn't I wouldn't
dispute that I I would I would say that
when I talked to some members of DHHS uh
prior to this meeting uh there was
concern that uh the department hadn't
been exercising effective leadership in
this area and uh I believe that there
are other checks and balances in the
system that to the extent that this is a
a a priority and a smart thing to have a
strategic plan on that and that an
effective commissioner and the checks
properly thank you yes
representative all right well thank you
very much for your time I'm available uh
for discussion by the committee at your
request and I will be sending an updated
version to of this testimony um but so
thank you so much I'll I'll Stick Around
for until you close out the this
bill the chair calls Dr Marie
ramas representing the Hampshire Medical
Society and as a member of
the
ship advisory which I'm going to take a
stab and say that's the State Health
assessment State Health Improvement plan
advisory Council and I know that because
it's right here on my
text so Mr chair I want Mr chair I need
to speak up for a moment this is
representative kerk just to let you know
I have been in constant communication
with that with Senator Sherman as you
know he was going to be testifying as
well as I will also be testifying he is
still waiting to introduce his prime
Bill and another committee so I'll keep
your apprised as soon as he comes on
much yes good morning Mr chairman may
I
for your oh yes sorry um please make
your presentation thank you very much I
I do hope that uh the committee has
received my written testimony that was
submitted earlier this
morning um in that testimony I go into a
little bit deeper um
explanation of the the wise
behind our current medical system and
how it is Shifting towards a more
value-based
um structure and um it's I I strongly
encourage the committee to to overview
that um before I start uh my
original comments I do want to address a
couple of the um remarks that were made
um by uh the author of this bill um
first of all all as a practicing
physician I want to clarify with um with
the committee that State Health
assessment State Health Improvement
plans are actually required by states to
do in addition to Regional or as we call
them Community Health assessments and so
these are typical processes that are um
best practices that are required um and
re and recommended um particular on the
public health standpoint for public
health um structures to create a plan um
longitudinally for um for their states
um so the the actual committee itself
however was
formed because exactly as um The
Honorable Mr Edwards mentioned because
our Health Care system is terribly
siloed we are
working within a system in the United
States where as a country we spend over
twice as much per capita on Health Care
compared to other industrialized
countries and our health care
outcomes um from life expectancy to
infant and maternal mortality are the
worst compared to our peers in the
world furthermore New Hampshire has the
fourth largest spending per capita on
health care costs in the country and so
we definitely have a problem and part of
that problem is because of the siloed
structure of our health care System
that's known it's been done and it
hasn't been working and so the precise
reason as to Mr Edward's commentary as
to why it is so important that we have a
convening of of um thought leaders who
are representative of the diverse and um
textured uh um community members that
comprise our state is absolutely
integral as a practicing physician I do
not necessarily get Communications from
the public health standpoint on the
decisions that are made on how to
improve the general communities and
populations um Health that is not part
of our current structure of systems the
second thing I'd like to point to the
committee's attention is that um as a
result public health plans don't
collaborate with all of the other areas
that we know contribute to a patient's
health and
well-being um the last thing I want to
um discuss is um he he mentioned an an
interesting phrase of redundancy of
parallel universes and for those who
aren't practicing Physicians I want to
say welcome to my world as a practicing
Family Doctor Who on a day-to-day basis
I have to be on the front line and am
told and dictated by insurance companies
what medications to change my patients
on who have been um well controlled on
their chronic medications I'm constantly
barraged with laws and plans and
policies that um that are made by people
who are although well-intentioned may
not understand the downstream
consequences of their decisions that
directly affect everyday Granite Staters
on a day-to-day basis and so it is
imperative that in this very um
complicated Health structure that we
have both in New Hampshire and
nationally that we have a place where we
can convene all of the stakeholders that
are necessary in um in creating a well
community
um It is Well understood and accepted
within the medical and public health
spaces that the way to improve health
care outcomes reduce overall health care
spending and narrow disparities is to
shift our Focus From the current fee for
service alakar model of Health delivery
to a more Global preventative and
value-based care system and contrary to
some criticism this approach has
actually proven to encourage healthy
economic competition by incentivizing
high quality and lowcost Care in the
market in fact this is precisely why the
center for Medicaid and Medicare
Services has changed its reimbursement
structure to incentivize robust Primary
Care delivery important population
Health outcomes and excuse me improved
population Health outcomes and bolster
coordination of care for patients and
this shift of medical re reimbursement
has not only saved Medicare and private
insurers billions literally dollars a
year more over it means that Granite
Staters also will save money and have
the ability to direct the their care in
the way that they see fit and so our
health and wellness encompasses all
aspects of Our Lives as a matter of fact
um a p a person's health actually is
dictated by more excuse me 80% of a
person's health outcomes is actually
derived outside of when I see them in
the doctor's out office that means how
they live work and play and so along
with its peers as a former Board of
director of the American Academy of
family physicians and a current member
of the aafp The Academy of family
physicians Commission on health of the
public in Sciences I strongly encourage
this committee to consider the vital ity
of the convening of the State Health
assessment State Health Improvement plan
advisory Council as a result this is
actually a body that is
multi-disciplinary that reflects the
textured experience of the residents in
the state it puts into action the very
recommendations of our trusted leaders
that are bipartisan and both on the
health care and economic as well as
public health uh spectrums and certainly
in the face of covid where we are seeing
such Stark Stark disparities it is
important to create a diverse bipartisan
and representative think tank that can
help Define what health and wellness
actually means for the faces of the New
Hampshire um residents and how they
experience an integrated and
concentrated um definition of Wellness
that is what this C this uh this group
is convening is doing it is taking the
already required State Health assessment
and Improvement plan that is required of
the state and we are actually taking it
into our hands as a state in a
collaborative effort to look at all the
stakehold holders that we know affect
health care and we are def defining what
health and what Wellness means for us
and more also we're going to create a
concerted effort where we're using the
same definitions hope Y and recommending
to use the same processes so that we can
finally um we can finally have an
opportunity to uh compare Apples to
Apples because right now we have
multiple sectors in our economy in our
Healthcare delivery structure within the
state that are speaking different
languages although we have the same
goals the New Hampshire Medical Society
is part of this group because our
members need integrated resources to
help our patients stay out of the ER and
enjoy the wonderful amenities our state
has to offer I personally need to equip
my patient with diabetes who is recently
unemployed due to
covid-19 with resources to housing and
Healthy nutrition for her to keep her
sugars controlled and out of and stay
out of the
hospital my my pediatric children that I
take care of they need positive School
experiences to provide them a foundation
that they need to reach their unique
potential because we know by evidence
that appropriate education leads to
healthier adults so we need to weave a
supportive and comprehensive Network
that helps our patients be independent
and involved residents we cannot do
doing because what we've been doing has
not been working we've been spending
more we still have poor outcomes and we
still have disparate outcomes between
different groups in our state
thank you Dr Romas we've got some more
people who want to testify but uh will
you be willing to take questions I
certainly
would thank you for your testimony I do
appreciate it thank you
sir next I'm going to the chair is going
to call on Christine Stoddard
from the bstate primary care Association
a lobbyist it says and you're an
bill good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Christine Stoddard and I am the director
of New Hampshire public policy for by
state Primary Care Association and for
the new members of this committee by
state is a nonprofit 501c3 that works to
expand access to healthc care for all
Granite Staters regardless of insurance
status or ability to pay and as the
primary care
Association for the states of New
Hampshire and Vermont um we work
directly with community health centers
in both States and in New Hampshire that
is 14 health centers with 56 locations
across the state and they serve
approximately 120,000 patients we are
opposed to House Bill 157 which would
repeal the State Health Improvement plan
statutes and the State Health assessment
and health Improvement plan advisory
Council and I think if the last year has
taught us anything there is no such
thing as too much planning when it comes
to Health Care addressing inequities in
our Health Care system and making sure
that people can access healthare when
and where they need it I think two of
the most important components in RSA
126 um a colon
87 is that the ship requires that the
state focus on strategies to improve
health outcomes and reduce inequities
and to strengthen public health and the
Human Service Delivery Systems the fqhcs
which are a subset of Community Health
centers are required by federal law to
treat everyone regardless of insurance
stat St or ability to pay there there
are no exceptions to this Rule and so
the patient populations that they serve
in the state of New Hampshire and across
the country because that is a national
network are very different than the
patients A lot of times that other
providers are serving and so they these
fqhcs and the community health centers
they provide primary and preventive
Medical Dental Oral mental health and
enabling services to um people across
the United States and in New Hampshire
that means one in five uninsured Granite
Staters one in five Granite Staters who
are enrolled in Medicaid 30% of their
patients are Medicaid enroles 35%
commercially insured 20% are Medicare
and 15% of their patients are um
uninsured and so as you can imagine by
those patient demographics they look
very different than what private
practices current usually serve um and
so their work looks different as well
and I think the benefit of having ship
is that you get a broad picture of what
New Hampshire's Health Care system is
who's being served who isn't being
served where the UN mean unmet needs are
and where we can do better and I think
to Doc I would just Echo what Dr Ras
said she was spoton we have to have a
broad understanding of what's going on
in our Health Care system and figure out
a way to fix it and address met needs
and that's exactly what ship
accomplishes I I believe and as you can
tell from the statutes we do have a
member that sits on that um Council but
prior to this being codified in State
Statute this group already existed and
they were doing work behind the scenes
but the statute allows us to present
this information publicly have it
documented in a a more clear fashion and
have it open and available to the public
to
access um it's I I am not a community
needs assessment expert and I'm I'm sure
that Paula minan is probably on this
committee listening to this testimony
and so I'd ask her to clarify um that
part of the statute but I would I would
just remind us that there is more to the
Health Care system than the hospitals
and the acute um care hospitals and Kirk
access hospitals in New Hampshire there
are other healthc care providers that
need to be considered and their patients
more most importantly as we design a
Health Care system that works for
everyone and so um we would ask that the
committee recommend this bill in
expedient to legislate so that the state
can continue to look at the health care
system as a whole and address the needs
and holes where they are so that we can
um begin continue to move forward and
prevent if we can pandemics like the one
that we're currently in so happy to
answer any questions if you have any
take
question thank you representative gay
has a question thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my
question why do you feel like you don't
have a voice without this
if if you look at the and I'm sorry I'm
having a bit of a hard time hearing you
so I'm I'm going to assume what you
asked and please correct me if I'm
wrong um if you look at the bill it
talks
about the community needs assessment
being every three years performed by
Community
Hospitals I think that by having a ship
you get a broader view of what's going
on in the Health Care system because
is healthc care providers treat very
different populations based on their
needs and so if you look at the patients
that are treated by an
fqc and for those of you that don't know
fqhcs have to be located in what are
called medically underserved areas which
means that there is a a shortage of
certain types of Health Care Providers
this could be in an urban area it could
be in a rural area in our
country it doesn't necessarily have to
be in a a um small city or town in
northern New Hampshire they exist in
Manchester as
well the ship allows you to have a
broader view of what's happening and not
just use the community needs assessment
questions
thank you very much mresa Shapiro has a
question I'm sorry who has
representative Shapiro representative
Shapiro ask your
question yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking the question um you
have described the very um idealistic
about idealistic Vision as did um Miss
Ras about um changes bold changes that
could come out of this Council
um which I would tend to um agree with
the need for those kinds of changes what
is the mechanism by which an advisory
Council such as this actually
creates um change in the health
system so DHHS might be better able to
answer this question but our
participants and by state has
participating did in this process in the
past um find Value in that you have
voices that are managing our Healthcare
System um coming into a virtual room if
you will and and participate I'm sorry
my son is trying to break into my office
give me a
second I apologize the fun of working
from home right with small children who
are doing remote
School uh you have people participating
ating in a in a virtual hearing and
hearing what is going on in the other
service areas and so you're able to have
a better understanding of what other
types of providers and populations are
experiencing have that documented and
have the state be able to look back and
use that document as a Guiding Light to
where we need to move the state
forward it also helps people um develop
an understanding of where we lacking and
and as you know and as you've seen in
the news from the pandemic there are
populations even in New Hampshire that
are being very disproportionately
affected by the pandemic and the
pandemic's amplifying things that were
already happening and so by documenting
this we can um go back and reference it
and move
forward followup followup so what I
assume from what you've just said that
um it would be likely that there would
be ideas for legislation that would come
out of this
Council that is how I would use it and I
I Envision that is how my members that
participate um view it it to me it is a
guide book and and how we can improve
our service delivery system in New
questions is Senator Sherman on the
meeting
yet yes he just texted me he is here now
and uh so he and I both are available
Sherman thank you Mr chair and uh as
always when I'm in house Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs I
feel back at
home having served on the committee for
two terms
um this is probably in my book one of
the most important areas of work that we
have
done looking at how we deliver Health
Care in the state of New Hampshire I was
in the house when Co Sunset and this
absolutely to
co it's not regular
it's not uh and so this is not uh Co
related I also have participated in our
Hospital uh assessments Community needs
assessments and while very effective it
targets each of the uh hospitals and
does not um does not look at the state
as a
whole um so so many years ago when I was
in the house or several years ago we did
uh oh by the way I'm sorry I didn't
introduce myself I'm state senator Tom
Sherman District 24 11 towns on the Sea
Coast I'm also a practicing
gastroenterologist at exitor
hospital um so when we did a um a hard
look at healthare in New Hampshire one
of the things that keeps coming back to
me is that there really is no way to
look at um not just health care but
wellness and
prevention um and support across all the
populations towns rural areas cities um
we just haven't done that as a state um
except through this mechanism of State
Health assessment and State Health
Improvement plan so fundamentally the
two drivers of this are one one to
improve the health of the state by
looking at where there are gaps and
where there could be uh
improvements but also how do we do that
as efficiently as possible how do we
look at where there may be redundancies
where there may be multiple people
working on the same process and that is
cost saving we have one of the most
expensive healthare systems in the
country our state we spend more on
health care our insurance is expensive
our cost sharing is
prohibitive and there's a reason for
that and we don't understand all of the
reasons for that there are certainly
Insurance there are but this
understanding of how do we provide
support for people in public health and
health care across the state is
something that really we we don't have a
good handle on but the State Health
assessment will allow us to pull that
together understand it um with no power
for regulation but certainly a power to
say well how can we do it that's what
the state health Improvement plan is all
about is how do we do a better job how
do we coordinate care how do we close
gaps and none of that is telling anybody
what they have to
do it's making
it's an advisory
Council but if successful the goal will
be over time to lower the cost of Health
Care improve the quality and improve the
efficiency and that's why I think of
this Council number one it is an amazing
group of people and I would invite any
of you to come join us at our next
meeting uh several of you actually sit
but it is an amazing group of people all
dedicated to doing a better job of
providing health care and the provision
of Public Health in the state of New
Hampshire and one of my goals with this
is to have an understanding of how we do
that what are the inner connections and
can can we do a better job of those
connections but this is not
regulatory it's not telling people what
to do do it's understanding where we are
and making recommendations on how we can
do what we do
better with that I'm happy to take any
questions representative Weber thank you
Mr chairman and thank you senator for
taking my
question I just wanted to see if you
could give us a little more clarity
about how the statute that we're
proposing to repeal
works as I read it
it says that the commissioner of the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall in consultation with the health
assessment and State Health Improvement
plan and briery
Council develop a state health
assessment and a state health
Improvement plan so am I not correct in
thinking that the actual development of
any plan is left to the commissioner and
the role the council is advisory and
consultative you you are correct in that
thank you very
much anyone else with a
question representative Marshall's a
question representative
Marsh uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you senator for appearing before our
committee it's a pleasure to see you
again and I want to apologize once again
for the scheduling conflicts that have
caused me to miss some of the uh uh
State Health assessment State Health
Improvement plan meetings but th this is
my question um you you wrote this
legislation and I would like to know if
you feel the provisions of RSA 126a
872 are sufficiently prescriptive to
predetermine the outcome of the State
Health assessment and do you see as
others have testified before us this
morning that the State Health
Improvement plan is actually a vehicle
to legislate quote bold changes in our
say I would say it is a it's not really
a vehicle it's a vehicle for providing
recommendations that are felt by The
Advisory Council would be to the benefit
of our system both the public health
system and the health care delivery
system but not um some of them may not
be so bold some of them may be
just sort of oh this isn't happening you
know some of the because we have really
very little idea of all the different
facets and all the
different uh types of of Public Health
and Health Care delivery in our state
which is part of the assessment portion
of this we have we we will likely find
areas where tweaks are necessary where
connections are need to be made um
others there may be bold recommendations
but I tend to think a little more on the
also on the pragmatic side you know what
else can we learn well suppose we learn
that there's a community that has no
access to some type of health care
whether it's mental health substance use
those kind of things and we didn't
previously recognize this that's not
bold
that's filling a gap and in the end
filling that Gap will decrease the cost
in the state of New Hampshire because of
all the costs of untreated illness so I
see it as uh I think there's a lot of
possible outcomes we may also find that
we do everything perfectly and nothing
is
needed right so
it's I I don't go into this with a with
an answer I go into it with a question
and that's what I'm hoping to come out
with are some answers to the
questions but I don't know all the
questions that's part of the beauty of
of an assessment is that you find out
things if you do it correctly which I
believe they're doing a phenomenal job
you find out things that you never knew
necessarily were a problem but you also
find that you're doing other things
really really well uh one other benefit
to this is that if you do a Statewide
assessment one of the problems with
Healthcare in almost the entire
country is that we
are um is that it tends to be very
local so somebody may be doing a really
great job with a really Innovative
system in one part of the state and the
other part of the state doesn't know
that that's happening so that's why
doing a Statewide Health
assessment is something where we all o
can see who's doing a great job can we
help another part of the state use that
as a model for the other part of the
state and do
Improvement not by Reinventing the wheel
program thank you Senator and Mr
chairman may I have a followup May uh
thank you and I I agree with you I
really would like to see our health care
System improved um and uh I I do look
forward to thing that happened one way
or the other but one of the issues that
I think many members see with this bill
is that this legislation never had a
house hearing and the house members
never truly participated in the
development of the charge to this uh
Council uh and perhaps the uh committee
might consider using this bill as a
vehicle to tweak that charge in such a
way that uh it may more broadly reflect
the concerns of all the members of our
committee is that something that you
could support and would you be willing
to work with us in doing that I'd be
happy to uh look at um the yeah you know
there there were several pieces of
legislation that Co kind of steered a
different direction and certainly the
bill was intended to come before both
Chambers fully and have input um I would
much prefer to see a bill improved than
repealed when I believe it's doing great
great work to start out with so I would
be absolutely open
to um possible changes that would
improve the work we're doing but I think
the work we're doing and you're a part
of that is really a great job what I
would not want to see this become is is
a Regulatory Commission I don't think
that's an appropriate role I think the
advisory component is where we should be
sitting um but I do think there there
may be other things that certainly I
didn't think of or the commission hasn't
thought of yet that you all may come up
with that you'd like to see looked at as
well by the commission by the council I
I thank you for that and I see that as
being an excellent outcome of this bill
so I would support that as well so thank
you very
much further questions for the
senator
hearing none thank you Senator and it's
always a pleasure to have you back with
your old crew thank you very much and
everybody take care yep the chair
Futures hi can you hear
me
yeah hi Holly Steve I'm the health
policy coordinator of new Futures and
for the uh the newer members uh new
Futures is
a
nonpartisan nonpartisan
nonprofit
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all New Hampshire residents
uh as you can tell it's been a while
since I've been in front of a committee
because uh roll off my tongue um
chairman and members of the committee
it's a pleasure to be here with you
today and I appreciate the opportunity
uh to
testify um this this afternoon um new
Futures is in opposition to House Bill
um understand that the house um feels
that they did not have any input on this
uh in this particular bill because of
everything that happened last year um so
you know our position obviously reflects
um the bill that came uh before you and
that is before you um certainly not uh
representative Marsh's uh recommendation
at at looking at modifying the
statute um I don't want to take up too
much of your time because one I sent you
written testimony and two the folks that
went before me know a lot more about
this stuff than I do but I did just want
to to point out the fact that
um there's a reason that the community
needs assessments are in the IRS code
and that is because it is a requirement
of the nonprofit
hospitals um to participate in that
process and I know if if uh Paula
minahan is on your list behind me I'm
sure she can explain this more fully to
you but there are three hospitals um
particularly ports Portsmouth Regional
Hospital Parkland in Dairy and uh
frisbee in Rochester that are four
profit
entities those entities do not have to
do a community needs
assessment um so if
the state was to
Simply compile the community needs
assessments done by the hospitals we'd
be have some huge gaps um around the
state
particularly
in uh the Sea Coast Area in both
Portsmith and Rochester and uh right and
dairy um which are are pretty uh
populated places um those areas no
longer have a community needs assessment
being done unless those hospitals are
doing them voluntarily it certainly is
not a
requirement um so so this is not a
complete duplicative process uh by any
means and also um I think as was
mentioned but I just want to hammer home
the point that um you can't really take
all of the need these needs assessments
put them on a table and see what's going
on in the state because you they're not
comparing Apples to Apples um you're
comparing apples to grapes and so you
don't really have a sense of what the
whole picture look looks like around the
state if you're simply taking 23
individual needs assessments that are
being done as a basically an exchange um
for being considered nonprofit not
having to pay an income tax um many of
the
services um and or activities that the
hospital hospitals provide in exchange
are Financial type um
activities um and again I hope Paula is
on this call to be able to explain this
uh more fully than I do because I don't
want to step on her toes um or say
anything that's uh contrary to what the
hospital uh Association would say about
their members um but I think that the
community needs assessments would be
lacking a lot of information um that the
State State Health assessment wouldn't
be lacking so I just want to you know
wrap up by saying first you know you
have my written testimony um would
encourage you to read it if you have any
questions certainly reach out to me um
secondly um as uh Christine alluded to
but I just want to uh expand a little
bit that you know if there's anything
that the ongoing addiction crisis Mental
Health crisis and covid-19 pandemic have
taught us it is that New Hampshire could
benefit from having a stakeholder
engaged process that's overseen by the
legislature to assess and develop a plan
to improve health outcomes reduce reduce
Health disparities and strengthen Public
Health and Human Service Delivery
Systems and codifying the council
codifying the Shaw and the ship is the
only way to make sure that that's done
and make sure that it's done with
legislative oversight um and with that
um just simply ask that as it's written
um we request that the committee um Vote
itl or inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill
157 um however if there is an appetite
to look at doing a an amendment to add
to it um uh with the House's input
certainly um you know new Futures would
consider being in support of that um if
we were able to see the amendment so
with that uh concludes my testimony and
I'll answer any questions if anybody has
questions
can
okay
um seeing that there are no
questions the chair calls recognizes
DHHS
hello can you
hear can you hear me yeah wonderful so I
think I I think I'm on the phone and on
the computer which is very confusing so
yes okay uh good afternoon uh
representative Pearson and committee
members um my name is Lisa moris I'm the
director of the division of Public
Health Services uh through the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I'm speaking today on behalf of the
department uh in which is in opposition
to this Bill HP 157 which repeals the
State Health assessment and State Health
Improvement plan Council in addition to
my oral testimony you should have
written testimony from me and from uh
the deputy director uh Patricia Tilly
which was sent to you
yesterday RSA 126a colon 87 and 88
directs DHHS through the work of a
multi- sector Council of subject matter
expert and leaders within their fields
to to complete a state health assessment
and State Health Improvement plan for
the State of New Hampshire you also
received a membership list uh with uh my
testimony so that you can see the
membership of uh this particular Council
and um uh the fact that it uh it's a
broad geography as well as a broad uh
sectoral
representation this law creates an
assurance that the department regardless
of leadership will use a datadriven
inclusive process for assessing planning
implementing monitoring Improvement in
the health and well-being of New
Hampshire's population legislative
oversight of this process further aligns
the planning with budget and policy
priorities HB 157 identifies two points
of concerns that I would like to address
it's true that Community Hospitals by
law must complete Community needs
assessments every three years the
concern is stated in HP 157 is that the
State Health assessment is duplicative
of this process rather than being
duplicative a state health assessment
Aggregates and aligns Community
strengths while identifying
opportunities for more efficient and
effective use of State resources across
state agencies over the past seven years
our community public health networks
across the state have collaborated with
some hospitals and Community leaders in
performing Community needs assessment as
required by federal and state statute
for hot nonprofit hospitals if we
already we've already discussed
information obtained from these
assessments are utilized in the
development of Regional Community Health
Improvement plans rather than being
duplicative the health assessment and
health Improvement plan provide needed
data for completion of these Regional
assessments and as stated earlier
Aggregates and aligns community straints
and identifies opportunities for more
efficient and effective use of State
resources across state agencies um it's
also important to mention that not all
hospitals um uh participate in this
community needs assessment process that
some hospitals do this uh with their
communities and some hospitals do it in
isolation of their communities the
reason that they do it is stated earlier
is because it's required by by law both
federal and state law the goal for the
completion of these assessments is for
hospitals to do community benefits plans
um these are plans that are that are uh
Focus solely on um hospitals and the
work that hospitals will do um alone uh
sometimes with communities other times
um in terms of where they will put some
of their
resources the other point of concern
identified in HB 157 is regarding the
certificate of need process which was
repealed in
2016 the State Health assessment will
focus on four categories health status
in outcomes access to opportunity
community and social connectivity it
will highlight birth outcomes vaccine
rates chronic disease and health status
and will focus on access utilization un
cost certificate of need will not be
considered as part of this process we
all benefit from a predictable structure
for which data driven priority setting
uh is built by building transparent
routine and consistent process for
assessment driven by experts in their
fields will be able to set and achieve
ambitious goals and drive Innovation I
speak for the Department and ask you for
your support to continue this important
work as codified in the rsas for the New
Hampshire State Health assessment and
State Health Improvement plan and I'd
like to end by talking about the
leadership within the department as
mentioned earlier um our commissioner
and all our leadership believes that um
it's important for us uh to get input
from um uh subject matter expert and
leaders across the state in various
representing various sectors to ensure
that uh when we um have and finalize a
community health Improvement plan um
that um it has uh it is in it has uh as
part of it and included in it um all of
the areas um uh of expertise um through
uh with the goal of improving Health
outcomes so I'll stop right here and
take any questions that you may have any
questions
represent I'm curious as to what are
your
concrete after you do assessments which
I can assume is an ongoing
thing what do you do with your
discussions what actions do you suggest
what is the value add of the information
with so um thank you for that question
uh so I heard most of it I believe but
um after the assessment what we'll do is
we'll take a look we'll have all the
assessment information analyzed and from
that assessment information we'll
identify priorities within the state uh
based upon the needs that's identified
and we will take those needs and we will
begin to address what some of the plans
are uh that will meet those priorities
and needs we will uh look at and
incorporate the existing uh state plan
so we have a state plan on Aging we have
a 10-year Mental Health Plan um uh we
will take those existing plans where in
the development of a housing and
homeless plan we will take those plans
and incorporate them into the final
State Health Improvement plan so we are
not um uh re inventing the wheel uh we
hope that uh what will come of this uh
may be will be a better integrated
system uh we will work more efficiently
right now uh we tend to um work in uh I
think across the state in uh more siloed
ways although uh Regional planning is
becoming uh more present than it has
been in the future but this will further
um enhance that integrated work that we
do on the state level but also on the
community level and uh although this is
a DHHS plan uh this is actually the
state plan for New Hampshire which uh
incorporates other departments across
the state of New Hampshire uh into the
final draft of the plan um so
communities can use this information as
they are developing their Regional plans
um and also um for the legislature to
take a look at to see how we can
incorporate uh some of the uh the state
St Health Improvement um goals and
objectives into legislation when needed
um but really what this is is this is um
a um a a guide book for change as
opposed to uh a mandate for
question well I was just wondering of
what sort of suggestions do you make is
it like well you need another hospital
here you need a another clinic here or
you need more providers who need a
certain need like drug
addiction yeah I'm interested in the
concrete things that you're trying to
make
happen sure so you know we're just in
the process of uh compiling information
for our for the health assessment the
health assessment and its analysis will
guide uh the development of the State
Health Improvement plan um and that
Health Improvement plan uh will provide
recommendations to the department and
across the state and two communities
around sort of uh around the goals and
objectives um and priorities they should
be looking towards so I don't want to uh
I don't I I I don't know uh what that uh
Health Improvement plan is going to say
um uh we will be utilizing um
evidencebased and promising practices uh
in
recommendations um you know an example
um could be um uh as somebody had
mentioned earlier uh you know looking at
where there are gaps in certain Services
across the state of New Hampshire um uh
are all vulner are all populations
having the same access uh to care uh so
it could be uh there would be a variety
of uh recommendations based upon uh the
priorities based upon the health
questions yes representative
kushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mrs moris I I'm
wondering what is the extent if any of a
partnership between this Council and the
can can can you uh somebody repeat that
question I apologize I could not hear I
heard Regional Planning Commission I
heard partnership but that's all I heard
now um I was just wondering what is the
extent of a relationship if there is one
um between this Council and the New
Hampshire region Regional planning
commissions so we do have representation
from the municipal Association but I
think uh we don't have anybody from the
regional planning commissions and I
think that's a a great um thought is to
uh pull uh Regional Planning Commission
membership in or uh to ensure that um as
we provide Outreach to the communities
um to um address their needs um through
conversation um that we would uh be able
to pull them in at that time that's
wonderful thank
you did representative Merchant have a
question yes Mr chairman thank you um my
question to director
Morris I think we're all in agreement
that healthc care system we have today
is very
fragmented I want to commend this bill
for pulling together stakeholders from
various silos to have a healthy
conversation I think sharing that
knowledge is very very constructive
however I've heard a couple of times
that it's datadriven evidence Bas if you
will so my question to yourself or
someone else on this group what data is
being collected to help guide
evidence-based decision making and how
does one go about collecting that
data so um we have a contracted with uh
UNH Institute of Health policy and
practice to um work with us to um
identify what areas that we want to
assess and uh as um Senator Sherman
mentioned I encourage you to attend one
of the meetings we really have um uh
some robust conversations um and we take
the time that's needed to be able to
think this through well so there are
many um data sources that we're looking
at uh across the Health Care System
across the social service system um and
even outside of those systems to be able
to um uh compile data uh that we feel is
necessary in order to get and understand
uh what's happening in the across the
state of New Hampshire but we're also
survey we're also Pro doing Outreach to
different communities uh within the
state so right now uh we will be sending
out a survey through the UNH Survey
Center that has been vetted for many
weeks by uh the council um
and um that provides not sort of
perceptive information around um
people's perceptive and actual
information around people's experiences
uh in terms of um accessing uh the
health care and um other areas that we
know lead to um to health outcomes um
after that we are going to be uh
reaching out into the community during
covid it's made it uh much more
complicated
uh to different uh uh different groups
within communities to be able to have
deeper level conversations with them
it's quite possible that um that we will
uh that the the first um State Health uh
uh Improvement plan will identify gaps
in the data that we have and part of the
priorities may be to um identify ways
that we can um uh we can access that
data so um uh if there are gaps in our
understanding so that we can have uh
good planning for the future um so um
evidence-based practices so for um for
just about every every sector every uh
social and uh Health Care uh entity
there are evidence-based practices
there's also promising practices uh that
uh may not yet be evidence-based that
we'll be looking at um and as Senator
Sher I believe it was Senator Sherman
who said there may be really wonderful
things going on with really good
outcomes um in certain areas of the
state that we want to know about um and
replicate throughout the rest of the
State of New Hampshire or at least
inform others in the state of New
Hampshire about those promising
practices Mr chairman if I may make a
comment followup yes um what I'm hearing
is
that the proposed bill would only allow
for information coming from the
IRS um Community needs assessment and I
think what I'm what I've heard is that
the robustness of what's being collected
far exceeds those data
elements um and therefore it sounds like
we're taking the opportunity potentially
here to narrow down the data that we're
going to collect to only that with
Community assessments and that's only
for not for profit houss thank you
sir
any further questions and please make
sure there questions we'll have time in
the exec session to um give Reflections
anyone in the which case thank you very
much
um is Morris and the chair now
recognizes uh well before I recognize
anybody just please uh we've gone on a
long time and we've heard a lot and I
don't know how much more new there is to
hear so if you have anything new that
you can add to this that doesn't repeat
and underscore uh that would be very
appropriate uh with that the chair
recognizes uh representative Jerry kerk
okay thank you very much Mr chair can
you hear me okay yeah okay great um Yes
actually I did want to go back I I sent
some written testimony complete with
some graphs and so on but I do want to
actually move a little bit into
something else for a moment and that is
the that indeed a lot of
12687 was misrepresented in the in the
bill introduction because indeed it says
clearly that it's a consultative body it
is indeed called an advisory Council for
a reason it is not regulatory it has uh
it is not certificate of need and that
is uh so that was a problem as also
stated by representative Edwards that it
was huge and unwieldy it's not unwieldy
at all we've had a very good turnout at
each of our meetings oh I should say I'm
sorry for the record I'm representative
Jerry kerk I'm a retired uh orthopedic
surgeon I'm also currently the vice
chair of the sh ship advisory Council
anyway so it's not un wieldy the large
membership lends A diversity of opinions
that will allow a development of a much
more comprehensive assessment and plan
than we would get from just the
hospitals um so anyway the the main
thing to understand and I'm going to
take a slightly different tack on this
than some of the other people there's an
assertion in the statement of intent of
HP 1557 that allowing increased
competition will reduce health care
costs but that is simply not true and
anybody that has looked at any of the
international um data knows that the
United States has the most free market
competitive Health Care system of all
the developed countries but the
comparison demonstrate that again as Dr
Rama said we spend twice as much as
other developed countries with the
poorest outcomes and I have some rather
interesting intelling graphs over time
uh which I sent out in my written
testimony for uh just the simple thing
of our what we spend and our life
expectancy we're at the top for spending
the bottom for life expectency
expectancy now the point of that is very
simple competition and free markets work
great for Consumer products where you
can shop for the best deal and decide
not to purchase an item if the price is
too high but healthc care is not that
it's infrastructure it doesn't function
like a free market and even if we solve
the problem of cost transparency it is
very difficult to do comparison shopping
you're lying in an emergency room with a
broken ankle heart attack or an inflamed
appendix and you can't choose not to
purchase the appendectomy you need just
because the price is tooo high so again
the goal of this plan this assessment
group and plan is to improve health care
outcomes and strengthen Delivery Systems
if we work on improving management of
chronic illness we will save substantial
health care costs by preventing
avoidable hospitalizations and that's
the phraseology that is usually used for
example it's far cheaper to treat
hypertension with a cheap generic
anti-hypertensive than it is to treat a
stroke that results from the
uncontrolled hypertension that includes
clud the costly acute care the
rehabilitation and the long-term
disability I do find it particularly
troubling to see this bill come forward
when Co has clearly revealed the
weakness of our fragmented competitive
free market system that has led to some
of the worst outcomes in the world and
is endangering all of us it's not a
matter of only endangering those who
don't have access it endangers all of us
by increasing the spread of Co of the
the virus now the other thing that I
here's this angle that I'm want to hit
on this because since I think doc Jess
Edwards was specifically talking about
the free market issue and about how this
was against that it really isn't because
if we do accept our current policy of
free marketing financing for the
significant portion of our health care
System the data that ship generates for
improving healthc care delivery will
actually assist competition it states
clearly in section 126
a87 that this information is public
publicly available and it is a public
resource for decision making the bottom
line is the nonprofits hospitals Health
Care Systems providers and insurers will
be able to make use of the data to
determine how to deliver Health Care in
a more cost-effective fashion and
thereby decrease costs and increase
quality so if we look at our current
feif for service system that pays for
production uh rather than uh healthare
rather than Healthcare outcomes there's
no incentive for providers to control
costs so what's the people that have
stepped in center for Medicare and
Medicaid services and the insurers they
have had to step in to try to lead the
way and trying to control costs with
various payment reforms and value-based
payment reforms such as an Accountable
Care Organization that holds providers
accountable for outcomes will drive
competition amongst providers for cost a
effective delivery of healthare so
indeed this the work that's being done
by this is not anti-competitive it is
not anti-free Market it actually will
enhance the free market competition by
giving this data to the provider groups
and to the insurers so they can begin to
then develop systems that work the most
effectively I think you all know that I
would really very much prefer that we
not have an insurance-based system but
that's what we got and this doesn't go
against it it helps it it'll help gather
and drive the decision- making gather
data to drive the decision- making as to
where the efficiencies can be realized
for both insurers and
providers the bottom line is the
advisory Council should finish its task
to provide data to guide our decisions
thank you very
much thank you representative kerk any
representative representative Marsh has
his hand up representative Marsh
uh thank you Mr chair and and thank you
representative for taking my question
before I give you my question
representative Edwards did ask me to say
that he his remarks said nothing about
the free market I don't know whether
that's true or not I'd have to listen to
his tape uh but my question to you has
to do with the charge to the uh sha ship
Council um and you and I have discussed
on many occasions that there are issues
with the cost of healthc care uh in New
Hampshire and in spef specifically the
cost of healthcare to individuals which
was the subject of an earlier bill that
we heard today uh would you be
supportive of the idea of changing the
charge to this Council to include
looking at the cost of Health Care and
insurance coverage in New Hampshire as
compared to other states and the fiscal
stability and sustainability of the
various entities that provide Healthcare
in New
Hampshire um thank you for your question
actually though we answer the first part
first it was not in at repres pres 's
testimony it was in the statement of
intent where he said allowing increased
competition to reduce health care costs
in New Hampshire so I was not speaking
to what his testimony was but speaking
to what the bill said the first part of
mine was about his testimony where he
stated that this was mandating what the
commissioner had to do with response to
your request about changing some of the
um um charges I think we certainly could
look at those I think looking at our
state and comparison to others may be a
difficult one because I'm not sure how
we can get the data well from some of
the other states in a comparative
fashion but I would certainly not oppose
that because I think again the goal of
this is decrease costs and improve
Healthcare co uh outcomes it's really
the the triple aim that Don Berwick
talks about uh for healthc care reform
we want to decrease cost but still
improv quality and so whatever we can do
to do that but you know that's that's
that is certainly not this bill but it
could certainly be a vehicle as we
mentioned earlier thank
you I thank you any other questions of
Representative
kerk I have lost my sheet with those who
are not yet testified but signed
up aha
um nope those are all checked off I had
a few others that have signed up
recently and I'd like a little help in
knowing who they
are absolutely we have Joan ask ask Asim
I'm sorry if I pronounced that
incorrectly yes thank you let's bring
her
forward Miss ask if you just um there
you go okay um so my name is Joan ashim
and I'm recently retired um I'm a nurse
and I was the executive director of the
New Hampshire Public Health Association
I'm representing that Association which
is membership organization of public
health professionals across the state um
and we are opposed to the bill I want to
point out that I was around years ago
when we developed our first state um
plan in New Hampshire and I also was on
the leadership team developing a similar
plan in the state of con concut um and
also I was a member of the public health
accreditation board which is a board
that accredits state and local Health
departments and one of the major
requirements for that accreditation is a
state health Improvement plan and State
Health assessment this plan that's in
the legislation follows the
recommendations for best practices for
State Health assessment and State Health
Improvement plan further those the the
accreditation standards and this
legislation call for reporting in on
outcomes and accountability so there is
that piece of it um I I I did want to
say you know a couple of people have
asked about well what might we see come
of this and I just thought I could give
you a couple of concrete examples that
came out in Connecticut um one was a
policy change and that was to have
standardized housing uh uh statutes
across the state so that each each
community
looked at the same things when they
looked at housing standards now you
might not think that would be in a
health Improvement plan but if you think
about the ramifications of poor housing
asthma lead poisoning and and injuries
so so that was a public health policy
change that was recommended on the other
hand there are programmatic changes that
might be recommended for example we know
that if women have babies too close
together that it
decreases it can um account for poor
outcomes for the baby so one of the
other Pol uh program practices that was
being undertaken is to talk to women
when when they're not pregnant about
when you know how do they want to have
children how frequently do they want to
have children so that's a change in
programming so I think that that these
changes can be made on a number of
different levels um that can change the
health of the population of the
state um I I wanted to reiterate what Dr
Ramos said that only 80 only 20% of of
our health is dependent on upon Health
Care the other 80 is based on the
opportunities that we have to eat
healthy to exercise to abstain from
smoking um and healthy behaviors and so
this plan helps to focus on those root
causes and also allows for that
integration for example of Housing and
health care to work together so that
they're not working in silos and they
can you can change housing standards so
that you can have improved tell so I
will I submitted written testimony I
just did want to speak to some of the
questions that were raised and um to say
that um we uh oppose and ask that you
oppose this Bill thank you very much
witness representative gay thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question how much does it cost per year
for this uh organization to
function for the council to
function
yes I I mean there's no funding
allocated for the council to function
people are doing it either on volunteer
time or as a part of their job so I mean
I don't think there's any additional
costs for the council itself
representative KARK or Marsh you might
know
otherwise uh
yes representative kerk yes there was
some money allocated in the original
bill but I think that has to do with the
um State Health Improvement plan I don't
think it has to do with the advisory
Council I do not know that with
certainty but for example I mean we are
there in an advisory fashion and I'm
assume there must be some contract
between DHHS and the Health Institute of
policy at New Hampshire at UNH because
they probably want to get paid for their
work but the rers are doing it for our
usual High wages that we get as
representatives and um other volunteers
for example Dr ramas Who testified
earlier she doesn't get paid anything
she just shows up and does her work like
snow representative snow you had your
hand up need to un you gotta un me there
you are there you
go um I'm a little fuzzy on details
about this but when I first came to the
house
I uh four or five years ago uh there was
a plan of foot based on some planning
efforts that were going on under the
former commissioner before Lori shabet
took over and that plan included
changing the districts the Mental Health
Centers uh community health centers uh
Behavior Uh uh developmental disability
centers and so forth all have different
regions that they serve and his plan was
to take the state most of whom had even
10 or 11 districts combined them into
just seven districts and they were doing
some planning within all seven of those
districts and it's still ongoing uh
there's directors and planning staff
that are working and all those areas and
yet we've heard very little about how
much progress was made how that fits
into this plan and it might be
worthwhile getting a report from them is
this still a reality is this still
something going on about dividing that
up it might help us in our thinking
thank
you I don't know if that question was
for me but if if Lisa Morris is on I
think she could answer that better than
can you hear me yes yes great hello
again everybody
um so uh thank you uh representative
snow for your question um prior to so
you're right there were although I was
in the community at the time there were
uh discussions on the state level uh and
even when I came into the state four
years ago relative to regionalization
and what that should look like and then
of course covid hit and um we although
we have a lot of other work other than
co co has really um delayed that
continued
conversation um but we will have it um
will this particular plan um discuss
that I I I really I don't know uh
uh because we're just not there yet um
it could possibly make some
recommendations related to it uh but uh
it's too early to
tell thank
questions in that case the chair
recognizes Rebecca sky from the
Aging
good
afternoon um are you able to hear
me yes okay great thank you good
afternoon let me introduce myself I am
Rebecca Sky I am serving as the
executive director for the New Hampshire
State Commission on Aging the charge of
the commission as established by rsa1
19p is to De to advis the governor and
the general court on policy and planning
related to aging board thinking public
policy will ensure that all of us have
the opportunity to thrive and be valued
in New Hampshire as we age to that end I
hope to get uh we get to know one
another better throughout this
legislative
session the state Commission on Aging is
in opposition to this bill uh the
granite state were one out of every five
of us is over the age of 60 has the
second oldest population in the N Nation
we are an aging State and an aging
nation and an aging world if we are
Adept at adapting to this demographic
shift we can support well-being later in
life so that more of us are able to
continue to contribute to our families
and communities over the Long Haul there
is a longevity dividend to be realized
in this longevity era both economically
and socially thoughtful assessments and
planning at the local Regional and state
level will enable communities in the
state to engage in coherent consistent
action and leverage more resources to
address the conditions to create the
opportunity for health and
well-being coordination at these various
levels of governance and community
structure results in Greater planning
efficiency and better outcomes we do not
believe this process to be reiterative
of the community health needs assessment
required by Community Hospitals it
should build upon those assessments to
create greater value for all communities
in New Hampshire we also find the
process not at all alike the bygone
certificate of need process as the the
State Health assessment and State Health
Improvement plans are advisory rather
than regulatory as has been mentioned in
the past and um really a state health
Improvement plan is a rallying vehicle
to focus resources efficiently
around the comprehensive nature of the
assessment and plan go far beyond
healthc care infrastructure that was
managed with the certificate need
process the determinance of Health are
much broader um than the healthc care
that is available in our communities the
planning process as outline seeks to
address all that drives Health possibly
including housing Transportation social
isolation all issues that that matter to
all of us as we
age I also heard concerned that last
year statute creates an administrative
burden uh limiting possibilities to the
strategic planning by DHHS in contrast I
suggest that the broad template in the
RSA allows DHHS to jump past rudimentary
process decisions to quickly get at the
important meat of strategic
planning um as mentioned previously the
Shaw and the ship process have has
happened in the past another advantage
of codifying this process in state law
that makes the process it is that it
makes the process more open to the
public with greater
transparency just the posting of the
council meetings on the Gen Court
calendar increases Public Access and
some the state Commission on Aging
believes there's Great Value to the
State Health assessment and State Health
Improvement planning process we are
excited by the fourth thought that
included the chair of the state
Commission on Aging um and
representative from the New Hampshire
Alliance for healthy aging on the
advisory Council the years of infirmity
and of infirmity at the end of life can
be minimized by planned action to
address the determinance of Health and
Wellness based in our communities
greater alignment between local Regional
State Health Improvement plans will
result in a better New Hampshire and a
transparent process overseen by the
legislature made with deep engagement of
the incredibly diverse advisory Council
will ensure a good product thank you so
much would you take some questions
questions seeing none the chair
minahan I can't make it just yet no I
M Manan we can't hear you if you're
speaking I'm I'm sorry I did not hear
that uh we've got Miss minahan on and
she's unmuted however we're not able to
hear her speak okay is there anyone else
who has signed up to testify that has
yet I believe representative mapi has
her hand raised in the
attendees has asked to
testify uh she has her hand raised after
your question so I agree I think so
understand
please um good afternoon chairman and
the committee members thank you I had
signed up in support of this and I had
signed up to speak in the previous uh
yoga the author
therapy Bill
247 but it feels like listening to all
that
discussion seems like this is a very
worthy Council that's looking at
changing the course of or benefiting our
Granite status for health outcomes and
maybe this is the council that can look
at innovative ways of um
providing uh Wellness Health and
prevention and early prevention programs
in health care field and uh so I'm
thinking here saying oh this is where
the alternative therapies and
interventions should be looked at and
see how the efficacy and changing the
outcome of the health and well-being uh
would help the granite status that's all
thank you very
much is there anyone
else uh Mr chair chairman yes sir I I
would like to point out that there were
two PA minahan listed under attendees
and I think it's possible that Christina
promoted the wrong one so I would ask
one
are uh there's another one in the
attendees Christina and still listed in
the attendees with a hand
up that's the one that I uh Pro um that
I
trying
if there is no one else signed up to
speak then I close the hearing on House
Bill
157 and I open the hearing on House Bill
244 relative to the membership and
duties of the joint healthc care reform
oversight
Abramson uh and we will hear from
representative Abramson after a five
minute stretch and whatever break that
you signed up this bill I thought I had
but um extroverts asked a question give
you a second to answer my wife says know
introverts needs seven seconds well
technology needs more so uh I think I'm
doing better on that
but thank
C my other question is what the about
signing up because I thought sign
told I got aint out at the beginning and
my clerk got a print out everybody was
going to be
testified and then I discover more
people and in fact
somebody
representative in favorite and so I need
to know what actually the policy now is
because I thought it was
by well I I
[Music]
read and I'm not objecting together I
just want to be sure it's the same rules
for everybody
exactly you tell me what the rules are
to good to see
you know it's a shame that you're
leaving right now we're going to
Realtors I motion to we haven't even
subject
no I'm wrong it just says you're
given instructions that it had to be the
that
teres
have
thank
you
so to announce now that this bill is
going to be resch or do I have to just
minutes
it's
amazing
finally
okay
what
clerk He suggests
little I will February 8 one o' first
out of the gate in the
[Music]
to although I
uh the year that Phil Ryan was on
Judiciary when he' been out for year and
came back the year before he
speak if any Democrat spoke on thee that
every Republican has to speak
8:00 of not being in that situation were
thinking having
t-shirt
j09 2009
know you
know and so much of our work is
[Music]
was a
lot I can remember saying something to
another committee chair and he said well
you know of course you have to end by
3:00 and we saying oh no no don't do
that and he said well you know perhaps
you can shorten your lunch hour said we
haven't taken the lunch hour since the
we
and
you were on this
municip
did that and I when I was chair I
declined to sponsor a lot of bills so
that I could stay in the chair and the
only ones that we were allowed to chair
[Music]
Department okay we are back from
Recess uh Mr chair representative caner
care yes representative coner there yes
sorry this I'm advoca ating for a person
who waited to speak and was missed again
this time I they didn't call me I called
them I did call uh Paul inan she was
waiting apparently she still was not
recognized I went to the attendees I
watched as she raised her hand and
currently at the top of the attendees is
her name with her hand raised she waited
patiently to speak if you're willing to
reopen the last one for a couple of
minutes I just want to let you know she
is there you know I'm a bleeding heart
you know I'm a bleeding heart
you so I've given her the opportunity to
speak and she is not muted but we're
her paa do you know how to unmute
because you've been
promoted
God Mr chair that is the one that that
that is the hand that was up she has
promoted well I will speak she just
simply she did send written testimony so
we should all look at that thank you and
we're going to give Paul Paula minahan
um a a little token to carry around that
she can redeem anytime she wants to
speak to us yes and she also pointed out
she did this the exact same way that she
did when she testified before and she
can't understand why this time it didn't
work thank you such as the strangeness
of equipment okay
now we are going to uh I open the
hearing on House Bill 244 relative to
the membership and duties of the joint
Healthcare reform oversight committee
representative Abramson Prime sponsor
representative Abramson you are
speak can you folks hear me yes we
can uh all right uh my name is
representative Max Abramson I'm
representing uh the beautiful towns of
Hampton Hampton Falls and Seabrook um I
did introduce House Bill
244 um the effect of the bill is simply
that we take all of these Healthcare or
all these not Healthcare bills all these
health ideas that we come up with that
people come up with and uh simply allow
the joint Healthcare reform oversight
committee to take on those ideas uh so
when we have a bill like uh House Bill
157 um it certainly has a lot of good
ideas in it but there are um roughly 15%
of our
bills um and probably as many ideas that
members have relate to healthcare it
would be uh much more more time
effective if we asked members to go
through the joint Healthcare reform
oversight committee right now it means
regularly um it has a limited role this
bill would expand the membership by five
members appointed by the governor but um
some members of the House indicated that
they'd like uh maybe the speaker or the
chairman of Health and Human Services or
Commerce or or uh someone else to make
these appointments um the intent is when
members have ideas for getting cost down
or
removing other boards and committees
that they feel are uh no longer relevant
or if someone has an idea in General on
Healthcare that they they simply sit
down with this board and have a kind of
informal discussion there um I've had
quite a few ideas over the years I I did
uh take the ideas from the New Hampshire
Republican platform which have again a
lot of ideas that do translate into
legislation
um if you look at the list of
legislative service requests and do a
quick search the word uh medical appears
16 times the word Health appears 47
times um again more than 15% of the
bills coming through deal just with
health care direct primary care
physicians health savings accounts and
and and so forth and some of them are
good ideas and are worthy of legislation
but need a little more time than than
just two members kind of talking about
an idea and then putting in a bill um
each one of these bills can have two
three and four hour hearings um and
that's not the most
efficient process for doing it that that
does consume a lot of our time I'm on
Commerce we get about uh one healthc
care or one insurance or an insurance
mandate Bill something related to that
per day um I was on Municipal and County
before that and we got a few healthcare
related bills almost all the Committees
get a few health and uh medical
insurance related bills so um and it
does consume a lot of time on the floor
so my preference is to Simply take ask
members to take their ideas to the Joint
Healthcare reform oversight committee
which is an already existing committee
does move the report date up from
December 1st to October 1st every year
uh and the intent of that is if somebody
actually does have an idea for a bill
we've kind of heard the pros and cons um
they can decide whether or not uh
there's any value or Merit in it but
they can also make the uh amendments and
uh uh changes to language before they
come before uh one of our
committees um and of course when we have
experts come in and speak on these bills
um they deal with the the the draft
version of the bill not the amended
version um and some committee chairs
don't even allow amendments to be
discussed during the hearing uh what we
need is the kind of the final version of
the bill in front of us so we can see
the actual language a lot of members of
the House have stated that they would
much rather get the final language um
the the U someone from The Nurses
Association contacted me and suggested
that we specify a nurse and I said well
maybe we need two nurses on this um
board but we need people who have
experience in healthc care to just kind
of have a sitdown informal talk on ways
to get health care costs down and get
service up we spend about 24% of our
health care costs are spent just on
Administration um we spend about $60
billion a year just on defensive
medicine we spend about $90 billion a
year on pharmaceutical
advertising um we
spend um you know something like $500
billion doar a year is just spent on
overcharging of services so there's
there are a lot of ways to reduce costs
and there are a lot of ways to to uh to
improve service but it's it it it's
better to take those ideas and have a
little back and forth and draw on some
of the senior members
of the House and Senate who have some
experience um dealing with healthcare
related bills so that's the intent I of
course open to Amendment um and the
Bill's house
244 um and it just uh it it expands the
duties of that existing oversight
committee thank you representative will
thing
okay who's
first representative Shapiro and kerk
have their hands up representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking this
question in your presentation I heard
you talk about um consolidating
discussions about healthc care all
within this um within this Comm
committee and um but you did not
address the
specific um agenda for things to be
studied by this committee so on line 21
page one line
21 you say
that one of the explicit areas for study
will be recommending that Congress
repeal the federal patient protection
Affordable Care Act um um known as the
Affordable Care Act um I guess um I know
that you're saying that this group would
only study this issue but clearly among
the things to be studied there seems to
be a um an
agenda and I would ask you why you would
want a committee to explicitly be
studying doing away with the Affordable
Care Act when um between the marketplace
and expanded Med medicate there are
approximately 100,000 New Hampshire
residents who are currently insured
through the Affordable Care Act who
would then be without
insurance
um especially bad during covid but
really plenty bad anytime so I'm
wondering why this is part of your
bill so the bill uh doesn't consolidate
discussion essentially if you were to
bring that remark that you brought up to
this committee or if you were even
serving on that the oversight committee
at the time the chairman would rule you
out of order and you wouldn't be able to
to discuss that remark you wouldn't be
able to speak for or against or uh
discuss uh let's say some of the we had
what five or six proposed amendments to
the Medicaid expansion Bill he wouldn't
be able to discuss any of those so uh I
am certainly aware that there are a lot
of study committees before the house
that are actually advocating for some
kind of agenda this is simply saying
that the chair wouldn't rule someone out
of order that uh if you were sitting
before this committee or sitting around
the table you would not you would not be
ruled out of order you'd be able to
discuss the pros and
cons uh of that idea admittedly these um
10 points are essentially copy pasted
right out of the New Hampshire
Republican platform because these
specific ideas are discussed all the
time that we hear about them often
enough for delegates to introduce these
ideas and for members of the house to
introduce these ideas for consideration
because they get talked about all the
time and the place for the for the idea
um certainly the idea of repealing
Obamacare earning a part of Obamacare um
does get discussed a lot in the actual
details if somebody wanted to draft a
house
resolution um or simply you might
encourage them to Simply write a letter
to their member of Congress as a
legislator and ask them or even form an
ad hoc committee or something based on
your experience um but essentially what
the intent of the bill is to say here's
we have the joint Healthcare reform task
force we're expanding what you're
allowed to discuss while you're sitting
in with this uh committee um anything
related to healthcare you'd be open to
talk
about any further questions for the
representative
representative kerk and representative
Merchant have their hands up
representative
kerk uh thank you uh thank you
representative a for taking my question
I was a little curious about your data
sources and you've sort of alluded to
this in uh line 28 in the first page
where you again are talking about what
things could be studied increasing the
use of Market forces to improve health
care and lower costs and I was curious
other than a platform of a party what
your data source is for making that
assertion given the fact that we have an
abundance of data the demonstrates the
United States has the most free market
competitive Health Care system with the
highest costs and the worst outcomes
that study has really already been done
and so I'm curious what your data source
is for making that assertion that uh
free market would decrease cost and
increase
quality uh you wouldn't be allowed to
discuss that on on this task force as it
is I'm I'm trying to pass the bill to
allow you to say that however um I spoke
with my grandmother and I spoke with
some older folks about how health care
used to be back in the day um Health
Care today is in the United States the
US healthc care system is the most
regulated industry in the world it's the
most licensed industry in the world it's
the most litigated industry in the world
it is by far the most subsidized
industry in the world uh and so on and
so on and the most mandates uh we have
anywhere between 17 and 57 Insurance
mandates per state ever since the
McCaron Ferguson ACT first States um in
19 McCaron Ferguson Act of 1945 and then
uh the federal government in the mid
1960s began heavily stepping up
regulations and and subsidies and and
and programs and so forth so we've gone
from what I would consider a free market
healthare system in the 1950s and early
60s which cost about 5% of GDP to a a
system where you've got a 10 to 18e
approval process by the FDA you've got
of course the Obamacare mandates I think
was split into two different viewed as
two different pieces of legislation by
the US Supreme Court you've had and that
was a 1300 page Bill you've had um
countless other government intrusions of
course there's patent abuse which is a
federal issue um um and and so on and so
on and so on there's so much
protectionism in the Health Care system
that blocks competition and we have you
know a lot of bills coming through that
are designed to open up Health Care to
more choices and more competition not
just to get cost down as explicitly
stated in the bill but also to get
quality up um when I talk to people
about two-thirds of the things they're
talking about um with Healthcare are
getting cost down and then about
onethird of were talking about the
quality of the customer service and uh
if you've dealt with Comcast Comcast
kind of has a monopoly where I live and
they get to charge whatever they want
and whatever customer service you get
that's the customer service you get if
you remember the old days with AT&T it
had no
competition um if you didn't like the
customer service that you got or the
prices you were paying there was nowhere
else you could go because there wasn't
any competition back then representative
a uh Abramson uh we are starting to move
off the specific Bill itself so I'm
going to um suggest I have a followup
yes representative kerk yes but just
very quickly well you've been comparing
how the United States is now to what it
was maybe 50 years ago a few other
things have changed my question is have
you looked at the international data
that compares different Health Care
Systems and costs and outcomes because I
think that's more illustrative thank you
oh my gosh yes I've spent uh um quite a
few years on that Germany Japan
Singapore Hong Kong Switzerland all have
basically free market Health Care
Systems Germany has the bismar system um
they have private insurance with a lot
of competition in their in their
insurance market and those are all you
know the health savings accounts in
Singapore the public option in Singapore
um nearly all of those countries are
based primarily on private not just
private insurance but have far less
government involvement in their
Healthcare System system and those are
things that that are definitely should
be open game for an open discussion
rather than somebody just you know kind
of drafting a bill and putting it in and
Commerce I have down uh representative
Merchant to to ask a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
representative we just discussed for
quite a length time a bill
157 which was the State Health
Improvement plan
Council and would that be a better place
to place some of these things we talked
about modifying it to include health
care costs I think which is what you're
trying to drive at um would you be
amendable to modifying this to either
include it in Bill 157 or to uh somehow
bring it together I'm just concerned we
have multiple councils doing multiple
things but all trying to get to the same
point would you be amendable to amending
this to include it in that Council uh
yes as a matter of fact I spoke with the
prime sponsor of the last bill 157 I
spoke with representative Jess Edwards
about doing something very much like
that um and trying to merge it into one
bill so it would be uh a much much
simpler process and consume less time um
he opted not to do that he wanted to go
forward with his own bill he's welcome
to do that um but the this kind of open
discussion or what I like to call a
filter um where we try and filter our
healthc care bills and medical
legislation through uh through one kind
of informal group um however members of
the committee would like to do it I'm
I'm open to uh amending the
representative
the chair then
recognizes representative Tom P Loos Z
AJ help me with that
PLJ look like it's spell okay
representative Tom PL you are recognized
to
speak Ah that's what no means he's not
going to testify I got it
now is there anyone that I do not have
on my sheet who is recog who should be
case we adjourn the hearing we adjourn
uh what are we doing we adjourn the
hearing on Bill two
44 and we now open the
hearing way earlier than than I had
246 with
sponsor thank you Mr chairman
congratulations on your new position uh
members of the committee for the record
I'm representative renie Cushing from
Rockingham district 21 the town of
Hampton and I'm here to uh introduce
House Bill 246 um it may be somewhat
familiar to members of this committee uh
it's been the topic of providing uh a
new
Tool uh to Pro to protect vulnerable
adults uh by enabling them to seek
relief through a userfriendly and
affordable method to protect themselves
from abuse and financial exploitation um
is is not new it's been the subject of a
number of uh hearings a number of bills
and different iterations have come
before this committee I think we
recognize New Hampshire has one of the
uh fastest growing aging populations in
the country I think that the covid
pandemic has just made uh even clearer
the need for us to have in place
mechanisms to protect the most
vulnerable members of our society and
that's what um this legislation before
you will do um it it expands it's an
expansion of our current protective
order laws that will allow vulnerable
adults to retain a protective order
frees the assets of an abuser and
prohibit the abuser from taking the
victim's property um and in addition
defending to defending older adults the
protective orders would also Safeguard
people with disabilities from abuse uh
and exploitation um this bill is drafted
in large part uh by uh attorney sh
Steinberg for the uh senior law project
the New Hampshire legal assistance it's
been supported by a wide array of uh
organizations that are uh uh advocates
for protecting the most vulnerable
members of our society um I will close
this testimony recognizing we're late at
time um and simply urge the committee to
uh pass this
take any
questions thank you representative
Cushing and would you take questions
from the committee
absolutely although if I if I might I I
I will say that I I know that attorney
Steinberg is uh somewhere in the queue
here and she has an appointment that she
may be running up against so if it's
technical aspects of the bill I would
pass them on to her uh but I'll answer
any other questions I'll answer and for
the record uh um I have not been updated
to that
person to be testifying which doesn't
mean that's illegal it just means I'm
working off of an old data sheet so if I
overlook somebody uh that's the reason
for it and nothing further uh take or
will the attorney at your side take
questions from the committee yes do we
have
anybody I'll take
questions we have representative kerk
representative snow and representative
shapir
kerk thank you very much I I just have a
quick question um I've received about
150 emails in the last two or three days
about how this is going to confiscate
guns uh can you direct me to the segment
of this bill that talks about gun
confiscation thank you for your question
representative there is nothing in this
bill that mentioned firearms that it has
anything to do with Firearms I mean for
some reason this has been uh transformed
uh into a bill that was model Upon Our
uh in large part model on our um
domestic violence protective
legislation um and and become a Firearms
Bill although this nothing that mentions
firearms in it
uh you know I that CL I don't want to
speculate why this is become so but
right I've asked find it thank you yeah
I've I've asked anyone who screams at
and says this is a gun grabbing Bill to
please point to any part of the
legislation that relates to firearms and
I haven't found
snow you can press your space SP bar as
snow now is it working yes okay thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh
representative Cushing for taking my
question which is exactly the same
question that uh uh representative kerk
just asked because I read it very
thoroughly and could find absolutely no
reference to Firearms or confiscation
and I was reluctant to respond to
anybody until we had a a question but
I'm certainly not going to respond to
157 I think it was emails that I got I
don't know how many others got but
anyway question time testifying will
come at a later time if you have a
question you have a question yeah the
the yes thank
you I I I defer because I he I the
question I was going to ask is the same
thing that representative kerk just
pero I will withdraw my question because
it was the same as representative ker
and representative snow so we've done
the
hattick anyone else wishes to ask
question yes the chair recognizes
representative Fulon thank you Mr chair
um my question is and I'm coming back to
find this
[Music]
um I had it right here and then I got
distracted um basically it's where the
restraining is where the defendant is
not allowed to be at the pl place of
employment school or any specified Place
regularly I'm I'm sorry I'm having
difficulty hear ing the question I
apologize okay I'll come over okay sorry
about that um what I'm the area that I'm
talking about is um on page five it's
the area where they start listing the
restraining portions of the bill um and
it talks about uh the places that are
frequently uh
or uh
where the the um abused person the the
vulnerable adult May frequently U be
that the plaintiff may not be there um I
brought up as as I was looking at this I
thought you know we all live in some
pretty small
towns uh where we shop there's only one
store and there's only one gas station
and um the the parents might have if
it's a husband and wife the parents
might have somebody at the school and
they take turns picking them up is there
how do how do you get around those kinds
of situations where there's really not
an option to be somewhere else that
they're not there to abuse the person
they're there because it's the only
place they can go to get the things that
they need or to
um have a meeting with the school
teacher or
something um thank you for your question
as in our um other uh legisl other laws
that provide for uh you know a
restraining order or or an order
limiting to contact I think you know a a
judge uh listens to the evidence that's
placed before the before him or her and
makes an appropriate determination of
be any further questions for
representative
kushen
I would like to uh recognize attorney
Cheryl
Steinberg thank
Steinberg attorney Steinberg if you're
hand
here she
much can you hear me yes okay great
thank you thank you um Mr chairman um my
name is Cheryl Steinberg I am an
attorney with New Hampshire legal
assistance and I direct our senior law
project there um and for those of you
who are not familiar with New Hampshire
legal assistance assistance we're a
Statewide civil legal aid program that
serves lwi income and older people um
with basic needs um Elder Financial
exploitation is one of our priority
areas um for older adults um because it
is such a big problem I'm also here um
just you know representing the New
Hampshire lines for healthy aging which
is a uh group of over 300 stakeholders
that are focused on the health and
well-being of older Granite Staters and
I am here today to support House Bill
246 um as representative kushin pointed
out um this has been kind of a long road
on this bill it's I think this is the
fourth time I've testified before this
committee on it uh it had become has
unfortunately become very controversial
um the first draft of the bill did
include a provision to confiscate
Firearms which was um directly taken
from already already existing law that
for domestic violence victims and
stalking victims so the idea was is that
vulnerable adults should have the same
protections as those types of victims um
because it became so controversial and
there was so much opposition to having
firearms in the bill at all every um
reference to firearms and deadly weapons
or anything remotely like that have been
totally removed from the bill um and so
there is
absolutely nothing as was asked before
in the bill that talks about
confiscating firearms and you know it
should be noted that the the um the
draft that's that you're looking at
right now last year was a draft that was
also uh introduced by uh Senator Bradley
in the Senate because it was an agree to
version that we had thought we had
consensus on but um after it was
introduced last session um some people
started even though again no firearms no
deadly weapons the issue now apparently
is um due process violations um that
they feel that the bill violates due
process rights because um there is the
ability to issue orders um without
having a full-blown evidentiary hearing
it' be a temporary order and then the um
the person who had the uh petition filed
against them would have the right to a
full hearing to have a final order
issued
um so it's hard for me to all I can say
about it is and I should also before
because I don't know who else is going
to testify there was also a lot of talk
and allegations that this bill allows
for telephonic hearings um to take away
you know people's rights and um and with
no recourse and I just want to emphasize
again that that is absolutely not true
just like with the domestic violence um
protective orders and stalking there is
the ability to have a telephonic
conference if the only when the court is
not in session and the the any orders
that are issued as a result of a
telephonic hearing are only good until
the next the end of the next open
business day of the court so they
automatically expire at that point so
they do not continue they are very very
temporary so I just wanted to get that
out of the way I I just want to once
again say and Senator sry representative
Kush already mentioned this that I mean
this bill really is needed more than
ever in my opinion um we you already
heard from for example Rebecca sky from
the state Commission on Aging we're the
second oldest um state in the country
and we're only getting older um
Financial exploitation is a huge problem
um across the country and New Hampshire
is no exception and the older we get the
only bigger the problem is going to get
um and already there's it's estimated
there's a big range anywhere between 2.9
to 36.5 billion dollar is stolen
annually from older adults um again we
don't have this kind of so the idea
behind this is that um because there
isn't anything in place right now and a
quick way to actually get people the
relief they need if they're getting
financially exploited or if I should say
being physically abused as well because
that does happen usually Financial abuse
goes hand in hand with other kinds of
physical abuse so it it's supposed to be
for all of it um but it is a way to get
this quick relief that is not currently
available um in our state and unless
again you're a domestic violence victim
or a stalking victim so um I you know
some of the relief that that would be
available is freezing the assets of an
abuser prohibiting the abuser for taking
and converting property um and and and
other things such as is that or it could
just be obviously just keeping the
person away if if the perpetrator is
somehow posing some kind of other risk
to them um I I would say that sorry
sure representative Marsh and
representative Shapiro have their hands
up representative
Marsh uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Miss Steinberg for testifying before
our committee
uh I have on my computer screen here
side by side versions of House Bill 1660
from last year which the governor V2 on
July 28th 2020 and this current bill
House Bill 246 and I see some formating
changes which make it a little bit hard
to compare the two of them but the only
difference I see is the difference in
the effective date am I correct about
that or could you please walk me through
the differences between the two bills no
you're absolutely correct I mean 1660
and the bill and I don't remember the
number I think it was Senate Bill 677
maybe that was introduced last session
they were ended up being absolutely
identical um so there is no difference
um because there was some amendments
made but they're exactly the same I mean
I should also point out that the the
governor's veto message was you know I I
would say not accurate and when they
said that the Coalition didn't support
it that's totally not true as well the
Coalition this this bill was a result of
it negotiations with the Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence and
there's specific Provisions in there
that we agreed to with the language in
there that that is in is in this bill
and it was in the last bill so I I again
I I there the thing that's been
frustrating is there's really no logic
to a lot of
the in my opinion the objections and and
a lot of the things that say that people
say that are wrong with it just it just
isn't true it isn't reflected in the
bill I mean so I just urge you to
actually read the bill
because there's the things that are
being claimed that are in there are not
in there that's all I can say I I I
thank you for that yeah representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um as you
alluded to the concern about
confiscation of firearms seems to have
morphed into um concerns about due
process so could you say could you say
specifically um the time frame how much
time it would be before a temporary
order
um is made um and in between when um the
defendant would actually be allowed a
hearing what is the time I I believe so
I believe it's three business days it
was actually it was actually abbreviated
from what the domestic violence statute
provides because there was concerns
right raised about that so I believe um
I believe it's within three business
hearing um and I can double check that
if you want but it it's it's I believe
that's what it was it was two to three
business days follow up yeah yes follow
up um so as far as you know it's at most
three days yeah
second thought I have second question I
have is I'm kind of concerned about that
we're um on the defense here and talking
about why all the reasons why this is a
bad Bill are not accurate um so to move
towards why this is a good bill um are
you or maybe somebody who comes after
you able to give an example of the kind
of exploitation the kind of abuse that
we're trying to fend off with this Bill
certainly yeah yeah I know I'm sorry I
know I did start out in the defense but
I just given the history of what's going
on with this bill I just kind of knew it
was probably coming I can give you
plenty of examples um I'll give you one
that actually I would tell you a that
former Senator Bob K gave at a hearing
that involves his brother so he he he
made it public so this would be one
example I I think a very good example he
he is a gentleman who is older um he has
a um a disabled 13-year-old son with
autism he um had this stepson living in
his house it was a stepson by marriage
um obviously but they were he was no
longer even married so they were
divorced but the stepson was living in
the house with him and his 13-year-old
son and he was always he never
contributed anything to the household
expenses he didn't pay rent he didn't
buy the food um and he was also um I
think had substance abuse issues and
could be you know very verbally um um
abusive and and even physically abusive
so at one point um the gentleman went
into the hospital and he and he learned
that this person the stepson had red
havoc in the house and had this party he
was making all kinds of problems and so
when he got out of the hospital he asked
him to leave he say you can't live here
anymore the he refused um and he became
um physically abusive the gentleman
tried to go and file a 173b a domestic
violence restraining order they told him
sorry you don't qualify and and he
didn't under the statute he didn't meet
the criteria um so um then they told him
go to the police the police will issue a
no trespass order the police told him
sorry we can't help you um because you
know it's not clear that he's a
trespasser because he has been living
here finally we got involved and I was
able with some effort to get the um I
believe I got you finally finally got
the police to issue a node
trespass um order to get him out of
there and he did finally leave but it
you know it was a lot of work and we had
to get involved so I mean I think that's
one good example I I'll give another
very quickly an example of of another
common situation where um you know we
have these adult parents who give their
homes to their adult children free and
clear adult parents sorry parents that
give to their adult children free and
clear and something happens and next
thing you know that the the children are
saying sorry you we you can't live here
anymore we can't afford it or no they
the house is getting foreclosed down
because even though it didn't have a
mortgage when you gave it to me we've
we've got mortgage it up to the hill we
can't make the payments so you got to
get out so I mean we had a a case like
that where the the um the children had
put the house on the market and my 80
you know four year old client had
nowhere to go and she was looking for an
apartment she didn't know what to do and
the only way to really stop this sale
from going forward was to go to Superior
Court and file a petition and that's
very complicated and she couldn't do
that herself I mean so we were luckily
she was able to connect with us and we
um got you know we got a petition filed
and got the sales stop but you know but
for that it wouldn't happen you know and
and so this having this type of relief
available would actually allow her
someone like her just to fill out a
simple form and get the relief
immediately without having to worry
about all kinds of complicated petitions
in Superior Court and Hope You Know M
and hopefully connecting with New
Hampshire legal assistance for
help does that help thank
yes representative
kushman thank you Mr
chairman I'm just looking very closely
and um I see under temporary relief it
gives upon showing of immediate and
present danger of abuse exploitation
neglect the court may enter temporary
order um and that they will be effective
until the close of the next regular
Court business
day then they go back to the court where
the plaintiff
resides
um and they do not have to make actual
notice to the
defendant yes um the hearing shall be
held no less than two business days and
no more than three days after request is
received by the clerk um but then it
says the orders may include and then it
lists um you know a one two 3 four five
I page five I'm sorry six of page five
it says other relief including but not
limited to so there is room there uh
even though the the petitioner may not
ask the court to confiscate Firearms if
in their report um they make
mention um of firearms existing in the
home a judge could then make an order
because they're not limited by this bill
correct um I would say I I would I I
guess I would defer to the the judicial
branch to answer that question and how
they would interpret it I would say that
I have heard um the judicial branch say
in the district court they don't feel
they have the ability to um place a
broad interpretation on these kinds of
laws so that unless it's explicitly
written in there they they they're
chairman yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman um I don't if this
goes to someone on the committee but
helped me understand last year this bill
appears to be vetted by this committee
um and passed the committee went on to
the house and get passed to the to the
Senate then beo by the governor was it a
standalone Bill Governor vetoed or was
it part of an Omnibus package that the
governor veto I'm trying to track down
why it was a it was a standalone Bill he
it where one find
that um I'm happy to um send it to you
email thank
Kelsey yes thank you Mr chairman um I
have a question what specific due
process protections are in this bill and
does this meet all the Constitutional
requirements of not taking property
prior to being found guilty in a court
of law with an attorney
present okay
well okay it it it absolutely complies
with due process the due process is is
that they that the defendant is getting
notice of this petition being filed and
the right to appeal to to request a
hearing um yes there is some ability for
the court to issue some orders before
there is a full-blown hearing but that
is consistent with due process has been
upheld by the court as totally
consistent with complying with due
process requirements so it's no
different than what happens in the
context of a domestic violence
protective order um situation or a
stalking situation or other situations
there is the ability to
temporarily um make orders and
potentially deprive people of certain
property or whatever right you want to
call it before there's a full-blown
evidentiary hearing in the court so
that's all I can tell you it's it's it's
very it's settled law
um I I understand that some people don't
like it but it's settled law there
really is no controversy about it
whatsoever thank
question oh can you hear me y okay thank
you
every time I have to do this differently
thank you Mr chairman when the temporary
order is given there is
a next court date or at least in three
days there has to be an evidential re
hearing does the defendant have to
request that evidentiary hearing or does
it automatically occur on the next
day for the expedited hearing I believe
they have to request it otherwise it'll
be scheduled within 30
days thank
kofalt yes uh so so I believe uh that
the primary
sponsor mentioned that this has been uh
this this has been covered several times
and I guess I would go back to two years
ago I think the the word Firearms was
mentioned close to 20 times in that bill
so for those who have um questions as to
why this might be interpreted as a a
concern by Second Amendment Advocates I
I'm going to say that that that's why
having removed those references to
Firearms uh is is potentially a step in
the right
direction uh my my question for the the
primary sponsor and for attorney
Steinberg is whether you believe it
would be acceptable if this bill were
modified to uh strictly prohibit uh the
seizure of firearms or orders to
surrender
Firearms um would would that be uh
acceptable within uh within this bill
would that be acceptable to you uh I
mean I I guess um I mean honestly this
was never about Firearms it was again
just something that was modeled on an
already existing statute I mean I do
have some problems with I mean obviously
if it's strictly Financial exploitation
and there's really no physical violence
I I really having the the guns are
relevant as far as I'm concerned so yes
you know if there's really some physical
you know if we're really talking about
someone that's being physically abused
and there's been a weapon involved I
that's where I guess I I would maybe
have some concerns about just making a
Flatout prohibition under any
circumstances like to have the court to
have some discretion but so F follow up
to that question wouldn't actually two
follow-ups I'll ask them together
wouldn't that be wouldn't that latter
scenario be covered under existing
uh domestic violence scenarios number
one no it wouldn't no it wouldn't can
you can you elaborate on that please
well because I mean unless the
vulnerable adult is also a domestic
violence victim within the meaning of
the RSA
173b then they they won't they aren't
entitled to that
relief um so you know there are the
people were Tau this is the whole thing
the people we're talking about are not
really domestic violence victims they're
are people that are um
vulnerable adults that a lot of times
what it is is the abuse takes place by
caregivers and um it could be hired
caregivers it could be I mean it could
be a family member um but not
necessarily living with them so there's
certain requirements under 173b about
they need to be a household member and
they need to be or an intimate partner
and I I don't know all the criteria of
the top of my head but the whole idea is
it's supposed to be for people that
don't meet that criteria and that's why
we need the bill is because there's this
group of people that aren't covered that
are
vulnerable and need the
help okay so that would potentially
indicate some some need for revisions to
the domestic violence uh statute I I I
heard you say attorney Steinberg that
this is really primarily about financial
abuse or financial concerns and so I my
my follow-up question is why not then
limit it to Financial abuse so that uh
so that we can um address people's
concerns and and uh and and get
something through that could protect
Elders from that Financial abuse yeah
well as I think I did say it it isn't I
mean that that is I I will say I mean
yes in all fairness Financial
exploitation is the biggest part of the
issue but there is also physical abuse
and neglect that takes place for these
individuals and the first example I gave
you the story um first story I gave you
involves someone who is being physically
abused not you know I guess he was being
he was being financially exploited as
well and he's someone that wouldn't be
able to get relief under
173b so I I mean I I guess the thing is
this I don't understand why
um people in this population shouldn't
have the same kinds of protections that
other people do and I I get that you
know it makes it easier to say it's just
Financial exploitation and therefore we
can prohibit the guns and but again
there's nothing in here now that's going
to allow for the confiscation of weapons
so I but you know I I don't know what to
do at this point because I do think this
is unfortunately um I it's just become
so politicized and now it you know
people feel it's this threat against
Firearms um and getting taken away and
it just isn't the case in my opinion
this bill would not do that and isn't
what it's intended to do and we got rid
of all the references they're all
gone
so I have a follow-up question is in the
scenario you described earlier where
there was actual physical abuse
happening um if that were were not to
fall under the domestic violence uh
statute would it not be covered under
criminal threatening and assault it
would but that's not going to get him
immediate release I mean you know maybe
he'll may it doesn't provide the same
kind of protection I mean the criminal
statute will will potentially punish the
offender but it it doesn't automatically
doesn't provide any mechanism for this
victim to automatically get relief to
get the person away from him and you
know I criminal investigations I mean it
isn't my area but I I don't know that
it's necessarily true that the person's
going to be immediately charged with a
crime and immediately go before the
court and have any kind of you know
action taken so um it's a different it's
it know the part of this whole you know
the other thing I should emphasize is
the whole idea behind this is to try to
hopefully prevent bad things from
happening you know and not have to react
after the bad thing has happened which
is what the criminal statutes do so I
mean we're trying to minimize harm and
trying to give victims a tool that they
can use to protect
themselves and you know while the
criminal statutes are very important and
I would say the the financial
exploitation criminal statute that we
helped put into place several years ago
has been a really great tool um that I'm
very happy is there it's it isn't enough
you know it it doesn't provide this
other type of relief for the victims you
know I
mean the know again the example again
I'll use the a financial example
someone's you know someone's stealing a
victim's money um okay great they get
charged after all the money is gone this
would be a way to go to court quicker
get an immediate order to stop the
bleeding so that it it so they won't
become destitute so that that's kind
part of the idea too so um it's a pre
it's really supposed to be preventative
in nature and try to minimize harm as
much as possible on victims thank you
representative fome your next on my list
and um much has been said much has been
said several times I'm going to ask both
the question respondents to uh focus on
new material and not repetition please
representative Fon thank you Mr chair um
thanks I'm actually moving very far away
from that and you probably can answer my
question because it's might be covered
in other law but as I was looking at
this and uh the um person may have the
uh have to sign this worksheet and say
I'm freely choosing to file this
petition and on and on um when I think
of vulnerable adults I'm also thinking
of of adults that may have a
developmental
disability which would not make them a
great candidate for making this kind of
a decision and the person who has been
abusing them may have been
their legal guardian or
trustee and I'm sure that they can come
in quickly and I'm assuming get rid of
that person in a totally different way
but how then do you what would it look
like
if what would it look like for that that
adult who has
been not necessarily physically abused
but financially or emotionally
abused um what what is that process
going to look like with those type of of
vulnerabilities okay so you I was just
so to make sure you want to know about
the worksheet in particular or um I
could oh think about the fact
that um the worksheet U made me think
about the a vulnerable adults yes
disabled come in then and me immediately
does the court step in and provide them
with a
temporary Garden okay yeah let me okay a
lot of things to unpack there so the
worksheet was a compromise that we
worked out with the courts and the
domestic violence Coalition because the
domestic violence Coalition was
concerned with that that this bill
because all the ability to confiscate
Firearms was taken away that there could
be people um that were domestic violence
victims that would choose to for
whatever reason apply for this relief
under the vulnerable adult statute
versus a domestic violence statute would
be giving up their rights to get their
firearms confiscated no the the the vi
uh perpetrators Firearms confiscated so
we worked that out with the worksheet so
that the victim could work through and
understand that if they applied for
Relief under this
particular law that they would not be
able to add that the court would not
have the ability to issue an order to
confiscate the perpetrators Firearms the
defendants Firearms so I I as far as yes
so so that's why that's in there it was
not in there originally so that's number
one number two yes I understand what
you're saying there are there very well
could be some people that might have
some challenges maybe understanding just
even how to complete a petition um I
would say one of the things that's in
the bill is that someone from the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services an adult
protective worker with the victim's
permission can help them complete the
form so that's one way they can get help
um the other way is hopefully actually
we put this that's why is that the
information in that worksheet is in
there too is that they can contact
either the Coalition or New Hampshire
legal assistance for help too um and
then we would hope to get them connected
somehow um to the help they need it is
it isn't perfect I I but it's one of
those things that I I don't you know we
try to do the best we can to see make
sure that people um understand what
they're doing and can get the relief
they need but um yeah oh and I should
also point out there is a provision in
the bill that allows the court to
appoint a guarding Ed item if the plaint
if really if the victim really is unable
to you know there's concerns about them
being able to make their own decisions
so that's in the bill as well thank you
can you just point that out for me in
okay
okay okay um before I call the next uh
questioner just to announce um we've got
several more questions from the
committee and we have not gotten to
anyone who signed up to testify yet and
I'm now informed there's 11 more so I am
going to um adjourn today's meeting at
4:30 and res schedule a continuation of
this hearing at 1:00 on
Monday February 8th so until 4:30 and
then it will be continued February 8th
which is an assigned date for this
committee to meet at
1M representative
Weber uh my question was answered in the
course of an answer already given thank
Nelson because of a time element I'll
withraw my question for now
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman um not
being an attorney I don't know where I'm
going in this I may put myself into a
bucket of what but I'm looking at this
whole issue of abuse and I looked at RSA
173 B1
definitions is it possible to include
economic safety which is basically
Financial exploitation that domestic
violence and includes that definition
economic safety and that that that would
take care of the
issue um well it certainly 173b could be
amended to do that but again the thing
with the domestic violence statute is
that the people that actually are
eligible for the relief are different
than the people contemplated in this
bill who are vulnerable
adults so um domestic violence victims
have one
definition and vulnerable adults have a
different definition and so so and and
sometimes there could be an overlap but
really for the most part they're two
distinct types of
groups thank
attorney thank you counselor for your
testimony and for your help in
explaining things no problem thank you I
I I hope I did sign up just so you know
I mean I know you I'm sorry if you
didn't see my name but I I did sign up
earlier today just so you
know think I was being presumptuous here
um so I don't know what happened but
thank you very much and I'm happy to if
anybody wants to ask me any other
questions after the hearing I'm happy to
SH now rep recognizes representative
John
Bert
I think I'm
unmuted I think you are too great uh
thank you uh Mr chairman and fine
committee members I am representative
John Bert and I represent gost toown
wear and Deen in District 39 in
Hillsboro County uh Mr chairman and
committee members
this bill has not
changed this bill is a gun grab Bill and
let me explain
why if you go let me find it again I
apologize oh it's right here if you go
to section
173d colon 3 judici you know the um
courts and
venue and it's the first line if you
look at 173 D3 in the bill the district
division in the Judiciary Branch Family
Division of the Circuit Court shall have
current uh Judiciary you know if I can
say that word right I apologize over all
proceeding what page in line is this do
you know I'm looking online I think it's
on page one or possibly two but I'm
looking online you know I Mr chairman it
it is uh page two lines 19 and 20 thank
you thank you whoever said
that and uh but it says the district you
know the courts have control over this
over all proceedings under this chapter
now what that
means is is bottom line what it means
is judges have the authority to remove
guns out of any
home in this type of a situation now if
they think it's a abuse or any other
crime like that they are going to say
remove the guns because if one shooting
happens which you know chances are it w
but if one
did it would not look good in the court
system so that's why they're going to do
that so this bill really does have a lot
of you know flaws in that area now
there's a lot of speakers and I want to
get to them so I just want to say I
oppose this bill and Mr chairman and
committee
members you know the bill is the same as
last year this is a gun grab bill in my
eyes so please oppose this and let's
move on to uh better bills and um get
those passed thank you Mr chairman and
have a good day representative I have a
question I'm convincible but I need to
be convinced yes are there other places
in this bill that irrespective of guns
now you would say is a bad
Bill uh there is and there are a couple
speakers behind me that will fill you in
on those um because I don't have the
notes right in front of me to point to
that section so I apologize um I just
came you know with this one particular
area that I wanted to point out but
there are other areas that uh other
people that are going to speak hopefully
we can get them all in before 4:30 and
that's why I want to make my
testimony we've got 11 people in the
addition to the names I've already been
sent we'll keep at it all right thank
you Mr chairman and hopefully we can get
everybody to speak because hopefully if
you only have one or two left over by
4:30 then you know hopefully you'll hear
them because it would be a pain to
reopen right now the chair recognizes
Ryan Donley who is from Granite State
independent living and wishes to testify
bill
can you hear me there he
is all right very good thank you again
for the record my name is Ryan doy and I
am speaking to you today represent
presen ing Granite State Independent
Living GSI is a Statewide nonprofit
organization that Advocates and provides
services for seniors and people with
disabilities who wish to remain
independent in their homes and
communities I am speaking to you today
in support of HB
246 I myself am a person with a severe
physical disability I live with a
condition
called osteogenesis in perfecta my bones
break and Fracture easily I am unable to
walk and I am also short in stature I
value my Independence which includes
driving my own van holding a job and
being a part of my
community however because of this
because of my condition I rely on others
for my personal day-to-day
care there is a great deal of trust that
comes in taking someone on to provide
that day-to-day care unfortunately there
can be times when that trust is broken I
myself was once a victim of serious
emotional abuse and an instance of
unwanted physical contact at the hands
of a living caregiver it was a traumatic
painful and frightening ordeal for me
and for my
family as it stands right now even for
vulnerable adults such as myself the
definition of abuse can prove to be
narrow because the nature of the abuse
I've subjected to was primarily
emotional I was successful in receiving
only a temporary protective order
against my former caregiver while my
personal situation was ultimately
resolved in a satisfactory manner I wish
could have been I wish more could have
been done at the beginning of my
ordeal that is precisely where this bill
comes into why for people with
disabilities like myself as well as
other vulnerable adults HB 246
reasonably broadens the definition of
abuse this will allow law to protect
those individuals who cannot protect
themselves with this in mind I hope the
members of this committee will choose to
support hb2
246 thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you today and for all of
the hard hard work you perform on behalf
of all New Hampshire thank you thank you
Mr
Silber
do we have representative silur I'm
unsure if he might be calling in or not
because I don't see him in the list but
let me keep
looking
representative silver would you raise
here if you did call in um you can press
unmute all right let me see if I can
give him a call and if you um and
perhaps you can move on to the second
person and I'll follow back up all right
leonan
I do not see him
simin
I don't see a j simpin either the chair
CH
go uh can you hear me Mr chairman can
you hear me I rice thank you uh good
afternoon um Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Alan Rice and I am a resident of Bedford
New Hampshire and I'm here today as the
New Hampshire state director of Gun
Owners of America um we're a National
Organization with close to two million
individual members and we are opposed to
House Bill
246 um earlier this morning I I emailed
my uh pre-written testimony to the
committee I hope you all received it um
and I wanted to to use my time to touch
on and rebut um some of the points that
um the prime sponsor made as well as one
of the other uh
Witnesses um they are correct in that
house bill 246 does not include the word
firearm and it does not include the term
confiscation um but it doesn't need to
include those
terms um the judge can order
confiscation um page six on line three
uh excuse me page six line three talks
about it's not limited to what's in
what's in this bill the judge can order
anything they want um nothing prohibits
gun
confiscation um it
it's not specifically allowed but it's
clearly not prohibited and we've seen
judges um in domestic violence cases you
know when there wasn't violence there
was just some some
verbalization um ordering all kinds of
stuff um so to say this isn't a gun grab
is is simply not correct um the the
other reason this is a gun grab is
because when you involve parents and
children they fit fit the definition in
both state and federal law of those
protected under the domestic violence
statutes and if a person becomes subject
to a permanent order that is issued
under house bill
246 that permanent order would in fact
trigger the federal domestic violence
gun ban so this is a gun grab
um even though the Ward's firearm have
been removed from the bill um even
though Miss Steinberg you know she
sugarcoated it and she used a lot of
fancy legal words to talk about it a
telephonic hearing means no due process
it means the judge only hears from one
party and the other party who's being
accused possibly falsely is not provided
with an opportunity to address the court
and say hey wait a second th this is
what really going on and and this is why
you shouldn't issue this order um we
realize that there's um short period of
time between the temporary order and a
final order and an extra hearing but you
know what we've seen these hearings get
extended especially in the last year
with with the China virus um all kind of
excuses have been used not to convene
courts not to have hearings now you have
a person subject to a temporary hearing
possibly losing their firearm sitting in
in legal Mumbo legal
limbo um they say this is needed I I I
referenced some rsas in my testimony 631
colon 8 n and 10 um those carry felony
penalties
for criminal neglect Financial
exploitation
um both the elderly the disabled the
impaired um they're B A and B felonies
so we're looking at serious offenses in
the current law and as we see this bill
the the only reason really to push it is
for another you know backdoor gun grab
um I I had in my notes I wanted to
address you know Miss Steinberg said you
know the the parents deed the home to
their children the children want to sell
the home and the parents kicked out and
they don't have any relief it it sounds
horrible you know a senior citizen you
know living out on the street and being
homeless but is that a proper function
of government to
intervene when they deed the home now
the child owns the home and they're
selling their own property I'm not sure
that's a crime and then I want to Circle
back to when they get in order not to do
guns they talked about negotiation
I don't know about other Firearms
organizations but Gun Owners of America
we've been very active in New Hampshire
for many years we weren't invited to
participate and it it looks to me
like the negotiations were extremely
one-sided um Miss Steinberg um obviously
I mean she has a a role to play um
representative Kush has been pushing
this this similar language since 2018
maybe even longer um he obviously had
you know a legislative agenda um but we
weren't invited you know to participate
in those
negotiations um and I I also want to
bring up two points about the bill
there's an indefinite look back in time
so someone can allege something happened
decades ago and the court can take it
into consideration when issuing such an
order um that's really dangerous um our
criminal codes have statutes of
limitations um in some cases for
misdemeanors it's as little as like a
year but this provides an indefinite
look back um pretty much anyone can
request such an
order um and yes the defendant can
demand a hearing at their own expense
and our attorneys tell me such a hearing
could run into the you know tens of
thousands of dollars um rather than
going on and and taking up more of the
committee's valuable time um I would ask
you to vote house bill 46 inexpedient to
legislate um our strongest points are in
my written testimony um but I'm happy to
entertain any questions uh that the
members may have and I thank you any
rice
Newman
I do not see Mr Newman thank
penik yes speaking now I'm Erin Pig I
live in Hollis New Hampshire um I uh
come here in opposition to House Bill
246 for a variety of
reasons I'm going to avoid redundancy in
the interest of time right but there's
uh there there is a significant La lack
of specificity on what property could be
seized in this bill which is part of the
problem that the Firearms constituents
are are bringing up it's specific on
pets for example but it's not specific
on what could be excluded from
confiscation if uh an order was
issued um it this this bill is
as was said earlier I think by uh by
Miss Steinberg this is the third or
fourth time this bill has been
surfaced and it's just a rewrite of what
has been surfaced before uh it's export
a no do process confiscation it violates
the 1 fourth 10th and 14th Amendment of
our constitution that's the US
Constitution and also similar ones uh
for New Hampshire uh another problem
have I read through the whole bill twice
and it it def it it defines the subject
of any uh in any issued order as a
defendant that subject has not been
accused of a crime or committed a crime
so they're not a
defendant right they're a subject of the
court order and that that needs to be
changed it's just it's just not the way
it's written is just it's just so
ambiguous that it's not valid a good law
needs to be precise it needs to be
enforcable this one is not the way it's
l written and I know that we've been
through several times with this this
whole thing started with a Firearms
confiscation um clause in it and yes I
agree that the the there's no word
firearms in this current vers of it
right but it's morph now to the current
version which is ambiguous in terms of
what can be
confiscated I think they either Veil
that
threat right or it's just because of
poor language in the bill but we should
be more precise in that the citizens of
New Hampshire deserve better than
that you know I was taking notes here as
Miss Steinberg was talking she said it's
not EXP explicitly written in there well
no it's not but that's the problem
that's exactly the problem it's not
explicitly written in there be explicit
about what the property is that can be
confiscated if one of these orders is
issued against
someone there's nothing in here about
the condition of the property that is
confiscated would be in once it is
returned to you if it
is so so so some people have a
invested sorry my phone is ringing in
their firearms and other
things uh and so so we don't want them
to be returned as as trash because they
were not stored
properly uh it so so as it's written it
does allow Firearms confiscation because
it's ambiguous about what can be
confiscated and what cannot uh I I think
the whole concept of calling the person
a
defendant in the bill when they have not
been accused of or charged with a crime
is
wrong and I thank you Mr chairman for my
time thank you Mr penich for your
testimony uh it's almost 4:30 and I have
only one more person whose name is on
the testify list from this morning and
I'm going to call on that person and
then I'm going to join the um adjourn
the meeting and again we will resume uh
at 1:00 on Monday February 8th and those
who are signed up to testify will be
given time to do so the one person
remaining on my list is representative
Lucy
Weber oh I only signed up in case
representative Cushing could not be
but you get two minutes I've got two
minutes and I'm going to take my two
minutes
because and I'm going to take my two
profile my name is Lucy Weber I
represent Chester one which is the um
cheser County towns of walpo Westminster
Chesterfield and
Hinsdale in a prior life I was an elder
law
attorney I started out doing Wills
trusts and Estates and I progressed to
what was then an emerging field of elder
law when it suddenly occurred to
somebody that our older citizens have
problems that emerge particularly with
respect to their property but other
things as well before they're dead that
need to be
addressed and one of them is of
elderly abuse and
exploitation and I cannot tell you in my
practice which was a long time ago how
pervasive it is and what happens is
somebody gains the trust of a failing
Elder and they either convert all their
property from the elders use to their
own use so I had a case for example
where an elderly lady with significant
assets well over a million dollars which
in
1985 was a lot of money she gave her
nephew a power of
attorney and eventually the nursing home
in which she resided filed with the
court and said said we haven't been paid
in a year can we get a guardianship of
this lady and I as one of my very first
um cases was appointed the
guardian when I arrived on the
scene the money was
gone the woman was
unpaid had she not had one piece of real
estate and had the nursing home not been
willing to take a lean against
that she would have become a charge on
the state and all of us would have been
paying for her nursing home
bills had somebody been able to
intervene at the beginning with a
protective order that stopped the nephew
from having the power of
attorney and stopped stop him from
draining her
assets everybody including the lady and
society would be in a better
position Domestic Relations orders don't
work that nephew was her nephew he was
living in another state he was not
covered by The Domestic Relations
protective orders so there are a lot of
cases where the Domestic Relations
protective orders don't
guardianship
statutes
take somewhere between 6 12 I don't know
how many weeks to get a guardianship in
place that is from my old experience so
it may be a different amount of time in
New Hampshire but they're not easy you
have to get an expert to testify that
the Elder needs a guardian it's a long
process and as you know assets can be
taken during that process so the
guardianship process doesn't help us
here the criminal statutes can punish
somebody for having done this deed but
they don't make the Elder whole and they
don't prevent either the financial abuse
or the physical abuse or the emotional
abuse from going on and on and on I mean
if
somebody getss arrested and they bail
themselves out and they come back what
what do you do these are cases in which
helpful I'm not going to go Point by
Point by all the things that I think are
incorrect about the testimony we've
heard because it's late and you heard
both sides a bit and I can talk about
that in an executive
session but what I ask you to consider
from the bottom of my heart is why do
our vulnerable adults not have at least
as much
protection as the people who are abusing
them that is the purpose of this
legislation and if the law s on one side
or
another I would hope that the law
s on the side
of protecting the vulnerable adult and
possibly overstepping on the rights of
their
abuser um and with that I end my
testimony and I will take no questions
and I thank the committee very much for
your attention and you did it in two
minutes thank you
I
think
chairman uh you stated we would take up
again February 1 at one o'clock and yet
in my printed calendar it says 900 a.m.
no no this hearing on this bill okay
gotcha 38 at 1 all of us will gather
again at 9:00 am on February 1 okay
thank you very much Mr
everybody bye have a great week thank
you you too Jerry take care everybody Mr
chairman what is the time on the
[Music]